We will not begin today with the report of the superintendent because we're going to have a ceremony before lunch where the superintendent will be able to speak and we'll also have even a brief film clip of what he's accomplished and how we've proceeded.
So we'll hold on that.
And second, I would like to announce this is Terry Burns' last meeting.
Would Terry here?
Not here yet, okay.
And she has announced her retirement at the end of the year.
She has a terrific amount of experience at the California School Boards Association, the State Senate, and she was Deputy Superintendent of the California Department of Education under Delaine Easton.
And Terry was a big help on our legislation and the state system of support.
And so we wish her well in her retirement.
I have usual announcements on the agenda.
We have two items, 11 and 12, regarding the CASP regulations.
They have been withdrawn by the California Department of Education.
We have three addendums, the student member recommendations for finalists by our Board Screening Committee, reports from the 2018 Student Advisory Board on Education, which we'll hear later, and the State Board of Education Screening Committee recommendation for appointments to our Advisory Commission.
That's item 20 later in our agenda.
There are two public hearings, item 6 and item 19, to be completed at the end of the board meeting.
The consent calendars, there's a handout on the table in the lobby listing the regular consent items, items 10 and 13 through 18, and waiver items, waiver 1 through waiver 9.
The proposed regular consent items are again 10 and then 13 through 18 and in that order of taking them up.
The board members, any of you wishing to remove
proposed consent calendars and please notify the executive director about your interest in that.
And we'll talk about the waiver consent items and the regular consent items tomorrow afternoon if board members wish to question those items being on the consent calendar.
I want to remind the audience that if you're going to address the board, sign in at the table just outside the room.
We'll have one minute per speaker with the exception of the public hearing with publishers.
We'll have two minutes when we do the science adoption.
If anyone wishes to submit materials, please put 25 copies in the hands of Amy Bobico, who is sitting there at the front desk on my right.
Please identify yourself if you're speaking before the board so that we know who you are.
And we have a number of recusals later on in the day for board members.
So that is my, that completes my opening remarks and so we're now ready for item one, the recommendation of the three finalists for submission to the governor for consideration and appointment to the State Board of Education.
Members Sue Burr and Bruce Holliday and Feliza Ortiz-Lacon have been working really hard on this.
This is a lot of work, really a lot of good candidates.
So, I think at this point member Burr will take over in terms of announcing them and then we will have some certificates for the finalists.
Thank you, President Kirsk.
Good morning, everyone.
Superintendent Torlakson.
This is my favorite meeting because we have the delightful opportunity to talk about all the wonderful applicants that we had to serve as our student board member.
Just to remind folks about how the process works.
We solicit applications.
We got a very broad pool of applications this year.
The job of our screening committee, President Kirst mentioned my colleague Bruce Holliday and Feliza Ortiz-Lincon, is to review all the applications, narrow them down to 12 semifinalists.
Believe me, it's not an easy job and I am here to report that the future is in good hands.
It's so inspiring to look at the applications and to talk to these young people.
We reviewed the applications, narrowed it down to 12 folks.
Then the semi-finalists, that's the category that we're going to be talking about as well, they attended the 2018 Student Advisory Board of Education.
We're going to have the opportunity to hear from those.
young people in just a minute about what their policy proposals are.
They held their conference this week and then the student delegates actually interview the 12 and they narrow it down to six folks after they've listened to the semi-finalist presentations on Monday and Tuesday.
So yesterday morning, we had the delightful opportunity to interview six candidates.
I really want to give a shout out to our current student board member, Hema Cardenas, who gave great advice to all of the applicants.
She helped us with the interviews, and we really appreciate your work, Hema.
You're a fantastic student leader.
Again, very difficult decision.
It seems like every year it gets harder, but I just want to say that this particular candidate pool was really amazing.
It was very difficult to narrow it down to three finalists, but that's our job based on the statutory requirements.
We narrow it down to three finalists who are then forwarded to the governor's office and Governor-elect Newsom will make that appointment in the spring and then will be joined by our new student board member next summer.
So, before I introduce everybody, I also really want to express my appreciation to the board staff.
Amy Babico, who runs this like a ship.
It's amazing how we get through all these applicant screenings.
And Patricia DeCoste, who for years and years has been very helpful in helping us select our student board member.
So with that, I would like first to recognize the semi-finalists.
I'm going to call them up by name.
and present them with a certificate.
Then the candidates, we will acknowledge.
And finally, we'll call up our three finalists.
And at that point, I'll make a motion and ask you to adopt our recommendations of the three finalists.
I also just want to call to your attention the blue addendum sheet because it identifies each student and gives their school.
So without further ado, I would like to call up
The first semi-finalist, Allison Gray.
If Allison would come forward.
And I'm trying to find Allison's school here.
She attends Salinas High School within the Salinas High School district.
Allison.
Thank you.
Next is Chloe Moreno.
Chloe attends High Tech High in San Diego.
Next up, we have these in different orders.
Sorry, we alphabetized by first name and last name.
Isaiah Colmanero.
Isaiah attends Gary and Jerry and Jacob's High Tech High within San Diego.
Our next candidate is Marion Mustafa.
Marion attends Irvington High School within the Fremont Unified School District.
Marion is not here.
I accept the award on her behalf.
Next is Nina Singh.
She attends Arthur Benjamin Health Professions High School in Sacramento City Unified.
We'll also get that award to Nina.
And Norma Garcia.
Norma attends Bright Star Secondary Charter Academy in Los Angeles Unified.
Okay, next up are the candidates.
We had the opportunity to interview each of these folks yesterday.
And again, as I said, it was really a stellar pool and we appreciate their interest.
First, I want to call up Angel Jimenez.
Angel attends Mountain View High School in El Monte.
Next we have Hanwoo Choi.
Hanwoo attends South Pasadena High School within the South Pasadena.
And last in this category is Waduse Yigletu.
Waduse attends Oxford Academy within the Anaheim Union High School District.
And now I would like to present to you our finalists.
And again, after we complete the presentation of the certificates, I will be making a motion that you adopt them as our recommendation to the governor.
First, we have Brenna Pangilinan.
She attends East Lake High School within Sweetwater Union High School District.
Next finalist is Olivia Ang Olson.
Olivia attends McClatchy High School in Sacramento.
And last but not least is Teenie Mukherjee.
Teenie attends Dublin High School within the Dublin Unified School District.
So again, without further ado, I would like to move that we adopt the finalists candidates to move forward to the governor as a student board member.
They moved in second.
Any further discussion?
Hearing none, all those raise your hands.
All right, they are approved.
Okay, thank you so much.
Okay, and I want to see if there's any public comment and then you will provide the certificates.
We have any public comment on this item?
Right.
So we need pictures and we need certificates.
OK.
All right.
Picture.
OK, and now we get to hear the student reports on item two.
So who's going to introduce this item?
Bruce Holliday and Hema Cardenas.
Well, do you need any start for this?
Go ahead.
Thank you, everybody.
Good morning.
I just want to really say thank you to all the students.
CAST represents what Student Voice is.
And, you know, they've been working on this since Monday, but the staff have been doing a lot of hard work since Sunday, and we really appreciate it.
All these students are amazing.
They represent California.
They represent the power in our young people, especially in these times.
And so the proposals that they will be presenting today are amazing, and I'm very excited for all
for everyone to hear them and I really appreciate and I hope you all take into account what they say and that we support it because it's amazing.
Thank you.
Okay, students will come forward and I think we have five reports which we're looking forward to.
Good morning.
State Superintendent Torlikson, President Kirst, and esteemed members of the State Board of Education, and honored guests.
My name is Rachel Liu.
I'm a senior at South Pasadena High School in Los Angeles County and the current State President of the California Association of Student Councils, or CASC.
This year's Student Advisory Board on Education, SABE, has brought together students from all over California to present and represent the student voice here.
An integral part of this conference and our delegation has been, as previously mentioned, the election process for the 2019 to 2020 student board member position on the State Board of Education.
I would like to commend many of the people who've made this conference and process possible.
First, the 12 semi-finalists who have taken an active role in their candidacy, as well as their respective proposals during this conference.
The current board member, Hema Kitsal Kardenas, for conducting the elections she went through just a year ago.
And finally, I would like to commend board member Bruce Holliday for consistently providing these students in a dry run panel with additional insight previous to this meeting.
Our consistent platform of presentations to this honorable board are not only an unparalleled opportunity for our delegates, but are the utmost recognition on behalf of the California Department of Education on the inclusion of the student voice.
We thank you all from the 6.3 million students of California.
And without further ado, I welcome the CASC Education Policy Director, Kenneth Kim.
Thank you for that introduction.
Good morning and thank you to Superintendent Torlakson, President Kirst and esteemed members of the board for allowing this amazing opportunity once again.
My name is Kenneth Kim and I am a senior at Brea-Olinda High School in the Brea-Olinda Unified School District, the Educational Policy Director for the California Association of Student Councils and the Director of the Student Advisory Board on Education Conference 2018.
The 29 delegates behind me are intelligent, witty, and open to both feedback and change.
Their passion for their own education, their willingness to be flexible, and their desire to actively work for change inspires both me and my staff.
Our qualifications, the delegation of students as the primary stakeholders of our education are the ones most affected by the California education system.
This year's delegates, with no bias or guiding from staff members, debated, voted, and decided on four topics, sustainability, mental health, inclusive history, and sex education.
In addition, our governmental affairs policy director, Arvin Hariri, and I have developed a proposal on student representation.
On day one, these delegates launched themselves into a long brainstorming process that, over the course of the three days, have been compressed into four succinct proposals.
We've worked long hours into the night, laying out a foundation for the proposals via root problems, assumptions, causes, and evidence.
the delegates both understand and acknowledge the differences between state and local policy ideas, keeping in mind the state's direction towards local control, and have kept this in mind when evaluating all possible solution ideas for the four topics.
I am confident that as a student advisory board on education presents the proposals to combat the issues within and concerning sustainability,
mental health, inclusive history, sex education, and student representation, the members of the student board of education will be hearing the most pressing concerns of the best student representatives of California.
And with that, I would like to welcome the first speaker who will be covering sustainability.
Good morning President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson and distinguished board members.
My name is Avery Reid and I'm here today to speak about sustainability in schools.
We recommend that the State Board of Education incentivize schools to cultivate environmentally principled students.
This will be done through the implementation of sustainable practices and a recognition program.
As I'm sure you are aware, climate change is a looming threat.
The actions we take now are imperative not only for the state, but for the entire world.
However, today I would like to tell you a different story, one that focuses on how we can save our environment.
Picture an ideal school.
The morning is painted with a golden sun and clear blue sky.
Students arrive at the school gates after a short walk or bike ride.
Solar panels line the top of school buildings that supply the day's electricity.
Throughout the school campus, compostable materials are used and thrown away in an organized compost system.
This is our ultimate vision for sustainability in California education.
Over the past three days, my peers and I have developed a solution to transform this vision into a reality.
We defined sustainable education not simply as comprehensive curriculum, but as a sustainable school environment.
We have identified that one of the most prevalent issues is that schools are not driving a sustainable culture because this simply is not a priority.
This, in conjunction with a lack of incentives for schools to establish these practices, leads to discrepancy in education surrounding these pressing environmental issues.
We see a need for eco-friendly resources in the school environment and a method for incentivizing sustainability.
We ask that the State Board of Education recommend to schools, one, the adoption of six sustainable action-based principles, water conservation, local sourcing, waste elimination, nature preservation, zero carbon emissions, and environmental literacy, and two,
Schools that prove to practice these principles in recommended actions would be recognized with an award known as the California Environmental School Award or CESA.
This award would be determined through an application evaluated by a pre-existing California school recognition program within the California Department of Education.
We recommend that the sustainability status of a school be re-evaluated every three years.
To help guide the sustainable development, the school board would recommend principles which have specific examples of actions for the schools to take.
These are outlined in the proposal packets.
For example, under the waste elimination principle, we have listed that schools can implement a tribe and waste system, which would consist of landfill, compost, and recycling.
We have included similar suggestions for all the six principles.
In order to fulfill the requirements set out in this award, the school must implement at least one qualifying aspect per principal.
Of course, more possibilities could be added by the CSRP.
On September 10, 2018, Governor Brown signed into law a commitment for 100% renewable energy in the state of California by 2045.
This commits us, our generation, to 100% renewable energy.
We must be properly educated for this responsibility.
We recognize that the board has implemented a blueprint for environmental literacy in 2016, focusing on educating students about the science of sustainability and climate change.
We truly appreciate the in-depth and progressive nature of this program.
However, we feel that a critical aspect of environmental education is learning in a model environment.
The recommended award program is comparable to other already successful programs.
The Oregon Sustainable School Award recognizes schools that emphasize four pillars of sustainable development, environmental impacts, healthy and safe students, education for sustainability, and social sustainability.
This program has successfully commended schools for their sustainability efforts, indirectly encouraging schools all around Oregon to contribute to this environmental agenda.
Similar to the National Green Ribbon Award, our proposal outlines sustainable actions but differs in the idea that it is more inclusive and attainable for all California schools.
With the recommendation of these principles and creation of an incentive, we hope to encourage the efforts of schools like those in Oregon.
My school, Credo High School in Rohnert Park, California, is an extremely dedicated environmentally friendly school that follows similar sustainability principles.
In executing our zero waste goal, we calculated that with the implementation of electric hand dryers, the school would only be paying 3.5% of the annual cost it spends on paper towels.
Thus, this proposal would incur no additional cost for the state board and only decrease the long-term expenses for each individual school.
I can confidently say that my school's commitment has cultivated eco-conscious and climate literate students, including myself and several members in our group.
This experience has inspired me to stand here today and ask that all students in California receive the same experience.
California is one of the most progressive states surrounding climate change in politics, legislation, and society.
We ask that the board incentivize schools to expand their environmental education with our proposed CESA award to continue the state's momentum.
We must create these programs now so there is no need for students to reiterate these sentiments 50 years from now.
Thank you.
Board Member Strauss.
So first, I just want to thank you and the students who helped put this proposal together and to share with students that there's a lot of talk about environmental literacy and sustainability statewide.
As part of the Governor's Climate Summit, we had a separate one just for education.
And there's a group that's planning a sustainability climate environmental program in fall of 2019.
And so I just would say to the students, it would be great to have your voice at that summit.
And as one of the liaisons that's helping with the planning, I hope that some of you will be able, depending on where you are in your transition to college,
to have the student voice at that, I think it would be really effective.
So I just want to thank you all for focusing on sustainability and the issues and tell you that there's a place for your voice as we really look at that in schools.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
That would be an honor.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
We've done this in past years, so I would like for your team to please stand so we could acknowledge and appreciate them.
Okay.
I think we're ready then for the second.
No, Patricia Rucker.
Go ahead.
Well, first of all, I want to congratulate you for a very thoughtful proposal and suggestion.
I enthusiastically supported the adoption of the blueprint for environmental literacy.
And I also am very thrilled to see this conversation happening, not just here at this conference and as a presentation in front of the board today,
But to know this conversation is happening among students across the state creates a different norm for what it means to create an environmental consciousness and the norms for implementing this at these particular activities at schools across the state.
Let me just ask you personally at your own school and in your own district, are any of these activities, conversations, your student councils at your sites are having as well?
Absolutely.
I go to, as I mentioned, like an extremely environmentally friendly and sustainable school.
So literally this conversation happens every single day, even at lunch.
Well, I'm glad the reason I knew that answer and I wanted to make sure you had a chance to say that to know that there are already models in place and that there are students who are very aware of this and are creating these activities as a norm.
in their own schools and at their own communities is also very important because that's a very important first step.
So thank you so much for bringing not only this very thoughtful, but very unique idea to the board.
And I really do hope to see many of these principles implemented as board member Strauss has already suggested that's going forward.
Thank you so much.
Hey, I think we're ready for the next speaker.
Next speaker will be covering mental health.
Good morning President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson and honorable board members.
My name is Josh Niblovana and I am a senior attending Henry J. Kaiser High School within the Fontana Unified School District in San Bernardino County.
Today my fellow peers and I are here to discuss a prevailing issue that is the implementation of mental health curriculum.
For the sake of this proposal when we refer to mental health we are referring to the general condition of one's psychological and emotional state.
There is an evident disconnect between a student's education in the classroom and the corresponding mental health standards established at the statewide level.
To bridge this disconnect, we are proposing the formation of a task force employed with the goal of evaluating the classroom implementation of the current standards within the revised health framework.
ER Taylor Elementary School and San Francisco Unified School District implemented the Healthy Start Room, a space designated specifically for mental health education.
The Healthy Start Grant's final report on program found a correlated increase in the school's academic performance index, from 444 in the year of 2000 to 784 in the year of 2009, to the creation and avid use of this Healthy Start Room.
Evidently, mental health education creates a positive academic impact.
Yet, there is still a dire need for such education to be prevailing all across California.
In fact, according to the National Alliance on Mental Illness, 20% of students are afflicted with mental health conditions.
That is 1.2 million students solely in California.
1.2 million who are in need of the tools to help keep themselves healthy.
We acknowledge that the board is aware of these issues and is currently preparing the framework for next year's mental health standards.
We also acknowledge the presence of currently set mental health standards.
Yet, when we took a quick poll within our group to gauge who remembered learning these in the classroom, we found that not a single one of us recalled learning most of the standards dating back to the sixth grade.
To resolve this gap between intent and implementation, my team and I are proposing for the creation of the Mental Health Evaluation Initiative Task Force, which would measure the efficacy of mental health standards under the revised health framework.
One possible way we see this being carried out is through the utilization of assessments, not mere surveys.
While one such survey, the California Healthy Kids Survey, serves to inspect the general mental health of California, our task force's assessments will determine whether each individual student can exhibit knowledge of mental health.
Our task force should not be confused with the Student Mental Health Policy Work Group that was created in 2012.
Whereas the 2012 task force is addressing the growing need for mental health resources and disperse the CalWell federal grant program, the mission of our task force is to prevent the neglect of new mental health standards and to ensure the curriculum is positively impacting student lives.
We understand the importance of local control.
However, in this instance, state action is pivotal as any implementation through local task forces would result in the confliction of ideas and the lack of a universal assessment.
Additionally, statewide action would be more cost effective as it does not call upon districts to pay overtime and carry out the assessments themselves.
It is only with the support of the state board that we can properly advocate for the implementation of mental health curriculum.
With the creation of this task force we will no longer remain concerned about our mental health standards not reaching students.
This is the first step in mitigating ineffective mental health standards within California high schools.
It is a necessity for us to obtain the data and proper evaluation of set standards, as the results will permit a follow-through and can ultimately allow us to target where improvements in the curriculum are required.
Possible next steps could include improvements in teacher training or readjustments in the student-to-counselor ratio.
The end goal is to ensure that all students within California feel safe, supported, and significant in regards to their mental health.
And so again, we urge you to create this necessary task force to ensure the continuation of our statewide journey to this better future.
Thank you.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you for that presentation.
And once again, if we could have your team stand up, please, so we could acknowledge them.
Thank you.
My question for you, we actually are currently, the health framework, as you noted here, is being, it's actually out for public comment, so that's a great way for you to weigh in.
It's out for public comment for 60 days, the next 60 days.
I know that mental health has been one of those pillars that we've seen really highlighted through the framework.
We had a diverse set of
of educators, people from the medical field that all weighed in on this because we know and year after year that has been one of the topics that youth have presented on.
So we know it's critical in our schools.
So I just want to encourage you to go ask students, student leaders and look at that framework and weigh in and give your comments because we do have to reply to all of our comments.
So thank you.
I'd like to add.
Oh, board member.
Thank you.
State Superintendent.
Congratulations again on an outstanding report and so very timely.
Appreciating what Felice Ortiz-Lacon just said in terms of invitation to be involved in the process.
We've also formed within the Department of Education a working group, a task force,
to go after about a billion dollars in money from Prop 63 that's set aside and designated for mental health, for professional development, for all staff to deal with anxiety, post-traumatic syndrome, anger, despondency, and suicide.
As you are aware, the rate of suicide is just a death toll that's unbelievable.
and preventable.
And so last year, 47,000 Americans committed suicide, many of them young people.
Homicides were 19,000, so suicides were twice what homicides were.
So it's a big challenge.
Thank you for taking it up.
And we need the student voice.
Everywhere I go in the state, students are telling me of their concern for their peers and for more counseling, more help.
So I invite you to join our working group.
And if you can get us your contact information,
Make sure you're informed of meetings we're having.
Thank you.
Okay, I think we're next ready for the next speaker.
The third speaker will be covering inclusive history.
Good morning esteemed guests and honorable board members.
My name is Valerie Zavala.
I am a senior attending Imperial High School within the Imperial Unified School District.
My peers and I stand before you today to propose revisions to the history social science framework in the context of curriculum inclusivity.
In the current framework, there are a list of materials, such as primary sources, that are recommended to teachers for classroom use.
Those primary sources are usually restricted to authors of one perspective.
These authors usually only tell the story of the majority.
This leads to students analyzing an event in history without a variety of perspectives.
Therefore, the Student Advisory Board on Education recommends that the State Board of Education instruct the Instructional Quality Commission to revise history's social framework
to incorporate more suggestions of primary sources, excerpts, and books from authors of underrepresented backgrounds.
We recognize that the State Board of Education has already been taking measures to make history more inclusive, especially through the recent adoption in 2016 of the revised K-8 History Social Science Curriculum Framework.
Therefore, we want to build upon the board's previous revisions by including more contributions from different ethnic and gender groups as stated in the Fair Education Act.
As we know, California is home to many cultural backgrounds and the history curriculum should reflect the different perspectives that make up our student population today.
Everyone must learn history, social science, in order to establish connections and make inferences from historical events and current events.
However, if students only learn from one perspective, they are unable to form critical thoughts about themselves and other cultures.
Because of this, it is necessary for the inclusion of those whose history is underrepresented.
To provide insight, I recently discussed cowboys in one of my history courses at Imperial High School.
The first cowboys were called vaqueros, and they were in fact Mexican.
However, many often associate cowboys with the stereotypes of the Wild West.
I am proud of my Latinx heritage, and I'm proud that cowboys are part of my family's history.
And yet, this was only covered in one or two sentences.
So as one could expect, I was more attentive to a history referencing Latinx people.
So when my community is portrayed in negative light, I felt ashamed of my heritage.
I didn't see where my family came from in a good light.
However, I am not the only one.
My worries are also expressed by my peers around me.
I'm not the only one worried about how others perceive me based on what is taught.
For example, the current framework has set for classrooms to evaluate the roles and contributions of the Navajo Code Talkers in World War II, as to just possible oral and visual histories that can be incorporated within the curriculum.
However, specific materials are not provided to recognize the actions and achievements of this important group.
With our recommendation, primary sources will provide students with a real perspective from this underrepresented group of Native Americans that provided the Marine Corps a form of communication overseas during World War II.
These sources can elaborate on particular beliefs and viewpoints of events more than the teachers or textbooks are able to within the allotted class time.
allowing students to further perceive experiences of those who were underrepresented in addition to majority viewpoint.
With the further study of these resources, students will be able to compare and contrast historical events and dive deeper into comprehending not only the event as a whole, but as events of multiple perspectives involved in the event.
This is why perspective is key.
The perspective of the author greatly affects what is written about their experiences and their opinions due to their own biases, implicit or not.
which is why the inclusion of diverse or multiple perspective authors is so essential so that the student is given an unbiased, holistic instruction.
For example, Canadian schools are currently including the perspectives of First Nations, women, non-European immigrants, in addition to the discussion of social responsibility as stated by Wilson Smith with positive results.
To further emphasize the positive aspects of revisal of the current framework, an ethnic studies pilot program was implemented in San Francisco high schools.
A study on that program found that there was a subsequent increase in attendance and academic performance of students who were initially at risk of dropping out.
Curriculum that was rooted in a variety of historical perspectives helped in closing the achievement gap, reducing dropout rates, and increasing graduation rates.
The positive outcomes of the program resulted in its expansion to all 19 schools in the San Francisco Unified School District.
This is only one example of the many benefits of using an author who is directly affected by a historical event.
With addition of suggestions of primary sources from different viewpoints of the author within the framework, a student will receive more information regarding an issue from multiple sources to feel more included in their history class.
With this revision to the history social science framework, students of all diversity will become more encouraged to involve themselves in politics and activism, and civic engagement in the youth will continue to significantly increase.
Thank you.
Yeah, so we'll be sure and send this to our Instructional Quality Commission, which oversees our textbook and materials adoptions and curricular frameworks.
And they, that's, we have a important commission that does that.
And this is the kind of thing we need them to see.
So thank you for that.
Board Member Rucker.
First of all, let me begin by saying I wholeheartedly agree with you.
Students have to see themselves in the curriculum and see themselves as part of the lessons of history that are being taught, not only to learn from those lessons, but to become a part of that history.
I was one of the board members who was assigned as the liaison in the development.
of the new history social science framework that we adopted a couple of years back.
It is gone from, it has, the framework in being revised has ballooned in volume and size in an effort to try to address
in many of the ways, in many ways, the issues that you raise in your presentation.
But I do agree with you for a very specific reason.
The perspective still remains very limited and very narrow.
The lessons learned from hearing from your voice and hearing what we saw with the development of the framework in the public comments that were received,
was that we have to consider not only what the development process looks like, but what are the perspectives that not only must be considered because they are valuable, but what message we are sending about what is of value in the state of California.
So I truly appreciate your perspective, not just because it's important to hear today, but even myself as a student in elementary school, in middle school, in high school, I also felt the same way.
I felt for a long time until I knew better.
Crispus Attucks had to be the only African American on the continent because that's the only one that was covered in the revolutionary period.
Then afterwards, somehow or other, we got to Harriet Tubman.
And by the time we got to the Civil War, my teachers expected me to be the expert on that because I was the only one.
So I understand your perspective and I agree with your concerns.
And also I hear your frustration.
I think this is a conversation the IQC needs to hear.
It's a conversation that has to continue being repeated.
And I am just so very grateful to know I am not the only voice that feels that way, but also is willing to stand up and make that statement.
So thank you very much for being here and for making that statement.
I would really like to meet and see all of your team members who participated in putting this recommendation together.
Could you please stand as well?
Board member Sandoval.
Thank you and the rest of the team for your intelligent thinking and description.
I really love the emphasis on primary sources.
I am of mixed ancestry.
I'm Chumash Indian from Santa Barbara County.
I'm also Mexicana on my father's side.
So I grew up feeling pretty invisible in our educational
system throughout school as far as having my histories and stories presented at any way.
So I was really honored to be a part of this process as a liaison to the framework revision.
We had thousands and thousands of
pieces of feedback from many, many people throughout the state, and it really informed the revision, which I feel is much improved and more inclusive.
But I do really appreciate your emphasis again on primary sources, and I just want to draw attention to one of the guiding principles of the framework, and that's student inquiry.
And what you're doing is you're using your voice, your student voices, and you're asking thoughtful questions that help us do our work better.
So, I want to thank you and the team for that and keep questioning and offering good constructive suggestions because that's what feeds this process.
Thank you.
All right.
And I think our next presentation, please come forward.
The fourth student speaker will be covering sex education.
Good morning board members my name is Stephen Kim and I am from the Fullerton Joint Union High School District.
We have identified a lack of proper and consistent implementation of comprehensive inclusive sex education throughout California as a primary problem that our state faces.
To address this issue we propose that the State Board of Education creates a task force to audit the compliance of schools with the existing education code outlining sex ed requirements.
This task force will evaluate the extent of implementation
and prompt action to ensure that all students receive the sex education they need and deserve.
The duties of the auditing group include the following.
First, a task force will be created for the purpose of conducting an audit on the implementation or lack thereof of sex education, noting which school districts forego sex ed.
With conclusion of this phase, the auditing group will compile a list of districts not in compliance
with the Healthy Youth Act of 2015, which defines sex education as a course to be taught at least once in middle school and once in high school, which also includes material applicable to sexual identities, which are not solely heteronormative.
If the district is found to be in noncompliance with EDCODE guidelines, it will be provided with a framework to address their unique difficulties and implementations
of these mandated guidelines.
The framework intends to equip and support schools with the resources and information necessary to address local concerns by providing a list of best practices.
Should action not be taken to implement sex ed in spite of the provided best practices and support of these difficulties in implementation?
The task force may provide their report to the Department of Education and the Attorney General's office for further action, ensuring follow through and proper adherence with the Healthy Youth Act.
Through this auditing group, we strive to make sex education accessible and applicable to all students as it is vital to their well-being.
Allow me to share you whose well-being is being affected.
we reached out to 196 K through 12 students from schools across California to gauge the extent of sex ed implementation.
12.2% have received no sex ed whatsoever.
68.4% who have received sex ed did not receive an LGBTQ plus affirmative education.
We see that this issue is pervasive and relevant, and the evidence suggests undesirable consequences if left unaddressed.
The Women's Policy Public Health Report reports that the presence of comprehensive curricula, which include both abstinence and birth control instruction, caused a 50% reduction in the likelihood of first-time sex being non-consensual among female respondents.
Consequences, such as the prevalence of sexually transmitted infections and teen pregnancies, are proven by the fact that 22% of all new HIV infections in the United States are from students ages 13 to 24.
Why the statistics?
Because sex ed cannot and should not be limited to reproductive instruction.
Properly implemented, it prepares our students with the necessary tools to protect themselves from non-consensual sex, combating a lifetime of traumatic memories, through teaching students proper consent techniques, and fostering healthy, non-violent relationships as described by the Healthy Youth Act.
Without proper sex ed, STIs or teen pregnancies cannot be addressed, permanently deteriorating the student's academic performance and future prospects.
When we see school board presidents making statements that misrepresent the Healthy Youth Act,
we see the need for a task force to clarify and enforce the curriculum.
Schools who ignore the mandated Ed Code are ignoring these adversity-affected students.
We simply cannot let that happen.
As students, we praise the affirmative clauses of the Healthy Youth Act and the State Board of Education's actions and efforts in support of this necessary legislation.
It represents our ideal education curriculum with fair and equitable curriculum and education for the betterment of our students.
We imagined an informed student population prepared with the tools to live a healthy lifestyle free from STIs and unwanted teen pregnancies, as well as ideals of increasing LGBTQ plus student affirmation made possible through an equal and hence inclusive education.
So I ask you, members of the State Board, to help our students access the educational opportunity which many are currently deprived of.
Again, we ask for the creation of a task force which will keep our school districts accountable for educating our youth.
With your support, our schools will have an objective evaluation of their practices
resulting in supportive feedback to address issues in implementation.
We urge you all as a state board to ensure the consistent adherence to sex education and to hear our voice.
Thank you.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you for that presentation, and I once again want to make a plug for the health framework.
I'm very proud of the framework that we are developing.
We have comprehensive sexual education.
It also makes sure that we are including everything with medically accurate terms.
And so I think that if you, and one of the most important things is we also address consent and what does consent look like?
And I think that's critical.
So I think it's important for you to get acquainted with that framework because everything that you mentioned is there.
And I understand that part of it is enforcing it, making sure that it's implemented, right?
We could only do our best here to put forth a framework that is inclusive of all of the needs, the health needs of all of our students.
But you're right, it has to be implemented.
And there is diversity of thought of what that means to put a health framework.
And I think you noted that very eloquently in your outline here.
But just know that we're doing our part, and we encourage you to look at that health framework that is up on our website for public comment.
And did you want to?
We actually have looked at the framework.
strongly support their framework, which is why we said it is part of kind of like our ideal curriculum.
And because of that fact, we want more schools because 12.2% of students haven't received this amazing framework that we believe all students should be educated with.
So that's kind of why we want to create this task force to ensure that students are receiving this inclusive and comprehensive framework.
Right.
It hasn't been approved 100 percent yet.
It's for public comment.
But thank you.
You heard it here.
The students support the framework.
And can we.
So now implement it.
So can we have your group please stand.
And so we could acknowledge and appreciate them.
Thank you very much.
I think we're ready for the next report then.
The fifth student speaker will be speaking on student representation.
Good morning.
Wait, does this work?
All right.
Good morning, members of the State Board of Education.
My name is Arvin Hariri, and I'm currently a senior at Berkeley High School in Berkeley, California.
This year, I serve as the governmental affairs and policy director for the California Association of Student Councils.
You've likely heard this phrase more than a few times, but I assure you it's only because it's true.
Students are the primary stakeholders in the education system.
But with the 6.3 million of us in California and counting, it's safe to say that it's difficult to make every single one of our voices heard.
Indeed, for too long, we've been kept away from the adult-dominated negotiation tables rendered virtually powerless in expressing our needs and concerns within the education system that was created for us.
That's why we recommend that the State Board of Education adopt the existing recommendation of the California Legislature and appoint a single student to the Instructional Quality Commission, or IQC.
As it stands, many of the students I've talked to feel lost in their education.
For example, many ASB members air their grievances about their fundamental lack of voice within the school, instead being delegated by their administration to creating posters and boosting school morale.
And don't get me wrong, while these things are important, they do not reflect a full picture of the ideal civic education.
So when we fail to instill a sense of civic duty in our students, we fail within the greater context of our democracy.
This systematic disenfranchisement has a clear and tangible effect on young voters' perception of the necessity of their voice.
According to NBC, in the midterms that just happened two days ago, only 40% of voters aged 18 to 29 cast their ballot.
That's shameful.
So instilling a stronger sense of civic engagement within these voters will result in an increase of educated voters, ultimately serving to better the overall quality of our democracy.
Now that I've well established the effects of student representation and why it's important, not just for the youth, but for all Americans, the question arises, why the IQC?
Why is this the perfect commission?
A quick preface for the audience.
The IQC is an advisory body to the State Board of Education on matters related to curriculum, instructional materials, and content standards.
So the inclusion of a student on this commission would not only legitimize student voice on a statewide level, but also provide unique student perspective on what we are interested in learning and how we want to go about doing it.
The grandiose depth, breadth, and purpose of the IQC would only serve to further amplify said student perspective, reflecting the needs and wants of pupils across the state, both directly and even indirectly.
We can't put a price on the quality of California's education system, but we can put a price on ensuring that student representation stays relevant to it.
At most, this proposal's implementation cost would only consider the transportation of the pupil to and from IQC meetings.
The travel cost is negligible compared to the priceless benefit of giving even a single student a voice.
Back in November of 2014, CASC brought this proposal to you, the State Board of Education.
However, we were told that this task would be within the jurisdiction of the legislature.
And so we took that advice, and we spent the next year in the legislature working in conjunction with ACSA, the Association of California School Administrators, and with Assembly Member Ed Chow on enacting AB 1204, which recommended on behalf of the legislature that you, the State Board of Education, appoint a single student member to the IQC.
Picking this student should be no trouble either.
Behind me stand 12 supremely qualified candidates.
believe me, supremely qualified, and some of whom you've already spoken to directly over the past week.
So using the process you've already created in place for the student board member position, appointing a student to the IQC should be a relatively effortless task.
And this idea isn't radical or new either.
In 2015, a student board member finalist was, as mandated by law, appointed to a superintendent's task force relating to the expansion of the CASP assessments.
So there's no doubt in my mind that we need a more accurate representation of the 6.3 million students in California.
There is a desire, a longing desire for the biggest stakeholders in our education system to express their voice, a voice often overlooked in a room of adults.
Having a student board member on the IQC is a small step that will result in a big, big shift towards a stronger student representation within our education system.
So thank you all very much.
Board member Strauss will comment.
So I want to thank you for being so articulate with your group.
First, let me see who helped you put this together.
So could your group stand up?
Me and Kenneth did it last night.
Well, so you guys are great.
And let me just say that the student voice and what you're sharing on our input
to our curriculum materials and resources are really valuable.
And what we are committed to is taking back your recommendations and talking with the leadership in CDE that works with the framework process and with the Instructional Quality Commission.
And also, I'll just remind you that while we'll address that issue of representation, but also the student feedback, and I think Member Sandoval was talking about the fact that whenever things go out for public comments, like our health framework is out now,
we get thousands, sometimes hundreds, thousands, ten thousands, depending on which framework it is, which we address.
And so in addition to looking at regular representation of a single person, I think we might want to take that recommendation of how do we get student councils to look at what's out for public comment
and give us comments which we have to individually address and either include or recommend why we're choosing not to.
And so in addition to a single voice, which obviously Hema is here representing students at the adoption process, but in the development process,
It might be interesting to be able to reach out and figure out a way, in an organized way, to get students to actually get input to what is going out to teachers.
So I just want to thank you guys for spending late, probably late last night, putting this together.
I would bet.
That's high school style, right?
And I just really just want to share with you all that we really value your process and input, and we will take it to the next step.
I think Member Burr wanted to make a comment too.
Well, first, I also just want to commend you on your follow through that when you presented a couple of years ago and with a similar recommendation and we sent you back to the legislature, you actually did the work and you got the law passed.
So kudos to that.
Just and I appreciate you letting me know because I'm chair of the screening committee and you'll see that we're appointing members to the IQC tomorrow.
But we do this annually and just it follows almost exactly the same application pattern as the student members.
So just for folks who are going to be involved next year as well in your work, keep your eye open for the recruitment process for IQC.
And if you're interested in applying, please feel free.
We will make sure that we acknowledge that students can be members.
and also to let you know there are other appointing authorities to the IQC, including the Assembly and the Senate and the Governor.
So, there's lots of opportunities.
So, you can pursue those.
But again, thanks and congratulations on your follow-through.
All right.
I think that concludes the presentations.
And so, we will proceed on to our item three in the board agenda.
Pardon?
Oh, break.
Okay.
We'll take a break.
We will take a break then.
Let's convene at 20 of 10.
So before we conclude, I want to thank you all again for your feedback and insight of these proposals.
It is of such value and really the insight validates so much of the hard work that these students have put into these proposals.
So two years ago, SABE marked my first realization of the value of the student voice, as well as my own.
This organization and conference consistently recognizes not only who students are and their perspective, but the potential of who our students can become.
We have special guest Lafate Makunyane from South Africa here today, and he has returned 16 years after his first
CASC experience to recognize the potential of what programs like this one can be and apply it to across 25,000 schools throughout South Africa.
So, if allowed, Makunyane would like to give several remarks as to the impressions he's received from these presentations and this process.
Okay, could you come forward?
Can you speak for two minutes?
Yes.
Yeah.
Good morning.
Thank you to the president and also to the honorable board.
But I'm really excited about what you are doing, the work that you're doing here.
And I'm currently a Fulbright fellow at Virginia Commonwealth University.
So part of the experience that I went through, the CASC training at Stanford University, and we went back into South Africa, we transformed the young lives of young people back home.
And we basically took the critical models and then made them, we customized them to fit the needs of South Africans and the challenges that we are facing there.
And it was a successful program.
And now I have the opportunity now to carry out an implementation program for over 25,000 schools around the country.
So that's why I'm reconnecting again with CASC to see how else we can also go in and work with the schools in various townships and various villages to ensure that we bring up change.
And this is what you witnessed today.
That's what I want to witness back home in South Africa.
And I would love to see if we could also work together.
Thank you.
And we wish you the best.
I would like to once again thank the esteemed board members, President Kirst and Superintendent Torlakson for listening to our proposals from this year's SAFE Conference and providing helpful implementable feedback.
I sincerely hope that very shortly we can turn these ideas that started in this room here into action implemented by you, the State Board of Education.
Thank you for your time.
All right.
I need to ask if there's any public comment on these items.
Okay, not hearing any, then we will reconvene at 20 of 10.
Okay.
The State Board will reconvene.
And we're now ready for item three on our agenda, which is an information item.
And it is the update and development of the California system of support for local education agencies and schools.
So if we could have the board members take their seats and I can get a quorum.
I do have a quorum.
Thank you.
OK.
In order to frame this, I'd like to make some remarks about feedback we're getting from the field on the state and local and federal system of support.
There seems to be still some residue, and not surprising, of people thinking that what we're doing has something to do in similarity with the old system under No Child Left Behind called
annual yearly progress and that this would be that what we're proposing is somewhat similar to the No Child Left Behind.
approach of sort of shaming and negative consequences for school districts with various threats about withholding funding.
Our system is focused on helping local school districts tap into the resources around them and around the state so that they can build the capacity they need to improve student learning.
We're really in the assistance business, not in the punishment business.
So that said, we are not going to shy away, nor have we, from developing a variety of accountability tools with consequences that highlight at the local level and the state level areas where schools and districts are struggling and where there are achievement gaps.
So we want to further develop this system.
And you'll be hearing today from several different speakers who are talking about what we're doing, how we can do it better.
And we are close to accomplishing our goal of stripping away the clutter of dueling improvement plans so districts and their agencies can focus on children, instruction, and this can be incorporated into the local control accountability plan known as LCAP.
So this, I'm hoping as we move forward we can
do better in communicating that this is not the past and it's really a future and it's a different approach.
So with that, I'll have Melanie make a presentation here and then we'll have some guests talking about how they're working on this system and how we can improve it.
Good morning, Superintendent Torlakson, State Board President Kirst and board members.
I'm Melanie Green, the Director of the Improvement and Accountability Division at the California Department of Education.
I'm so excited to present item three, an update on the development of California System of Support.
At the September State Board meeting, you were in the incredible hands of Deputy Superintendent Kerrick Ashley and Shanene Coates, and you had a wonderful presentation that focused on where we've been and where we're going.
To echo the words of President Kirst, we are not recreating a punishment system of the past.
Specifically, you heard about LCFF and how it formed the foundation for our new accountability and continuous improvement system.
You also discussed key aspects of the system of support put forward in the 2018 Budget Act and the lead agency selection process.
Today, we'll discuss aspects of the system of support and how it's evolved to include the federal school improvement requirements.
We'll hear from San Juan Unified about how they're using their LCAP and dashboard to support their continuous improvement process.
After their presentation, we'll hear from Tom Armolino, the executive director of the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence, who will provide an update on the work of CCEE within California's accountability and continuous improvement system.
Though you've thoroughly reviewed key aspects of the system of support at the last meeting, including the goal that's on the screen and the key shifts of improvement, it's important to refocus on the goal each time to ensure that our work stays aligned.
The biggest part of the goal that's jumping out to me currently is the part of building capacity to sustain improvement.
As a new mom, I had a lot of nurses trying to teach me how to swaddle my baby.
I had one nurse that would come in, oh, the baby is unswaddled.
Let me swaddle him for you.
And I'd watch, and she did this magic.
And all of a sudden, my baby was swaddled again, happy and smiling.
And she left the room, and I just prayed that he wouldn't become unswaddled.
I had another nurse.
that would come in, and she'd be like, oh, he's unswaddled.
Let me show you how to do it.
OK, I'm ready.
I'm listening.
And she would walk through what she did, how she did it, some memory tricks she had for how she kept it going.
And then right as he was swaddled, she undid it.
And she asked me to do it myself so she could give me feedback on the strategy on doing it.
So she was trying to build my capacity.
to improve on a very important new parent technique, as many of you might know.
And so it did work.
I'm an excellent swaddler.
He's four months old.
I don't have any pictures in here, but as you can imagine, it did work.
And I actually think of not only her positive reinforcement when she was watching me do it, even though I was fumbling, but also just the patience and the time and the space of, you're going to get this, and I'm going to help you.
So, I think there's different parts of this goal that resonate at different times.
I know as a principal and teacher, addressing inequities and student opportunities, and especially hearing from our student speakers today, and how they're thinking about the education system, and how we can make sure that we're having increased opportunities for all students, also pops out.
So, I just encourage everyone in the audience to think about what part of this goal is resonating with you, and also as we have our discussion today, are we living up to it?
Are we in that line of thinking?
At the last meeting, you also discussed the vision for California System of Support, including how support is a local process with support providers working alongside a community with the LCAP as the main driver for improvement.
It also comes with a new structure to help connect LEAs to resources.
But what does that really look like?
The next slides highlight information we're trying to provide to the field with samples of the type of guidance and information we're working on.
You all have a copy
of my next two slides.
It's a front and back.
I also have 50 for the audience.
This first graphic begins with the levels of support on the left-hand side.
So you'll see level one, level two, level three.
Then within the circles, you see LEAs and their students at the center, with county offices enveloping them as the first line of support.
Then the geographic leads connecting with the counties in their area.
The geographic lead agencies are also connected and able to draw upon support from the expertise leads.
Notice that the California Department of Education and the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence ensure coordination of all these actors, specifically through the system of support planning group meetings, which will include the lead agencies, both geographic and expertise, and of course continue to include stakeholders and the state agencies.
This graphic illustrates the substantial investment that the state has made to build the capacity of support providers and expertise in the field.
If you have any feedback, this obviously, we don't have enough time to discuss feedback, but please send me any feedback you have and we can work in getting this to continue to evolve.
So we've taken it to the system support planning group, had their feedback.
As you use it with folks, please send me any feedback you have so we can continue to make these resources friendly.
The next graphic breaks it down a little bit more and asks, so how does an LEA move through this system?
This slide illustrates the no wrong door concept, a concept that we talked about almost over a year and a half ago when we first started talking about the system of support as part of our accountability and continuous improvement system.
When you knock on any door, you will get the support you need.
If the first person you reach can't offer the support, they have the responsibility and will make sure you get to the person that can.
So specifically, you see the local educational agency on the left hand side.
and then their County Office of Education and Geographic Lead Agency, so that when they ask for support, either support because they already know what they need, or support in helping figure out what they need, and support in helping to prioritize their needs, those folks are there.
And if in discussions with that LEA, that person doesn't necessarily have the support to provide, they are going to reach out
to ensure that that community gets the support they need.
And you'll see a sample of specifically the state resources that the budget has put forward, but also
other resources that are currently going on.
For example, rural networks or different initiatives that folks are focused on.
So this has the specific pieces from the Budget Act and our subject matter resource leads, but it doesn't mean that that's the only places county offices and geographic lead agencies will look at to connect LEAs and their communities with the support they need.
This final slide is a draft of a table that outlines, and you don't have a copy of this.
It's way too drafty to then make a copy of.
But I can put it up on the screen just fine.
This is a draft of a table that outlines the LCFF, differentiated assistance, and the ESSA school accountability.
The board will have a fuller discussion in January on the implementation of these pieces, but I wanted to highlight that we're very cognizant that the field needs more information that's digestible on how these pieces work together and how they break down.
So on this slide, but I did want to highlight that we're trying to break down that information to the field and also using stakeholder groups to get feedback.
So I'll be taking this slide to the LCFF stakeholder group and asking them,
Is this helpful?
If not, why?
Is this communicating what we're trying to communicate?
So just an example that we're also cognizant that we need to break down how LCFF and ESSA break down and how they work together.
So we've reviewed key aspects of the system of support, but how has it evolved?
Specifically, how has California positioned the federal school accountability requirements within our accountability and continuous improvement system?
so that we can have, in the famous words of Nancy Ronell, one coherent state and federal accountability and continuous improvement system.
We do.
We love her.
And when I first came on at the Department of Education, those were some of the first board meetings I watched.
And I remember hearing her lay out this vision.
And so now to be able to help implement those pieces is huge.
And I still talk with her regularly about, is this aligning to the vision?
Is it coherent?
How do we continue to make it coherent?
In the improved ESSA state plan, you'll notice that the federal requirements complement our focus on the LCAP and dashboard as key pieces communities use on how they will get better for kids.
Specifically, the federal guidance provides an opportunity to go in depth with our school level planning processes and focuses on student groups and using multiple measures for student performance.
Now you will recall that early iterations of the ESSA plan was different.
Now there's more complexity as a result of some of the changes that were made, but it does align with our LCFF focus.
The state and federal alignment ensure that there's no separate system for schools.
In essence, the federal statute provides us guidance that we're using to ensure our school level planning processes, which are essential to district level planning, are enhanced.
And of course, that's a lot of high level policy talk without here's some examples of what it will look like, but that's what we're working on creating so that when schools are working on their school level planning with their district, within the LCAP process, they're going deeper into their student groups using multiple pieces of information.
So this is very much a policy discussion and we'll get more into the implementation in January.
It's important to continue to talk about the pieces of our accountability and continuous improvement system from a policy perspective, but it's more important to hear about how communities are living it.
Today we'll hear from San Juan Unified about how they are using the LCAP and the dashboard to continuously improve for kids.
I'm honored to introduce Superintendent Kent Kern from San Juan Unified, Pam Costa, and Shannon Brown.
I want to thank Superintendent Torlakson, President Kirst and the Board of Education for allowing us to come here today and share our experience in San Juan Unified as being identified for differentiated assistance.
As President Kirst mentioned, part of the system of support is to promote local ownership of the process and outcomes to build capacity.
The state and the Board of Education are empowering us as the district to examine data, engage in discussions and make the necessary changes to improve schools for all students.
On page five of your supporting documentation of this agenda item, the statement is made, the process of change in the education system, giving the size and scale of California's public system, or in our case, a large school district, can feel overwhelming at times.
That is why in San Juan Unified, we believe that we must do this work through partnerships.
And you're going to see that today with Shannon presenting.
And when I speak about working together in partnerships, this is the belief of our district administration, the Board of Education, and our employee groups.
One of the key partnerships that has allowed us to develop many innovative programs in the district is with our Teachers Association.
Shortly, you will hear from Shannon, the Executive Director of the Teachers Association, how the district and the union are partnering together to address the issues we were identified for assistance.
and how we are working hand in hand with the guidance of the county to go through a root cause analysis in order to make the necessary changes for growth.
Our board president, Pam Costa, who has served in San Juan Unified for over 40 years as a teacher, administrator, site administrator, district office administrator, and now on the Board of Education, is going to share how we use and review data to help us make informed decisions related to our LCAP.
Thank you, Superintendent Kern, and also thank you to the State Board of Education for the opportunity to share the collaborative work we utilize to develop our LCAP and are now using to address the areas which were identified for needing differentiated instruction.
Four years ago, a senior cabinet member and staff were identified to lead the LCAP work.
An LCAP parent advisory committee was formed comprised of parents, community members and students from our targeted groups with one board member as the board liaison plus labor leaders and staff responsible for issues being discussed serving as advisors.
In addition to the LCAP PAC, the district staff and board wanted greater input from parents, staff, students, and community members.
Listening circles provide focused feedback about targeted issues.
Seven superintendent and board advisory committees provide additional opportunities for stakeholders to add their thinking to the process.
Thought Exchange gives voice to all members of the community digitally.
Labor groups and site and district leaders also provide input.
Additionally,
More than 28,000 parents, staff and students responded to stakeholder surveys this year alone.
For the past two years we have added data equity walks.
This year over 300 parents, staff, community and students formed school teams to look at district data and discuss their thoughts about the data and ideas for future actions.
They will reconvene two additional times during the LCAP process.
Multiple data points are an important part of San Juan's work.
Everyone from the board to school site staff work with both summative and formative data regularly to determine if the actions going forward are meeting the needs of our students.
It is never about one number or one assessment.
We know effective assessment is much more than that.
I'd like to contrast that with my 40 years in San Juan as a teacher, principal, and director with previous initiatives.
As a young teacher, the school improvement program was launched.
I was told not to worry about who was involved in the plan or what was written because it was just a compliance document.
That was proven to me when reviewers came out and measured my bulletin boards to determine the amount of student work to teacher lettering, rather than the instructional programs going on before their eyes in the classroom.
As a principal, I was told to just make sure that the actions matched the budget.
Collaboration of stakeholders and the focus on instruction and data were really nice, but it wasn't what the state was looking at.
When reviewers came out, the budget actions were their focus, not the exemplary instruction occurring in classrooms or the collaboration or the parent engagement.
I became a director during the period of accountability, and I watched as schools faced sanctions.
They became objects to be fixed with no input from the school or the district, which brings me to current times.
And I think we've come a long way as a district and a state.
We're proud of the engagement, the use of data to make informed decisions to improve student learning, the collaborative nature of our work with our site teams and our labor partners.
We're also proud that the state values those things too.
We would rather not have areas needing differentiated assistance, but we are also appreciative of the way the state is providing the assistance with CCEE and the county offices.
We are partners working in collaboration with the Sacramento County Office of Education and their approach matches ours.
We are in collaboration to address our needs to benefit our students.
And to explain that part of the process, it is my distinct honor to introduce Shannon Brown.
Shannon was an exemplary teacher in the San Juan District, a California Teacher of the Year, President of the San Juan Teachers Association, and now its Executive Director.
As Kent said, collaboration is one of Shannon's core beliefs.
And we have been able to make some very beneficial student-centered decisions by working collaboratively with the Teachers Association.
It's my pleasure to introduce Shannon Brown.
OK, I'm not going to say anything because it will just ruin what she just said.
I'm lucky to be a part of the San Juan community where the superintendent and the school board recognize that practitioners who work in direct service to students are not only important voices to add to the conversation, but are partners to be engaged in this meaningful work.
And I want to say thank you to you, the state board, not only for hearing from us today, but to helping to design a system of support that itself is more closely aligned with the concept of continuous improvement.
San Juan has been identified for differentiated assistance in three areas, student achievement, student engagement, and school climate.
Because of my limited time to speak today, I'm going to focus on my comments on school climate, which we are identified for because of our suspension rates of our African-American students and our students in foster youth.
Honestly, initially I was not looking forward to working with the county office because of past experiences had shown me that their focus, as you have heard, has been largely on compliance and someone being able to check boxes.
During the NCLB era, common approach in education was to improve numbers as if numbers were the goal of improvement.
So many of the solutions that were generated during that time became about treating symptoms of problems and not addressing the problems themselves.
So we had a lot of good people working very hard, but were aiming at the wrong targets.
Well, things have changed.
Our Sacramento County of Office folks came out to San Juan and led us through a process.
It began with a reflection on multiple data points and within that discussion,
we moved to thinking about leading indicators versus lagging indicators and identified that we need to have some leading indicators to help us interrupt patterns throughout the year.
What added further depth to that work was that after the reflection, the county staff then encouraged us to suspend our natural inclination to move immediately into solutions, because we're really good at that, and encouraged us instead to wonder what was causing these outcomes.
Our team collectively agreed that suspensions are a symptom with potentially multiple causes.
And if we try to simply treat symptoms, which means just focusing on dropping that number, we would be at risk for covering up the real issues our students were facing.
Our identified overarching goal became to create and refine systems to assist students in developing more functional behaviors.
Several big ideas emerged from our work.
One, direct student support.
Given that suspension has traditionally been used as a form of discipline, we are now working on finding ways to improve and refine supports to students through our multi-tiered systems of supports that includes social, emotional, and mental services, including now various screeners that help us identify students who may be need and support before issues arise.
Two, and this actually has two sub points, staff support and capacity building.
We noticed that a majority of our African American and foster youth students attend schools where staff turnover is higher than in the rest of the district.
This turnover results in our newer to the profession practitioners serving our students with the most intensive needs.
We are now using research about secondary trauma of staff who work most closely with students who have a high number of adverse childhood experiences.
Work has now begun with a small group that do serve our most intense schools to develop ways to create a more sustainable work environment for the people in those sites.
The second part, we recognize that we have various types of programs that schools are using either as alternatives to suspension or for culture building.
But within that, we realize that each program has its own rubric specific to that program or has no rubric.
This causes a lack of clarity for school sites when they're moving to implementation to not be clear about what their next step is beyond getting everyone trained and making sure they have materials.
And it also causes gaps across the system with our ability to have a common language.
So when we are trying to determine what is working at what site for what students, we don't have the appropriate metrics to be able to do that.
So we are designing a rubric that will be used district-wide based on implementation research that includes the continuous learning cycles.
And we anticipate using this rubrics to help us identify programmatic gaps that are currently invisible to us.
And third, a big concept, equity.
Equity as a centerpiece.
So the concept of equity we have discovered seems to be something that everyone agrees on as long as it doesn't stop my kids from getting what I think they need.
So we know that given the diversity of our district and where the traditional center powers are,
Excuse me centers of power are in our district that this is going to be a heavy lift But we are committed to developing a common understanding among staff and families that equal does not mean equitable so with that That's what we're doing in San Juan.
We got a lot of stuff to do But we wanted to share a little bit about what we've identified for our work.
Thank you board member rocker
First of all, I was thrilled when I found out that San Juan was going to be here to talk about your schools and your program.
Shannon, it's nice to see you.
Shannon and I know each other.
We go way back.
And so she knows the question I'm about to ask because she's heard me ask these, make this statement and ask these questions before in other conversations.
So in looking at, in particular, your
your suspension information concerning foster youth and African-American students.
I'm very clear that the information did not come as a surprise to you.
But my question is, before we started this LCAP process and before you started to focus on this continuous improvement and looking at not just outcomes, but also inputs and processes, what had been going on in the district before
that makes you characterize your initiatives now as being so qualitatively different?
What had been going on before to address this particular problem that now makes the work you're doing now so qualitatively different?
Honestly, it was, we had a lot of different things that we were trying, which created a pretty fragmented approach.
So there wasn't a systemic thing that people could name as a district approach.
And one of the unintended consequences in the initial conversations was that lowering suspensions was the goal.
So suspension rates initially showed some level of decline, but what we heard from school sites was that caused an increased disruption to the learning environment because we were not getting to the deeper issues of what students were facing.
Okay.
And then the other question I wanted to ask, I was surprised
to learn from your chapter president about the work that your school site councils are also doing.
So, how have your school site councils been involved in these conversations and this work as well?
I think the school site councils are looking at their specific data at the schools because when you look at schools across San Juan Unified they look very different from one end to the other.
We have schools with 99% unduplicated students and then schools that are in the
20s and their needs are very differently so they're looking at their data and saying what do we need to do to support our school around that because again if we were to make a decision from the top down that may meet the needs of some but not others in parts of the district and you know one of the things that Shannon alluded to this a little bit
I was in a meeting after we were identified as needing differentiated assistance, and I don't think this superintendent I was with meant to say it this way, or maybe he did, and it was like, I can fix the numbers.
And that stuck in my head again and again as to, I don't want to fix the numbers.
I want to address the issues.
And if all we're going to do is fix the numbers, then we're not going to change.
So, I think that's the key piece in this in partnership with the county, in partnership with CCEE that we need to be clear on that this is not about fixing the numbers.
This is about addressing the issues.
And I just want to ask this last question.
Is it true that all the school sites in your district have a school site council?
I believe, yes.
You know, we went above and beyond the requirement of just our Title I schools.
So, we do have site councils at all of our schools.
I personally want to commend you for doing that.
I think that's an excellent way, not only of engaging your community and creating a broader network of stakeholders who are engaging with implementing the district priorities, but it's an excellent model for all districts to consider and look at.
So, I wanted to make sure I got a chance to say that and commend you for it.
Thank you very much.
Okay, I'm going to talk with our CFR liaisons, have any comments at this point?
So first, I just want to thank the San Juan team for coming forward.
And I know the three of you represent stable, long-term commitment in your roles and leadership in the district.
And I think that's, I just would say, significant in creating a coherent system.
And I appreciate the reflection on the way it used to be.
Many of us, like, I, it's sad that I'd laugh at the bulletin board comment, but some of us have been around a long time enough to know that people focus on different things.
I also appreciated your highlights to the data walks and looking at lagging indicators and leading indicators and understanding that it's not a simple fix on the data.
But we are in a transition period, and I think that's what part of this item is trying to highlight, that people know how it was.
We lived in that for a while.
And we're in transition and we hear the words, but what does it really mean, which is how we highlight it.
And I think Member Burr had asked to highlight the role of the county office for a district.
I appreciate you sharing what Sacramento County is doing and what the role is.
I know we're a really big state, we have lots of county offices, but you're a district that's really highlighted that collaborative work and the way to really differentiate.
So I just want to thank you for your, I know it's hard to narrow down when the board says you have like seven minutes to present and that's it.
and the role between the teacher leader and the board role and superintendent and really the continued work you're doing in San Juan.
So just on behalf of board members and all of us in this work together, just thank you for your time today and for what it took to put this together and for your ongoing work to make a difference for kids.
Well, first, I have to give a shout out to the district of which I am an alum.
I am very proud of you.
Go Matadors.
But so I really appreciate you being here.
And it was so great to hear both the contrast, as Board Member Strauss said, between the old and the new, but also how you sort of gave life to root cause analysis.
We throw around, as Melanie said, a lot of big policy terms.
that I don't think people really get.
And board member Ortiz-Lacon and I were reflecting on a recent incident that we read about in Maywood School District where a teacher actually punched a student.
But who had been pushed, the teacher has been pushed to the brink by bullying and racial epithets.
But the comment about studying what is the environment like for staff at schools that are very challenged.
And I mean, that was like, of course, you know, we really have to think about that.
I really commend you for the level of work that you're doing to get at what are the issues and how do we improve our student environments as well as our staff environments and make a difference, not just move the numbers.
So thank you so much.
Thank you so much.
It's really a joy and a pleasure to hear the story of the work that you're doing and that you are such a collaborative team.
And I think that's really important that you are representing so many different voices as you're sharing what you're doing.
I too love the walk down memory lane.
Because it is true, the evolution of what we're doing and the work that, the focus that we have now is so much more meaningful.
We have treated the symptoms in some ways, as you indicated, and had the wrong aims.
But your root cause analysis has gotten you to that.
And it's really looking at what are all the different things that LCAP, the opportunities that LCAP has provided.
I think we're on a journey that many, many districts put in things and now you're looking at how those things all go together and whether they're truly connected to that root cause that you found so that you can tweak and adjust.
And it sounds like you very much are doing that work.
So we really thank you.
And I think that your sense of wonder is to be commended.
because it's kind of risky and we feel really vulnerable when we say we're wondering about this as opposed to not this direct from A to B. And in that wondering, in that space is when these magical, innovative things come together that are customized to the local, you know, the local needs.
And so I just think it's sometimes hard as professionals to say I'm just wondering, but that is a great place to be.
So there's a university of wonder and I've seen it.
So thank you very much.
Stevie Wondersaw.
Board member Holliday.
I too want to thank you for your presentation.
It was absolutely brilliant.
I'm so excited by the work that you're doing.
In a bit of memory lane, you know, when I was in a school and our math scores weren't where they were supposed to be, the fix was
Find the math expert, bring the math expert in, and everything will be solved.
And it's not that way.
This morning we heard from five different students about what they're concerned about.
They're concerned about their health, their safety, mental health, sexual health.
They're concerned about the environment.
They're concerned about
things that the math expert doesn't necessarily reach.
And what you're doing, though, is you're taking the LCAP process, the support system, data analysis, not just to fix a math score, but to instead fix a school, fix a community.
help children in all sorts of ways.
What's really exciting to me is that you chose to talk about suspension and not math scores because that shows how broadly all the change that this board and the superintendent and the legislature, how broad all of this initiative is and how deeply and in important ways it can get to
helping kids.
It's very exciting.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, President Kirsten.
Also, kudos, commendations for your teamwork is fantastic.
And I just thought I'd do a shout out to the San Juan District and Shannon and the whole team.
The Institute for Labor Management, a collaborative process for school board members, administration, teachers, classified, sitting down in safe environments to share candid
approaches to collaboration roadmaps.
And San Juan District is a role model.
I just want to mention you've been a role model.
I think we've, the Labor Management Institute has brought in 150 districts, Glenn, and San Juan was one of the very first and a role model that shines brightly.
So thank you.
Yeah, I was on the board when we did the ECE, the Early Childhood Program, which Wilson Riles led, so you bring back memories.
I think our approach then was that you could just set up these categories and, you know, that would do it.
And here, your presentation is much more trying to integrate this within the total district, within
the broader needs of pupils, including school climate, and then link it to the budget and link it to a much broader agenda of data and parental participation.
So, it just highlighted for me how far we've moved from those days and those assumptions.
And it's very heartening.
So, thank you.
Any further comments about the board?
If not, Melanie will take over.
Thank you so much for San Juan Unified sharing a part of their journey and story.
We'll now have Tom Armolino, the Executive Director of the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence, share about their work.
Okay, welcome.
This is your first appearance and we look forward to working with you over time.
Thank you.
It's my pleasure to be here.
Thank you, Dr. Kirsten, Superintendent Torgson, State Board members.
I'm sorry I couldn't be here at your last meeting.
So, I've been on the job a little bit over four months now and what I wanted to share a little bit about is some of the work.
What you're going to see a little bit is where we're moving.
And it does seem to shift daily, depending on some of what's happening in the field, too.
But in my first 90 days, I really focused in three areas.
One area in particular was really to get out and really see the work of the CCE, really sit with staff and really be engrossed in that work and trying to really take a look at what are we doing, what's the impact of our work, as well as getting an understanding of the folks that we're working with.
What's their opinions about this work and how's it being impactful?
In addition, with the system of support, as you know, with all of the new leads that came with the governor's budget, in particular with the geographic leads, the community engagement initiative, the SELPA leads, we're heavily involved in that process.
So, again, I engrossed myself directly in that process.
And I have to tell you, too, it's really been
I really appreciate the opportunity to work really closely with the State Board staff as well as Tom's staff and CDE, too.
What's unique, I think, really about the system of support, as you can imagine, is really about relationships.
It really starts with really being able to have relationships with folks to have enough trust to try to figure out how we're going to do this work because it's really difficult work.
And so what was kind of neat to see is folks are really working really quite collaboratively together.
And then in addition to that work too, we work with county offices and CCESA and some of the other groups out there to really think about how are we going to really be able to implement this work.
And then the last piece of that first 90 days, I spent a lot of time on the road.
really trying to meet with a lot of folks as well as folks here in Sacramento, trying to understand their thoughts about CCE, both what we've been doing, what they think we should be doing, and then trying to understand what they know about the accountability system.
And one of the things I can share with you in particular is the school districts where I met in one of my first meetings I met with a group of 26 superintendents in Santa Barbara.
And at that meeting, they were coming together for two days with the county superintendent.
So they do this every year.
They kind of come together and they spend a couple of days and really talk about how they can work collaboratively together in their own county.
very unique opportunity to sit with them, and I started to talk about the system of support, and they didn't know what I was talking about.
And so I really took an opportunity to kind of share that diagram, and we were in a different draft at that time.
But it was really helpful for folks to kind of get an understanding, and the district's folks in particular,
We're pretty impressed that they were in the center of that work and that the system was really built on trying to support local control and giving opportunities and resources and understanding what all these other resources are really being built to support them.
And at the end of the presentation, I had one of the superintendents who said, what can we do to let the folks know who are making these decisions understand that we support this work?
And I said, well, I think part of what you can do is do what you're already doing here, is continue working together collaboratively, because the system of support really starts with you and your county office.
And so folks have really, I think, really embraced the opportunity and the ideas that are there.
It is very messy.
It's difficult.
It's not easy work.
But I really appreciate having an opportunity to be a part of it, too.
So based on those conversations,
What we've learned and then working with our board too, we've developed our own, some goals around where some of that work, we're focusing that work too.
And again, remember that some of the work I came out in July, some of the work of the CCE is already in place.
So some of that work is continuing.
And so where you'll see our goals are built around is some of that work that's already been in existence, figuring out how we'll shift that work to make sure that that work
Supports the work that we're doing in the system of support as well as some new work that's come this this year to us and so if you'll look at the basically these five strands of the continuous improvement strand is an area where We've already been doing quite a bit of work in particular the work in that area has been around our professional learning networks and so we have we have 58 or 56 professional learning networks across the state that we've been having this is our where our second year this year and
It's interesting when I was listening to San Juan too, I think they are an example of some of the similar of our professional learning networks we have.
I think of that 56, I think 38 are county offices and they're county offices who are working with their school districts.
And it's really focused around the work of the LCAP development.
and the work of really trying to work collaboratively together to try to make sure that that document is something that actually can be actionable and something that folks, they can work collaboratively on that work, as well as around the work of differentiated assistance, which, as we saw last year, that was some of the first year of that work, too.
So, we really tried to support that effort of really trying to give them the
time and the resources to kind of come together to figure out how they can do that with some fidelity and to be able to make sure it's moving forward.
Part of what you'll see in our work as well as where I'm talking with our folks is really trying to understand how do we now take that work that we've been doing and scale that work?
How can we make that as an example in the field to folks to say, if you're looking at a way to be able to do a professional learning network around working with districts around the LCAP, here's an example of that work.
Here's some examples of folks who've been doing that.
Here's how they've been able to do that work, an example of how you might be able to do it, too, if you're struggling in that area.
The system of support, as you saw earlier in the diagram, too, we are directly in the middle of that work, both working at the higher level with the State Board of Ed staff, as well as with CDE of really coming together and bringing stakeholders together around, how are we going to implement this?
The next piece really in that is there's quite a bit of work around now that we've developed.
We've determined who the geographic leads are going to be.
We have our community engagement lead developed.
Our SELPA lead is almost there.
We have these other support systems that are in place.
We really have a role of bringing them together.
So, for example, with the geographic leads, we're tasked with bringing them together, meeting with them, and then talking about how are they, one of the things that they're tasked with is how are they going to be able to develop capacity to make sure that every county office has the ability to be able to work with the districts and serve them so there is no district in the state that gets anything less than any other district based on where geographically they may be located.
as well as thinking about what resources they bring to the table and then how do we make sure that those resources are available to any district in the state.
In addition to that, we also have to bring the other agencies together.
So, for example, in the Community Engagement Initiative, last week I was down in San Bernardino.
They have the lead with a couple of agencies down there and we spent that first day with them just talking about the work that they have to do and how they're going to try to be able to scale that work.
And then with the self-believes, we'll be doing something very similar.
So each of these other groups, we have this responsibility of bringing them together, talking about how they're going to do their work.
And then we have the ability or the task of trying to bring all of them together.
to talk about how they're going to work collaboratively together to make sure that those resources, that everyone is aware of those resources throughout the state.
Sounds pretty easy, right?
Yeah.
It's very complex, but it actually makes a lot of sense, right?
And there's, and what's, again, what's unique about it, I think that districts really appreciate is all of those resources are geared towards them.
and really trying to have them an understanding that there is no district in the state that shouldn't get anything less than any other district in the state based on where they're located.
So, I really want to applaud the efforts of the board and others who have really, you're on the right track.
I really do believe that is the real work.
It does take time, right?
So, for example, meeting even just the initial work around the geographic leads.
We worked together, we chose those leads, we brought those county offices together recently.
But we got a lot of work to do just really trying to develop some relationships with them.
Again, continuing to build trust with them and then figure out how we're going to make sure that we can scale this going forward.
The direct technical assistance that you see here,
is really related to the AB 1840.
So, I think about a month on the job, you know, I got a call and somebody said, hey, I don't know if you're aware, but there's this new bill that's coming out.
And based on that bill, districts are in fiscal distress when the CCE now will be tasked with going in and providing support to those districts.
Actually, we'd already been in Inglewood District based on the superintendent's recommendation.
We've been in Vallejo.
We've been doing some work there where the superintendent actually raised their hand
and reached out to us and said, would you come and help us?
And we said, sure, we're really interested in supporting you.
What about the county office?
They said, we've already contacted the county office.
We'd love to work with all of you.
So we'd already been doing a little bit of work.
This shifted things a little bit because now the county office was responsible for that.
So we actually have a role in there to where we are bringing those agencies all together.
We're facilitating
the work around how we're going to support the district.
And then in addition to that, we've done some academic reviews where we're looking at the districts.
What we're finding in particular in the districts that we're working with is there are multiple plans.
Even though I know we all want to be focused on the LCAP, many of them have a strategic plan.
Some of them have a FCMAT plan that they may have had a study that's been done in regards to that.
And some of them, those who are in fiscal distress, obviously have their FCMAT report that exists there as well.
And so what we're finding in the very beginning when we're looking at doing this academic review is that
We're having to spend quite a bit of time trying to figure out which plan we're going to support, right?
And making sure that they're addressing the needs of the LCAP.
So we've done some initial work.
We've actually hired Nancy Brunel and she's doing some work for us to help us do this crosswalk.
Finding it really helpful, really working with the county office to get all of us on the same page to say,
This is the plan.
These are the goals.
And this is what we're going to do over the next three to six months to really make a difference for children.
And then trying to figure out what resources we can bring to the table as well as the county office bring to the table to support the district.
Again, it's all about relationships, right?
And the importance of really developing some trust.
But again, I'm really proud of the work that we're doing.
We're doing some really neat work, and it's really about folks trusting each other.
When we're sitting at the table, so you can imagine when down in Inglewood, we have LACO at the table, and so they have their large staff that are there.
We have CD there.
We're there, we have FCMAT there, and we have the district, and we're all trying to figure out who can do what and how we're going to facilitate this and make sure that we can do our resources, but we're committed.
We've also had the Department of Finance there.
We've been meeting with them every month, and everyone is committed to being at those meetings every month.
for this entire year where our group spends about an hour and a half to two hours without the district just talking about how are we collaborating, how are we working together, how are we making sure that we're not asking the district to go to six different meetings and that we're trying to do this work together so we can really make sure that we're keeping focused on the needs of the students.
The next box here you see is the research box.
And so, and really one of the things I heard from the field quite a bit is folks are really wanting to know what works.
We hear a lot about what doesn't work and we hear a lot about where folks aren't doing well.
I think what you heard today with San Juan is an example of what works, right?
And we use this word bright spots and you would see that in some of our work too.
And that to me is a bright spot, right?
And that's something that you can see is that it's really built around
you know, capacity of working with others, that systemic approach of really trying to move forward, not kind of a one-off or a one-year where you've looked at some results and said, that's really a bright spot, because it may not be a bright spot the following year too.
But what the field is asking for is, can you show us some examples of folks who are doing good work?
Right?
And so part of our work that we want to be able to do is we think we have examples of the work we've been doing.
So some of the work that CCE's been doing, I think in particular with our partnerships, then the old pilot districts that you've heard about too, we've got some pretty impressive work where we're starting to see some real results with those districts.
We think that's an example of some of that work as well as what you heard today, as well as some other folks out there.
Last week I was in
San Bernardino.
And during that time there, San Bernardino for the last 11 years has a program that they do through the county office around the area of governance.
And so anytime that they're so 11 years ago when what they did is they hired a couple of retired superintendents who were any district that had a new superintendent, they would assign, they would go into the superintendent and say, we will give you three days, 24 hours where we're willing to give you a free service that will come together with you and your board and talk about how you're going to work together.
We'll help develop that.
protocols with you, we'll look at the superintendent's evaluation, we'll look at what the district's goals are, and we'll help you around developing those protocols just so that you can have success.
Their data shows, so the average tenure for a superintendent is about 2.7 in the state.
Theirs is over almost six.
So the superintendents in their district stay on the average of about six years.
So we want to look at that work, right?
They've done some great work.
They've evolved that work now.
They also do some things locally with their boards and having their own board association.
They do trainings every year throughout through the whole district, too.
And so they provide real direct support for that district.
And that's an example of what we find often in some of our districts that are struggling academically.
Governance sometimes is an issue, right?
And what we know about superintendent tenure is the longer they stay, right, and the longer we have those folks in those places, we tend to see higher results for students.
So that's another example, I think, of some of what we want to be able to use our resources and tools to take a look at those and figure out ways that we can make those available to the field and move forward.
The partnerships piece is really, to me, that's really built around just partnering with other folks to do the work.
that we're really not intended to go do this work by ourselves.
When I first came on, I had a lot of folks say, how are you going to fix every school district in the state that's struggling?
You're really small, whatever.
And I said, we're not built to do that.
We're built to do it collaboratively.
We're built as part of the system of support to help other folks.
But we really we need to be able to really strengthen those partnerships.
So that was an area that we're really focused on and making sure that we're really working collaboratively with other folks and trying to figure out how we can bring a resource and maximize those resources as we help folks moving forward.
And I think I just talked about every slide I had all in one slide.
I think I did.
So what I wanted to do is tell you a little bit about what some of the lessons learned in this very short time is that I think there's incredible opportunity and there's incredible challenges.
And so, as I mentioned, in some of what I would say is so governance and labor and learning to improve
So moving and shifting and really helping folks understand to learn, learning to perform is where folks have really struggled.
So the example I would give you is our partnerships.
What we do is we
We work directly with the district.
The district identifies, based on their data, the area that they want to improve on.
So they do a root cause analysis.
And then based on that work, we help them do what we call short cycles.
There's a Plan, Do, Study, Act model where we bring them, we help them develop, what are you going to do over the next three months, right, around the Plan, Do, Study, Act model on something in particular that you're going to go after based on where your students are struggling.
We bring them back for one of our summits.
We look at that work again.
We do it again.
We plan for the next cycle.
So we do that five times over the year.
And really the goal of that work is really for them really trying to learn how to improve, right?
Instead of the old system is often we would do things and we would shoot right at the result.
And the goal really here is really trying to provide
an actual way to be able to approach information and data.
So take what they've learned, so let's say they're looking at math, and take what they've learned and when they did this Plan-Do-Study-Act model, and now you can use that for any other subject area that you might be struggling in.
The other piece, too, is where I struggle a lot.
I will tell you, in particular, in the districts where, like Englewood and Vallejo, is really having the time, right?
It takes time to make these changes, right?
And it takes time to have relationships of trust.
And then at the level of the district, getting what they need and the resources in place, and then getting to a point where you can actually get things implemented and start to see student results.
At the same time, there's this huge sense of urgency that kids are struggling, right?
And trying to figure out how we balance that.
The other piece that I feel like we also struggle with at times, too, is this idea of being a thought partner, right?
This resource or critical friend.
You've heard the term tight-loose, right?
And so in our new system is, for example, when we're working with some of the districts in particular, is we're going in and we're really trying to come alongside them based on where they feel like they need to improve and help them.
The struggle with that is that in the old system, we would go in and we would tell them.
I think the answer is a little bit more in the middle.
And so I think where I'm seeing in our new system is we're spending a lot of time here in this piece of really trying to really gingerly work with folks and make sure that we can support them.
But at times, they're not doing the right thing.
They're struggling a little bit in those areas and you have these resources and tools and trying to figure out how do you bring that to the table in a way where you're not telling them what to do, but you're saying here's some opportunities, here's some things that you might really want to think about too.
So there's a real balance to that work and I think we're in the beginning stages of that.
And then this last piece, too, is this idea of prevention versus intervention.
A lot of our work, especially in this 1840, is in this intervention piece.
And I worry that we'll spend a lot of our time in that intervention side and not doing enough in the prevention side to make sure that we're not
We're doing things so folks don't need that intervention and that real balance of trying to be able to do both.
So I really feel like for the CCE in particular, we really need to be addressing both of those areas and making sure that we're balancing, you know, some of what that work looks like.
Also, the opportunities and challenges, resources, expertise, best practices, you know, just trying to make sure that there's the resources to be able to provide those things.
Scalability is difficult, trying to figure out how do you scale this next level.
I will tell you the system of support
that really I do believe is the answer, right?
This idea of now that we have these geographic leads and we have these other, they really have this responsibility to really understand what exists out there in the state and then make sure that they're a resource for their county offices and as county offices know that that's available.
Every county office would never have the ability to know all of these other things that are going on.
So,
And I think we play a pretty strong role in that as well.
And then continue to build capacity at the local level.
So the other areas that we're finding in particular with some of our districts are struggling is you can help them with the plan.
You can help them with
some of the resources, but one of the largest resources where they struggle is having folks at the district level to really be able to have the capacity to really be able to serve.
They really need more folks, right?
They need more resources to really be able to try to implement that work.
Otherwise, what happens sometimes is they get stuck at that top piece, especially those that are struggling fiscally, right?
Because there's so many fires to put out, it's really hard to be able to get the instructional piece.
And I think that's it.
So, happy to answer questions.
Can you go back to your first slide there?
I'll try.
I wanted to ask you about one of your functions.
Let's see, where are we?
There.
Okay.
You, I mean, my overall impression is you've just got so many different functions going for so few people.
And so I, you know, it's going to be difficult to accomplish, you know, all these separate goals given the size you have.
And you didn't mention much.
Well,
The last one, serve as a resource and expertise connector.
Some people have talked about CCE as being a broker of really effective non-government and government resources that are out there.
In other words, if I'm in some district and I need help on math curriculum, then you would be able to connect me or suggest somebody that I could look at.
so that it was much more of a vetting and brokerage function for different organizations that could assist districts.
So how do you think about that in terms of your brokerage role?
Yeah, well, I think we are
I don't think that we're tasked with doing that work alone.
I actually think county offices have some responsibility in that area as well as the geographic leads.
So I think in our work, especially I would say in our work around some of this research and trying to look at what, as we're looking at bright spots or other examples out there, we are trying to be very intentional about what exists, right?
Really trying to find out what are the resources, what are the other things that exist?
in particular in the field.
We have not done a lot of work in regards to these other resources that you're referencing, Dr. Kurtz, but I think some of that will come under that research bucket, right, of being able to be in that role, too.
But part of what you said, I think, at the beginning of the questions is where we struggle, right, is we are tasked with doing some work based on statute.
based on the governor's budget, based on 1840.
And we're really trying to make sure that we do that work well and really working within the system of support.
So some of our struggle will, can we do additional things of that nature or how do we try to embed those in the work that we're doing?
Okay.
Board Member Burr is our liaison and then chair.
You're still the chair of the CCE board.
So, you have the first question.
Thank you.
Well, first, I'm so glad that you were able to be here, Tom.
We've been anxiously awaiting.
I was really happy to have you here because I try to make these little reports, but now they actually get to hear from the person who's in charge of making this happen.
I just wanted to respond a little bit to President Kirst that a little bit, I think what's embedded in your question is, and I don't want to say this in a negative way, but it's a little bit grounded in the old way, in my view.
I think there were, especially in the first couple of years of the creation of CCEE and Superintendent Torlakson serves on the board with me.
there was this notion that we were going to create lists of providers.
There were lots of people out in the field raising their hands saying, hey, hey, hey, we're the experts.
We can make this happen.
And I think that Tom described it perfectly of how do you make this shift from telling people what to do to creating a relationship with them and helping them understand, just the way San Juan was describing,
What is it that we really have to get to?
How do we peel the onion back and say these are the kinds of things we need to work on?
We got in the habit at the state level and for sure at the federal level because you and I bemoaned having to approve the SCS providers.
of sending in the cavalry and that somehow the cavalry was going to rescue that LEA and tell them what to do.
And it's as Tom described and superintendent Kern and his team described, it's much more complicated than that.
And it's much more nuanced at every single LEA.
So I think there is a role for CCE in helping to identify bright spots, to say what's working, to give these examples.
If you're having a governance issue, here's some people that might be able to provide you with some guidance.
So I think it is much more complicated, much more time-consuming, but it's worth it.
I think especially when you hear districts talk about the kinds of breakthroughs that they've had.
And the pilot partnerships, or we call them pilots, now we call them partnerships, that CCEE has worked with have had some very powerful ideas.
We heard from Anaheim
the superintendent in Anaheim a couple meetings ago who said, boy, we're struggling so much with our EL students.
We have to figure out what to do.
And they're partnering now with Cal State Fullerton to completely change their teacher credentialing program and to really create grow your own programs in Anaheim to get at that issue.
So I just think
There's so much power here.
I'm very excited about it.
I just want to, again, want to say how much I appreciate Tom being here.
And I think that it's also, it reinforces the notion that the first line of assistance is the county office.
And what the CCE is really trying to do is build the capacity of those county offices through a bunch of different ways, all of these different leads.
And that we, and then there's those local relationships are really critical.
And I really appreciate, again, what San Juan said about not so happy about seeing SCOE, but actually when they showed up, they were pretty helpful because the counties have made, it's a little bit like the department, right?
We're from Sacramento and we're here to help.
But they have made, the counties have made that shift.
They're not all of them, but they're certainly in that mode.
And I think that it's really going to prove to be an incredibly powerful system.
So again, Tom, thanks for being here.
Other board member comments?
Board member Ortiz-Lacon.
Thank you.
And thank you for the presentation.
I think my comments are going to be relatively broad.
I do appreciate the way that the system of support is developing.
This looks like a robust system.
The initial drafts, it was very anemic structure, you know.
But as I look at this, I also understand that there are some capacity issues.
And we were having a conversation last week, we as in my other role,
with the superintendent of L.A.
County and LAUSD.
And you have two million students in L.A.
County.
You have 80 LEAs.
And so when you think of that volume alone and you try to fit an L.A.
County into the structure, you realize that it is perhaps a structure that has very limited capacity to assist.
And so I'm still very interested in seeing how this is going to play out.
And I also appreciate our presentation,
earlier from San Juan Unified when they said we're not interested in fixing numbers, we're really interested in exploring the root cause.
So I want to be a critical friend right now and a critical comadre with a sense of urgency because I know that we have not directly addressed the academic indicators.
And I know that as a state board, we took a stance when we said we're not adopting a summative rating because we knew that that would be primarily absorbed by the academic indicators.
But they are still indicators.
And they are still two state indicators that we need to focus on.
My son started third grade this year.
And day one, I said, you know, Papa, this is going to be a really big year.
My favorite teacher, Miss Gilmore, was my third grade teacher.
And then it just slipped.
And I said, and this year, you take the S back.
And before I could take it back, he said, what's the SBAC?
And then I said, OK, I'm all in, because now I already told him.
And I said, you know, Papito, it's a really big, he wants to go to Stanford.
I said, it's a really big test.
And if you want to get to Stanford, you have to do really well.
And I'm sorry, I'm a parent.
And no one here could deny that that is one thing that we would focus on.
So when I'm looking at our SBAC test scores,
I want to explore the root cause.
I want us to model that process of continuous improvement and see what is causing the flat growth.
Why are we seeing declines in 11th grade?
We're seeing some hope in 3rd and 4th grade, but what can account for this?
Right?
And I think it's important for us to model that, because even if we don't want to narrow the conversation, somebody else is having the conversation.
And I think it's important for us to get ahead of that conversation and really show intent in trying to understand this pattern.
So I'm wondering, as we're providing support,
How are we using the interim targets that are page 31 and 33 of your estate plans, if you haven't seen those?
We have state targets.
We have seven-year state-determined targets for each of the indicators, and we have outlined interim targets.
Most people don't know we have those, and we're already behind, because we were supposed to make an A-point gain for African-American students in ELA, and I think 10 points in math.
we're already behind on our first year of targets.
So how can we use those better?
How do we bring light to the fact that this may not be the end all, but it's important for us to consider these state indicators as well.
I don't know if I have an answer.
If somebody does, I'm open to it.
But the
Where I think we're still struggle when I've seen in some of the districts are working in I saw I was prior to this position I was a county soup for 11 years and the district soup prior to that too and as a county soup To I found I still think the we have a long ways to go to make the LCAP actionable I think the LCAP is still and even in these other districts.
I'm talking about they develop a strategic plan because
Of course, there's more in the strategic plan, just the academic piece, right?
And so I get that piece too.
But I think often they're trying to take, I still think we've got a ways to go to not have that be such a large compliance document and trying to figure out how we can make it much more actionable, get at some of that specific data that you're talking about.
I think folks are still struggling with that.
There's just so much in there that piece to do too.
You know, all I can tell you, I think, and Sam, I'm sure, can speak to this, too, is that what I'm finding in some of these, again, some of these districts that we're working with is really trying to figure out what's the strong issues in their data that they need to go after, right?
And when we're doing these short cycles with our partnerships, too,
we are starting to see some growth on things that they target, right, and go strongly after and put a lot of resources after those things and then use good models, right, to really be able to do it.
You would think everybody understands that Plan-Do-Study-Act model, but they don't, right?
And so really trying to make sure that there's providing them some models and some opportunities to really come together and go after those individually with the hopes that that's where we'll see the improvement.
Any other board member comments?
Oh, Karen Valdez.
Thank you so much for being here today.
I have to say that the graphic really helps.
You have evolved as an entity, if you will, and so I appreciate all of that information.
I think your honest feedback from the meeting with superintendents in Santa Barbara is the current reality that the workforce doesn't know as much as we assume that they know, so I appreciate that conversation that we had and how we move forward in making sure
that the leaders truly understand what the system is about and the clear intent.
I think that's still a challenge.
And I think that the work that you're doing in terms of helping districts understand that they just need one plan and which plan is going to lead them.
And your work around PDSA, I think, is very celebrated.
I think that's the right work and that it's iterative and that fail forward to get better, I think, is part of the work that you're doing.
So I think many districts are in cognitive dissonance.
I mean, they know they need to do some things.
They know something is coming.
They're not clear yet what that something is, and that really is a partnership.
But within that, I think it's going to be very, very valued.
All of the resources and the things that you shared today are in place, and that you really value relationships and trust.
And I think under the human condition, because these are people leading all of this work, that is really, really important.
That's the cornerstone.
And that the things aren't competing, that they're really completing each other.
So the graphic that shows how CCEE fits in in terms of the whole system, I really appreciated seeing that.
And I think it clarifies for them the role.
And I think there were assumptions about what CCEE might do, and now it's much clearer.
I think they picked the right person to do the work.
I really appreciate the vulnerability and the honesty that you have in terms of, I don't know, we'll figure it out.
And I think we will figure it out together.
And so I really, really want to thank you for the presentation today.
Well, I also want to lend my voice to the chorus of folks who are thankful that you were here today and also thankful that you are the person who was selected to lead the work of the collaborative, particularly at this time.
We're in the middle of a transition of a lot of work at multiple levels in this state today.
And it's tempting in a transition to take a look at other ways of going or other ways of considering this work, particularly given the frustration
that many feel with not knowing or having a real clear picture about what the actual next steps are.
So I also appreciated the graphic that was created today.
It gives a better and clearer mental model, not only of your work, but also the
organizational structure, the network of what this system of support really looks like.
I think the biggest transition we're going through right now is this transition from very linear and even one-dimensional thinking about what intervention is to looking more at a systems approach and doing real systems thinking.
Systems thinking is not something we have ever been good at.
And that's because we have only looked at one element of accountability, which is the outcome, instead of holding the whole system accountable in a more reciprocal way for inputs as well as processes.
Because some of the systemic and longstanding concerns that San Juan talked about, like the overwhelming amount of suspensions of African-American students, which outpaces their actual enrollment,
as a student group is not a new problem.
It's been a longstanding problem.
And the fact is, it's never been addressed.
It's never been well addressed.
And they are finally trying to have a conversation that holds the system itself accountable, not only for how the students are treated, but how the adults in the system are treated as well.
Those are important and intentional conversations that nobody previously has wanted to have.
And that's very important.
But more important than that is your process, the organization that's being laid here, represents a commitment through this transition to keep doing this very hard work.
It's so much easier to have a binary idea about accountability, either yes, you did it or no, we check this box and keep going.
It's more difficult to focus on the sustained focus on continuous improvement and leaning forward
to the work rather than stepping back and saying, see, I knew that wasn't going to work either.
So I really do appreciate your honesty in today's conversation.
We're going to have to have more honest conversation because this work is going to continue at a pace that will be frustratingly slow for a lot of folks.
But the fact is, this is what's actually going to yield the outcomes that we're actually saying we want rather than the outcomes that we just give lip service to.
So I really do appreciate what you did today.
and what you came here to talk about.
Thank you.
Board member Strauss.
Well, Tom, thanks again for being here and for bringing the parts connected.
And I think that's the issue that we have statewide as you look at how all the pieces fit together as a whole.
And I think that's the issue that district and site leadership have as well.
And as we're out in school districts thinking about all these different pieces and what you actually focus on, that role, and as you describe, whether it's the broker or the resource connector, I think that's a really important role.
Because I know when people were doing all these things, they weren't making any progress on maybe much of anything.
And I think, but they're working really hard.
And so I thought you said it's an incredible opportunity, but it has incredible challenges, really does grasp the work ahead, but how we're really trying to think about this differently.
And I think this year going forward is really important because people are now, okay, so what's next?
What's happening?
I think your voice and your experiences brings that together at a really important time with a really small team to try to do that.
So I think districts looking at someone who's had district and county leadership roles and statewide looking at that, I think will be really helpful to our work going forward.
And so the I think the lessons that we'd like to see going forward is and as we look at standards work and implementation of the work and around what member Ortiz Lincoln said around our equity gaps and our achievement gaps and I know we have some accountability more that we're going to be doing today in our meeting but
I think that's something obviously we've tried to put the systems in place to try to address that but I think the gaps in achievement that we see statewide still are a big concern and I know that your role in focusing on what should we spend our time focusing on and I appreciate the loose tight comment and I think it is it's not just
We'll be there and you know best, but it's also they're looking for the outside resource to help focus them.
So that loose, tight balance of, I think, is a different place from, OK, we're here and you just do all this, we'll hammer you really hard.
But I do think it's in the middle.
So I think your lessons as you stay in the loop and continue to do the work this year will be helping inform and going forward.
So I just want to thank you for the way that you connected all the pieces together and excited about seeing the work ahead.
Thank you.
Board Member Williams.
I want to thank you for your presentation as well.
I understand CC better than I have before.
This isn't one of my liaison roles, so I haven't spent a lot of in-depth time thinking about how it's going, and I know Sue has, and I trust that and count on that.
But a thought occurred to me as I was listening to you talk about it, and especially the dichotomy that you put up there between a sense of urgency versus
the need for time.
And then as I was listening to Feliza mention urgency, a sense of urgency, I do think that we've spent a great deal of time over many years on this board putting new systems into place and trying to make sure that they're all well aligned and carefully articulated.
And I would hope, I have two points I want to make.
I would hope that the board going forward, which won't include me after January, but I would hope that the board going forward would start spending more time talking about the academic outcomes in California and where we are and whether we're meeting our goals and whether we're meeting them with all groups and why and develop a little bit more sense of urgency around that.
That's one point I want to make.
And another one is that to the extent that there could be more funding going to K-12, if there's a ballot initiative around Prop 13 that might wind up getting passed with more funding, whether it's a bond initiative,
If the new governor's behind more funding to K-12, both SPI candidates are behind it to the extent there could be an infusion of more money going to K-12.
I would encourage you as you're doing this work,
to be thinking not only what difference could that make to your organization, where would you put it, what could make the most difference, but also as you're talking to districts and helping them with their struggles, having them start thinking if that, without getting their hopes up, you know, unnecessarily, but if there were,
Where could you put it district that it would make the most difference for you thinking just anticipating that potential possibility and thinking ahead about it as part of the work that you're doing in your own organization as well as with the districts that are struggling?
Okay.
Yeah, I like that.
And I think districts probably have that list already.
And I think they do have a pretty large list.
I do.
I want to, I guess, just finalize my comments to that.
Yeah, that loose tight concept is something I think we have to speak more of.
And in particular, where
where we have this data that's shown we're not improving, we're going to have to move a little bit more in this direction, I think, in particular.
And that's not telling people what to do, but really being able to provide them opportunities of here's some examples of what to do, and here's some resources to support that.
And really be going after that work, too, because my experience, again, is both as a county SOUP 2, I had very few superintendents who I worked with and I continue to see across the state that aren't working extremely hard and don't care about children.
They were working very, very hard.
Some of them not doing some of the right work, needing some more direction, some inexperience about what to do, and more examples of ways that they can do it better.
But a lot of folks are working really, really hard.
and just really struggling as we've struggled for many, many years.
So I think we just have to be careful.
That's the piece I keep saying on this piece.
I love what we're doing around the systems support.
I love this idea of coming alongside folks.
But I also feel like we can't spend too much time just standing next to them.
We've got to really be able to do more to be able to help them with resources and tools and practices.
Thank you.
I appreciate the opportunity to be here.
And if ever you have wanted to speak more about or learn more about CC, feel free to contact me.
I would love to talk to you more.
I'm always interested in your ideas.
And I really want to thank, in particular, Tom and Sue.
I was telling folks at our last board meeting, I have an incredibly unique board.
It was really cool.
I mean, it's really different than any other board I've worked with, right?
Because I have incredible experience on that board.
I have a district superintendent who's amazing, right?
I have state board members, a state superintendent, a teacher on that board, you know, a county superintendent.
And, well, you can't get much by them, that's for sure.
They're like, what about that?
And what about this?
But they're actually very, very helpful on really, I think, what a board is intended to do to really help shape kind of to make sure that you're going in the right direction.
So thank you.
All right, thank you.
We're ready for public comment.
Would the following people please line up?
Rigel Massaro, Brian Rivas, Elizabeth Robitaille, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, and Danny Espinosa.
Good morning, President Kuerst, Superintendent Horlickson, and members of the board.
My name is Rigel Massaro, an attorney with Public Advocates.
Public Advocates is a member of the LCFF Equity Coalition, which submitted a letter aligned with my comments.
We continue to support the direction of the system of support, and we're very heartened by the comments we heard today from San Juan and CCE Director
We particularly appreciate the inclusion of groups representing and advocating on behalf of students and communities of color and low-income and immigrant students and communities in the system of support planning group.
Thus, we are a bit concerned about Item 3's proposal to reduce the planning group meetings by 50% from bimonthly to quarterly.
And we think this may reduce consistent and meaningful stakeholder input.
We would instead appreciate more opportunities to participate, such as in the planning group or including stakeholders in other work groups, at least periodically, if not at every meeting.
We want to help teach LEAs how to swaddle.
I also want to recommend that the system of support give greater focus to the substantive areas.
Three, engaging in continuous improvement, the new EL roadmap, and teacher and leader retention along the lines of what we heard happening in San Juan.
Thank you.
Elizabeth Robitaille on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
As Senior Vice President of CCSA's school performance, development, and support, I can assure you that the California Charter Schools Association cares deeply about meaningful, robust accountability for charter schools.
We believe that it should be based first and foremost on increasing student learning for all students.
And where charter schools aren't delivering on that promise, CCSA has a decade-long track record of publicly advocating for these charter schools' non-renewal.
But we are concerned about how the statewide system of support will translate into charter school accountability.
What for traditional districts and schools is a system designed for support can lead to punitive school closure consequences for charter schools.
Right now charter schools are the afterthought in the development of a system and yet the linking of LCFF ESSA comprehensive support to LCFF differentiated assistance could have dramatic unintended high stakes consequences for charter schools.
Thus we respectfully urge the state board and the department to clarify that for a charter school
The school will only be referred for assistance in accordance with the standards and procedures of Ed Code section 476073.
Thank you.
President Kirst, I'm Brian Rivas speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
First, I want to say thank you to Member Ortiz-Licn and Member Williams.
We agree with your comments about the need for urgency in this conversation.
But I'll also say I think there's quite a bit of common ground in this discussion.
Lots of us out there are rooting for the success of the system supports.
And I want to compliment your staff for the presentation showing how the various elements work together.
It's helpful for those of us who are rooting for the support of this effort to be able to explain how it fits together.
We agree with our colleagues in the Equity Coalition about the planning group.
Right now it feels like those meetings feel like a report out on work that's being done between meetings.
We'd like to see a little more of an opportunity to have input and to
how the work is being done, and we'd also like to see the English learner roadmap integrated into all the levels of assistance.
Good morning.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, and I'm representing the Californians Together and California Association for Bilingual Education.
I would like to thank the board staff and department staff and their continued work on the evolution of the system of support.
I'm here to really ask the state board to advise technical assistance providers to integrate more thoughtfully and systematically the new EL roadmap into all three levels of support.
This would provide a foundation for English learners, high-quality programs and instruction rooted in research and best practices.
Each technical assistance provider working with LEAs that have an EL subgroup should be knowledgeable about the state policy this board approved unanimously and reinforced by the regs adopted by the board for the implementation of Proposition 58.
Doing so would ensure that any level of support provided to LEAs results in practices and instructional strategies leading to improved language development and academic performance for our EL students.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Daniel Espinoza from the Learning Policy Institute.
We appreciate the progress towards constructing a system of support and as part of the system LPI encourages the board to consider developing a professional learning infrastructure for educators that would support all levels in the system.
This infrastructure would ensure that across the state there's an adequate supply of standards aligned high quality professional learning
so that all schools and districts interested in improving student performance in all major areas can get access to that support.
Rather than just waiting for districts to struggle and directing counties and CCEE to pick up the pieces after they have fallen over the cliff, these offerings would build a fence at the top
and help prevent failure.
For example, for an LEA whose dashboard data points to need to focus on English learners, support should include access to resources and intensive professional learning opportunities focused on better serving English learners.
The same might be said of math instruction or serving special education students.
There's a great deal of expertise that exists within the state, including in the California Subject Matter Projects, a number of county initiatives, and in the Instructional Leadership Corps.
But these are not sufficient in scale to meet school's needs, nor coordinated and made known in a manner that allows them to be accessed by those who need them.
Time.
Also, there should be similar supports for California school principals.
There's in the latest Getting Down to Facts survey,
Nine out of ten principals identified a need for professional development and standards, developing a whole child approach, and supporting school staff.
Thank you.
President Kurst, members of the board, Dean Drescher here on behalf of EdVoice.
I just want to quickly echo your comments, board member Ortiz-Lycone, and thank you for them as well.
We too are super concerned by the decline in 11th grade scores and urge the board to push for understanding more clearly what's behind that.
We also agree that the state interim targets laid out in the ESSA plan are really important guideposts.
And are absolutely important in the work moving forward because as you said quite well, Board Member Williams, academics matter and the achievement gaps in this state need be addressed with all urgency.
Thank you.
Good morning, State Board.
My name is Ephraim Mercado from Children Now.
I just want to say that we're very optimistic about the development and evolution of the system of support.
Specifically, the identification of the lead counties as a GEO leads really shows that the focus is on expertise and capacity as opposed to past practice of selecting the regional leads.
So we're really optimistic about that as well.
Specifically, we'd like to recommend that the state conduct a level one support analysis across the board to identify what's happening and to help direct funding currently and in the future to help those supports, to perhaps consider a third party evaluator for the system of support planning group and that work, to have an outside view of what's happening as opposed to a group that's very intimately involved, and then to support what Martha said about the EL roadmap being integrated into all three levels.
Thank you.
Eric Premack with the Charter Schools Development Center.
We share our colleagues concern at the Charter Schools Association about the misfit between the
charter aspects of this and intervention and other aspects of this and think that this needs to be thought through much more carefully.
We were talking about kind of a swaddling metaphor with respect to school districts.
The metaphor with respect to charter schools, you might think of more as kind of getting kicked out of the nest with revocation being
at the end of the chain there.
So our concerns here at times are much more serious and urgent.
Our shop has been engaged with CCEE starting with Dr. Cohen and continuing with Tom Armolino.
We're operating two of the PLNs and trying to find our way through this just like everybody else.
The disconnect though between
Charter flexibility, state law, and the ESSA plan continues to be very problematic, makes it very difficult for us to do our work.
And we think that there needs to be some serious careful thinking about this misfit in the square peg in the round hole.
So we appreciate any work you guys can do to encourage that.
Thank you.
Good morning, Andrea Ball on behalf of the California School Boards Association.
And first, I want to thank you so much for having that presentation by the district from San Juan Unified and including a board member.
And I think it was back at the May meeting when board member Burke made a note or noted that it would be interesting to hear from a school district.
on the implementation and development of the system of support and CSBA is pleased you had one today and encourages you to schedule additional presentations from districts, especially as new members come onto the board next year.
CSBA is supportive of the development of the way the system of support is moving.
Since LCFF was enacted, CSBA has engaged in professional learning.
We're operating two networks or partnerships with CCE where we include board members and superintendents.
One is for rural districts to come together and one is for just a cross section.
And I think the learnings there, which we have shared out, are very helpful to share with other districts as we move forward.
Finally, I just want to call attention, I gave you a link to a survey that we published on board members' views of LCFF, just real brief.
I think you'll be pleased to know two-thirds of them reported that LCFF has helped them in their local decision-making, engaging stakeholders, and serving students.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Caitlin Jung on behalf of the Small School Districts Association.
We just wanted to thank all the partners and for the work they've done in building the system support.
Small school districts have found it very helpful and we've appreciated being part of the planning group and we look forward to further involvement as the system continues to be built out.
Good morning, LeAngela Reed on behalf of AXA.
So my colleague came and presented the comments on SSTA.
I'm sure she'll kill me later.
So AXA would like to thank the boards, CDE, CCE and SESSA for the opportunity to be involved in the planning group and the communications work group.
They feel that that's been essential to creating a common message and ensuring mutual understanding of the emerging system of support.
And I think all of us that have participated agree with that tremendously.
As the system, as the state's second phase of this system of support gets underway,
They've gotten some feedback that it would be helpful to have some talking points on differentiated assistance, particularly for the new sites that are eligible in 2018 and haven't been because I'm sure that you're all working on that.
But that's something they think would be very important.
They also appreciate sort of the update on the lead agencies and look forward as we build out the capacity in those under their those lead agencies and the work moving forward.
And finally, they look forward to partnering with state agencies and providing feedback in February and May to provide information from their leadership assembly.
So, thank you and thanks for accepting everything.
Okay, we're going to...
We'll resume at 11.25 with a special ceremony for our state superintendent.
So we'll get ready for that.
So the State Board will reconvene.
Do I have six?
I want to wait for our members.
Thank you.
Please reconvene.
All right.
So we're now going to pause in our regular agenda before moving on to item four to acknowledge that this is State Superintendent Torlakson's final meeting with us.
And so I just wanted to remind people of some of his background.
He earned his bachelor's and master's degrees and teaching credential from UC Berkeley.
And he started his career as a teacher in the Costa County's Mount Diablo Unified School District.
And then he has been on the ballot for more than 40 years.
And he began on the Antioch City Council, the Contra Costa County Board of Supervisors, and then was elected to the California State Senate and State Assembly before being elected state superintendent of public instruction twice.
in the past eight years.
Tom has also served the United States as a fireman in the United States Merchant Marine, earning the Vietnam Service Medal.
So as we think about yesterday's election,
thinking about how hard it is to get elected and how hard you worked on this.
I mean, it's a tremendous achievement to run in a huge state like this and win twice.
And I think we're really understanding and grasping that.
It's been a pleasure to work with you.
I think our working relationship between the board and the state superintendent is really the highest standard of collaboration and cooperation that I have seen since working here on state policy starting in 1969.
So, I think we really have been able to work at the staff level.
The relationships there are really strong.
And I think you and I have had a history of friendship and trust that will go on for a very long period of time after both of us leave these positions.
So, without further ado, I'm going to ask Glenn Price to make some remarks and to introduce a brief video.
Thank you, President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, Executive Director Steph Walters, and board members.
I also, just before I get into our main topic here, Superintendent Torlakson, I wanted to extend my thanks to you.
It's been a real pleasure for me to serve under your leadership and guidance and policymaking, in my opinion, and echoing your comments.
President Kerr, you are without doubt
the finest state board of education that this state has ever seen.
And it's been evidenced by your history of innovation and public service and everything you've done.
So thank you for allowing me to be of service.
By the same token, it'd be impossible for me to stand here today without channeling in some way a group that I think we kind of loosely refer to as Team Torlakson.
And if you walk around a little bit in Sacramento or the state of California,
It's almost impossible not to run into amazing people in county boards, in boards of education, in county offices, over at First 5 California, wherever you go, there are extended members of the Torlakson Network.
And so I'm kind of channeling, Tom, today some of their appreciation for you as well.
And the existence of this great group of people is really in itself an indicator of your ability to coach and mentor us.
So we appreciate that.
You know, speaking of coaching and mentoring, I first met, I don't go back the whole 40 years, President Kurz, but I first met Superintendent Torgson about 25 years ago when I was a parent activist in the West Contra Costa Unified School District and running for school board.
And I went to a campaign event and I met then candidate, Assemblymember Torgson, or then Supervisor Torgson, running for assembly.
Of course, I became immediately intrigued by the idea of an educator running for the state legislature, and that was the beginning of an incredible friendship.
To kind of go into detail over the past 25 years would take way more time than we have today.
From those initial adventures that we had together, Superintendent Torlakson, working with people like Senator Leroy Green to secure the funding for Hercules Middle High School and West Contra Costa Unified, to obviously these most recent years here at the Department of Education.
It's been a great journey and it would take literally hours and hours to detail all of your great work.
But if we just take a minute to reflect back to where we were in 2010 and the state of fiscal emergency that this state was experiencing and then fast forward to today and thinking about just the presentations that we just had as indicators of all the work that's been done around accountability, around support systems and everything in between.
really about the California way that you have so articulately outlined division for.
It's clear to me, Superintendent Torlakson, that so much of this would not have happened without your leadership ability and about your great coaching and mentoring ability to bring together teams.
So I just want you to know that I am tremendously proud of you.
I'm still inspired by your incredible 80-hour work weeks.
I don't know how you do that and keep it going.
But most of all, around your incredible ability to keep bringing together coaching and mentoring extraordinary teams has really been outstanding.
And I know I speak for the entire staff of the Department of Education in expressing that gratitude.
So speaking of expressions, I want to just start up now, and so doing with a big shout out to Cynthia Butler in our communications department, a brief video outlining some of the work of Superintendent Torgson.
California has embarked on a journey to transform the largest K-12 education system in the nation.
The goal is to make our 6.2 million students ready for career in college in the 21st century.
We have raised academic standards in many subjects and changed our funding system to give more money to those with the greatest needs and more local control over spending.
We have also started a new way to evaluate our schools that provides a wealth of valuable information to parents and the public.
California has made these changes with remarkable support from virtually all segments of our state, educators, teachers, and lawmakers.
Our journey has become known as the California Way.
The California Way is all about team building, developing broad consensus among all the key stakeholders in education, schools, and California around our common goals.
Our goals, starting with the Common Core,
We had consensus where other parts of the nation, other states could not find common ground.
We were able to find common ground and implement the Common Core with enthusiasm.
The business community was there, the teachers were there, parents ready to embrace this change for more rigorous education, for better preparing our young people for competitive global economy, for their need to have the skills to survive right here at home in California in whatever jobs they will take up.
Our new standards, our new goals in science education are extremely rigorous, deep learning.
The new next generation science standards we're implementing in California with great enthusiasm.
I'm a former science teacher.
I'm especially pleased to see how the education community and parents are embracing this new way of thinking.
We've seen a significant increase in graduation rates from 72 percent just seven, eight years ago.
to now 82% graduation rates.
We've also invested heavily in the California way in career technical education.
Here we see graduation rates more in the range of 95 to 97% because students are enthused, it's hands-on learning, it's connected to the real world, and they see the purpose of their learning in their future and what they could do equipped with the right knowledge.
Our voters have seen the value of the high goals and high standards we've set and have said yes to invest in our California schools.
Just in the last election cycle, we had a ballot measure that gave $9 billion to improving our school facilities and a $7 billion annual commitment of a higher tax to invest in our schools.
We also saw the merit and reached consensus about redistributing the funding that we do have.
to target the students that need it the most.
So in California, students growing up in poverty, English learners, and foster kids, their schools are going to get more funding because you need more resources to reach those students, to reach and teach those students and have them succeed.
So in California, out of an $80 billion education budget, we shifted $10 billion, almost 13% shifted to the school districts and schools with the greatest needs.
We have a blend of local control
with state assistance coming in to help and regional assistance building up as part of the teamwork.
A new focus for the California Way is dual language immersion and biliteracy.
Global California 2030 is an initiative where we want to dramatically increase bilingual education in California, the teaching and learning of world languages.
Biliteracy has so many benefits.
It helps students excel in all their classes, gives our students a broader perspective, and prepares them for the global economy.
Learning a second language is good for the brain.
So these are some of the ways we define the California way.
It's about the future.
It's about equipping our students with the ability to understand and discover their own inner strengths and talents and to hone those strengths and talents to be successful.
OK, Tom, do you want to make some remarks?
Well, thank you all.
I was asked to make remarks to keep it between 50 minutes and 60 minutes.
But I didn't know it was going to be a broader thank you opportunity.
But I'm going to take advantage of the opportunity to say thanks around.
And just thank you, Mike, for our friendship, for your leadership, your incredible, hardworking, visionary.
Council is wise and you're always there with very thoughtful ways of penetrating to the bottom of what the issues are and what the choices are to move forward.
And I can't thank you enough for that leadership and friendship.
And we get together before every board meeting and have dinner together.
talk about family and travels and other fun things like that might.
And then, Glenn, thank you for your kind comments and incredible leadership.
Karen, thank you for your leadership.
The whole board, I can't say enough what a delight it's been to work with you.
and to forge forward to get to public policy.
What I notice about the board is you do this teamwork.
We've accomplished so much, and what we've been able to accomplish has been through teamwork.
And it's been with mutual trust, respect, candid, often passionate debates and dialogue here very often.
And that's good.
That's healthy.
And that's why we're here.
That's what our job is as the State Board.
And so I say thank you also to the incredible staff of the State Board of the Department of Education.
for your terrific dedication to all of our students, our schools, our teachers, our districts.
And that leadership you provided has helped us move through a time of great transformation, filled with some anticipation, some anxiety.
But around the state, I've seen educators in the classroom and the administrative offices embracing the change and working to make it work.
I want to say a big thank you to those who come to these chambers quite often to be heard.
And it was so great to hear from the youth today, wasn't it?
We are assured, as you said, Sue, that our future is in good hands when we see the talent and articulate way that these young people are viewing the world and the issues they're ready to tackle.
So we have made progress.
You all, we all are the California way.
And that tremendous progress is coming a long way.
Glenn mentioned it.
When I first took office eight years ago, I declared a state of financial emergency.
We had already been laying off 10, 20,000.
We were looking at 30,000 teacher layoffs, 20,000 layoffs of classified employees, programs being dismantled.
Science put it on the back burner.
Arts put on the back burner.
Programs dismantled.
It was chaos.
Morale was in a free fall in our schools.
And we said, no, we're not going to let it happen.
We're going to invite the public in to see the great work going on, the great learning, the great teaching, the inspiring educators.
And the public gained confidence in what we were doing and said yes to invest, as I said in the video.
So we did endure, we did persevere, and we made that progress together.
And I want to thank the voters of California for being willing to invest in education.
And by the way, in 2016, 165 ballot measures, local ballot measures from school districts also went before the voters.
And 95% of those were endorsed and voted on positively by voters.
bringing in another $15 billion of investment for our public schools.
So again, the voters said yes to invest.
So it is amazing to think how we built so much positive change and how we've changed the way our schools are funded, upgraded what our students learn, and how they are tested and brought an entirely new system of evaluating our schools.
The famous dashboard, the California School Dashboard, and giving us useful data to help guide instruction.
And we heard a lot today, and I'm so proud of the work, the collaboration, the team that's behind our system of support.
I think all of you who are implementing this out-of-the-silos system, I thank you all, because it's out-of-the-boxes, out-of-the-silos, and it's leveraging our opportunities and our skills and experiences together.
I think we've also had the progress of implementing the Common Core.
Again, I mentioned in the video with less controversy because we took the time to talk to the business community.
We took the time to talk to parents.
We took the time to talk to teachers about what Common Core meant, and it was embraced.
I think perhaps now, more than ever, a key part of the Common Core is problem-solving, critical thinking, and perhaps
Now more than ever, we need that where's the evidence, continually asking where's the evidence, why, how, being able to distinguish between facts and alternative facts, news and fake news.
These are science skills and life skills, but they're important skills in our political system, I think, too, as well.
So I had to make that comment.
You know where it comes from.
So the graduation rates was mentioned, all-time high, our suspension rates having dropped dramatically.
It's fantastic.
Eligibility to University of California and for our Cal State University system has increased significantly, particularly for Latino and African-American students.
And I want to thank the School District of California for supporting our Safe Haven School Program, which basically said all parents are welcome, all students are welcome.
We want you in our schools.
We want you to feel safe and comfortable in our schools.
And so we celebrate our diversity in California.
Our diversity is our strength.
And I was pleased that so many districts took a strong stand to protect our parents, regardless of their immigration status.
I say, debemos construir puentes, no muros, which is, I believe we must build bridges, not walls, and spend the money on building those bridges of communication and understanding.
And we can do that through language, and that's part of the 2030 Global California Initiative.
So I was continually inspired.
I have a passion for education.
You all have a passion for education.
That's why we're here as a teacher and coach.
I was continually inspired by my students and their desire to learn.
My father was a teacher and a school principal.
And so I picked up a good deal of inspiration seeing him in action during the years.
My interest was further stimulated when I joined the Merchant Marine as a fireman right out of high school and traveled the world.
And we taught KwaZulu-Lim, Guam, and Vietnam, to name a few places.
And what I noticed that I enjoyed sharing what I knew
about the winds and the tides, climate issues, marine life, coral reefs, how the oceans work as a system.
And I found out I liked teaching and it worked.
What I also found out that most of the sailors I worked with hadn't finished high school, yet they were smart and talented, bright and knowledgeable.
and knew so many practical things like how to fix things, just how to fix things.
A real important skill around the house, right?
But whether it's pumps or boilers or condensers or refrigeration units or generators, they knew how to fix things and they were comfortable with their skills and those were valuable skills and they were paid well for their talents.
So I'm very glad, too, and I want to say thank you to all who've worked on this hands-on, real-world learning.
The CTE has come a long way, and the graduation rates reflect that.
Finally, every time I see my three grandsons, my passion for improving education for all is renewed and it is energized.
I see Anthony, Mateo, and Milo, Milo's just a year now, constantly curious, endlessly exploring, yearning for learning.
And isn't that what we want for all of our students, to keep that
sense of inquisitiveness and curiosity alive.
And those are skills for life and build self-confidence, which builds good results.
So I call you, I say we are, you are, we are the dream team for education.
Over the years, I'm so proud of the friendships that we've been able to forge and look around and see so many of you that we've worked closely together and have friendships that will last for a lifetime.
I'm looking forward to a new phase.
Obviously, term limits dictates direction in some of these things, but I will still, in my new phase, it will revolve around education.
I'll still be right with you, be assured.
I hope to be, I will be close by, standing with you with high hopes and high expectations.
We will move forward, preparing and empowering our students to make their dreams come true.
And because of you, and because of what I see in the classroom, and because of what I see in the students I've had the pleasure of meeting, I am optimistic about where the California education system is going.
And I want to say thank you for your optimism.
Are we optimistic?
We're here because we believe we can make change that's positive and lasting.
So I want to thank you for your optimism and for your commitment.
Thanks so much.
It's been a great journey.
Thank you.
I want to give some other board members a chance to say anything if they want to.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Yeah, I'm probably one of the newer board members.
I've only been working with you for four years.
I was in part of the sacramental circles before I joined the board.
And so when I asked somebody, well, what is the relationship between the department and the state board?
They said, well, historically, it's been a hot mess, quote unquote.
That was a quote.
They said, but now it seems like it's working out.
And I do agree.
And I think it's working out because it has to come from leadership, right?
As somebody who came into the state board and not really having the relationships here in Sacramento, one of the things that have impressed me the most from your leadership is that following the presidential election, you set forth the Safe Havens Resolution, which meant a lot to undocumented, immigrant, and DREAMers.
And I work nationally.
No other state board, no other state superintendent had done the same.
And we were looking to California, and we were looking at those resolutions, those templates, to try to encourage others to send the same message.
Because from the highest office, you're saying, you belong.
We care for you.
This is a safe haven.
Schools are for you.
And I think that's an important message to communicate to all our students, that our schools are safe havens.
Not only our immigrant students, but students in general.
And I think you've done a really great job in doing that.
You've put English learners on the radar and given platforms and visibility for our English learner students.
And right before your term ends, you promote the Global California Initiative 2030.
So I think that all of those things reinforce the message of inclusivity, the message that we are one California, a very diverse California, but one for our students.
So I thank you for your leadership.
We're going to miss you.
I know we're going to see you in different circles, but I just wanted to thank you.
So, Tom, you know, I'm a high school English teacher, so I have to rely on the words of other folks to say a lot of the things that I feel.
Lewis Carroll wrote, The time has come, the walrus said, to talk of many things, of shoes and ships and sealing wax, of cabbages and kings.
This is a time to talk about statesmanship.
A lot of people use that word and they don't know how to use it well.
You came to this office.
You didn't have to lie to get here.
You didn't have to put a target on somebody's back and blame them for the failure of the school system.
You blamed the system, and you focused on how to fix it, and you focused on how to bring everybody to a table to sit and talk together.
You created parity.
You created a hopeful vision and a wish list that actually pulled all of us into the same room and pulled all of us
along in the same momentum.
That's what true statesmanship really looks like.
And that's a wonderful legacy to leave behind.
But you didn't just do it here with a bully pulpit of being the state superintendent.
You did it when you were a state senator.
And in initiating a lot of policy concerning PE instruction, making sure that PE had parity in the curriculum with academic subjects.
You did it in the conversation on career and technical education saying it shouldn't be an either or choice for students that all students should have access both to preparation to enter the workforce as well as the option to choose to go on to college and that there should be parallel rigor in those courses.
You did it on talking about the funding question with schools when you authored and sponsored the Quality Education Investment Act.
You did it in so many different ways and with so many different folks
that make people genuinely appreciate you and they can't help but smile when you walk into the room or you enter into the conversation.
It's not enough just to say you're leaving us.
It's more important to say what you are leaving behind.
I came to the board with you, with a group of folks that were called the Magnificent Seven, but you're leaving behind a group of folks
who are better as a state and who are better as a policymaking group because you showed us the way.
I'm going to close with Gil Scott Heron.
The revolution will not be televised.
The revolution will not be right back after a message about a white tornado or white lightning or even white people.
You will not have to worry about a germ in your bedroom.
The revolution will not fight the germs that cause bad breath.
The revolution will put you in the driver's seat.
The revolution will not be a rerun.
The revolution will be live.
You did that for us in California and we are all better for it.
Thank you very much.
Board member Sandoval.
Powerful words.
Beautiful.
Thank you so much for everything that you've done, your contributions to making our lives better in the state.
And I also, just on a personal note, I met you before I began my board service.
You came to our reservation, our small little community, and I was struck by your ability to listen, your ability to connect, your goodwill.
And it was true, it was sincere, it still is.
And so that, I just have a few words.
Kakinalan, I am grateful to you.
That's in our Somali language.
And I'm so grateful for all that you've done to embrace and include all of our students in California, all of our families.
And it's making our communities greater here.
Thank you.
Kakinalan.
Okay, Board Member Strauss.
I'm one of the group that came with you, Tom, and I would just say, like Member Ortiz-Lacombe, I didn't know, none of us knew each other when we came, and so we've all grown together and I think have made a really commitment followed by the model that you and President Christ have set of working collaboratively together.
And I think as we came in, our career started in teaching, and as we measured, it always had to be good enough for our kids, and now Tom and I share grandkid stories and grandkid pictures.
And that is a good measure of the next generation.
And are we putting in place policies and practices that will be good enough for all of our kids?
So I just have to say, I've been very fortunate to be working collaboratively with you and been on some panels with you and some of the work.
And I appreciate the mission that you've been focused on for all kids, for good collaborative labor management work, for the outreach to the Atlantic Rim countries, and all the work that you've done
to connect our work in a broader global area.
And so I think this is the chapter.
As we look to the next chapter and the third chapter, as they say, I think there's lots more ahead and I think we'll still cross paths, as we say.
But it's been a pleasure and I think it's evolved over the years of us working together.
It's been a challenge and we've done, as Mike said, what else could we do?
Look how much we've done.
And I think we've done so much, although we know we have so much to do to continue the pathway.
And your leadership with the department has been really very special.
And I agree that the collaboration among CDE and State Board is really a model for future work.
Thanks.
So I'm very new on the board, but we've had opportunities to interact.
But that 80 hour work week that was referred to earlier, I mean, I'm from Southern California and constantly you are present.
It's amazing how you've gotten around this state.
And I think more importantly, you've just
made relationships with individual people.
And I think that's one of your traits.
And I'll tell a quick story.
The day I was sworn in on the board, my son was here.
And I introduced him.
He was a senior in high school.
And I said he was going to college.
And you asked him, what do you want to be?
And Max said, I want to be a teacher.
And you simply said, we need you.
And hours later at the airport, my son turned to my husband and said, you know, Dad, no one told me that they needed me.
And you said that.
And it made a difference.
And you continue to be a mentor for him.
I have him take a picture for Max every board meeting now, and he's been sending messages.
But that's the kind of connection you've made, and I just really want to thank you, and I'm very much looking forward to the global initiative and how that's going to go forward.
But thank you for the opportunity to work with you.
So Tom, my colleagues have spoken very eloquently about your statesmanship, your policy leadership, and your knowledge of education.
And I just want to say, what a nice guy you are.
You just, from the very first time I was, when I was first appointed, you gave
You called me and welcomed me to the board.
And since that day, you've always made me feel very welcome.
And having sat next to you now for, what, maybe two and a half years, never failed to ask how I'm doing, how my school's doing, just taking the time to ask about me personally.
And it's not always just about business.
You've always made us feel very comfortable here.
And so thank you very much.
I'm going to miss sitting next to you.
Thank you.
Member holiday I don't mean to be toward the end.
I think member Rucker probably should have the last comment but My father was a professor of
Elizabethan drama, and he could quote the most obscure Shakespeare passages.
At the same time, while he was doing that, he would teach me how to gap a spark plug so the lawnmower would run.
And he grew up in a very small town in Indiana.
And when he would go back to this town with all of his credentials as a professor, he would hang out at the coffee shop and talk about farm tools and how the crops were growing and all the rest.
I see a lot of him in you.
I see both the high aspirations for excellence in education, but also a common sense about what it means to be human and kind.
Thank you.
I just have two things just to add on in addition to what everyone else has said.
And one is when I was part of the original team to come onto the board and at that time, the first six months, Mike was calling a meeting every single month.
And I lived in the Bay Area.
And so Mike and I carpooled to the meetings.
that first six months.
And he has some funny stories to tell about how fast I drove to get up here.
But what I remember is Mike talking to me about how important it was for you and him
to develop a relationship very quickly that was going to be not just a friendship, but a partnership and working together.
And, you know, he knows all the stories about all that he's been around politics in California much longer than I was.
So he knows of all the different relationships between superintendents and board members that did not work well and that were acrimonious and undermined.
the productivity of both the department and the board.
And he was absolutely committed that that wasn't going to happen with the two of you.
And he knew that you would be equally committed to that as well and that you were going to do that partnership.
And I've been so impressed
that the two of you have dinner at almost every meeting.
If you're in town, you have dinner the night before the start of every meeting.
And that kind of consistency and staying with it to stay committed to that relationship, because I'm sure you don't always agree on absolutely everything, but you get together and talk about it and work it out and respect each other and respect the contributions that you each make.
And I think what that's done for me
is it's made the board work have so much more potential for making an impact because the time isn't wasted in acrimony between the state board and the CDE like it has in some instances in the past.
It's made so much more potential for all of us to make so much progress and to enact so many reforms, which wouldn't have been the case if that relationship had
had not developed and you hadn't been committed to it.
And so I thank you for that.
And then the other thing is next generation science standards.
So, you know, I fell in love with that in the first year with Next Generation Science Standards.
And I'll say more about it when we have our NGSS agenda item.
But you, too, were in love with it.
And I loved the fact that you were so committed to it.
And because you were a science teacher and you understood it and you immediately embraced it.
And and wanted us to to adopt it and and to do really good things with it and you supported It felt to me like you supported everything your uh, terrific staff were doing Uh at phil lock fontaine who I missed Uh, you know at the time was the lead on this and and also I felt very supported with my role Uh in the stuff I wanted to do within gss and felt that support from you as well.
It felt like uh
that we were in it kind of together in terms of, oh, you know, this is going to be a great thing for California.
You know, let's make this happen.
And I really appreciated that.
Sue Burr, our first executive director of the board and board member.
So you were playing a different role.
Yes, I was.
When this all began.
I was.
I wanted to speak a little bit to that.
And first, just start by saying how bittersweet this is for me, Tom, because it's been such a pleasure to serve with you in a variety of capacities, not the least of which on this state board, but certainly on the collaborative.
I think we've really done some amazing work together.
And I just want to reinforce a little bit of what board member Williams was talking about.
And Feliza made the comment that she was told the relationship between the board and superintendents in the past was a hot mess.
And I would say that was a major understatement.
And having known many state superintendents prior to you, I would say that their least favorite thing was to interact with the State Board of Education and to have to sit through meetings.
And so I just wanted to, I have to express from the bottom of my heart how much you embrace the notion of collaboration and how we are all in this together.
And also reinforce something that Deputy Superintendent Price said.
You made the rest of the department feel that through your coaching and your mentoring and your leadership, so that we could work together seamlessly and do wonderful things on behalf of the students of California.
So for that, I'm deeply grateful and I'll really miss working with you.
Okay, I think that gives us some time for if there's any public comment on this.
I did forget one thing as they come up, which would take another half hour.
But it was, do you remember my administration as governor?
Three days.
And to Karen's point about recruiting, the one most important thing I did in those three days was I declared one day, change lives, become a teacher.
And to address the teacher shortage.
Hi.
Angela DeRamos representing California Teachers Association.
His name, his own record.
That slogan carried you through your terms in the State Assembly, the State Senate, and as Superintendent of Public Instruction.
The California Teachers Association applauds your leadership in education, your legislative innovation to create the Quality Education Investment Act, your stewardship over the millions of students who attend a public school in California,
and your unabashed support of educators like me and educator quality.
Along with Dr. Kirst and the board, you've created the California Way and in doing so, your name and your record will stand the long test of time.
On behalf of California Teachers Association, thank you and we have a little token for you.
Thank you.
think is the capital idea.
OK, well, more to come.
Hi, thank you.
Andrea Ball on behalf of the California School Boards Association.
Superintendent Torlakson, we want to thank you for your leadership on many levels, but one thing I was thinking about is given the prior board item is I think that when you created a number of task forces and work groups and brought in diverse perspectives for those,
Early on, I think the one on accountability and continuous improvement and the report that you put out was really a foundational element of moving us to this new system of support and continuous improvement.
A real change, as you've heard from the local district folks.
And then your work to support early learning, I think has been very valuable.
And also, as remarked upon earlier, the work group, English learners and the roadmap and the fact that this board
Approved that policy just really cemented a pivot in a good way for California and education and so really want to thank you and wish you all the best Tom is a long-distance runner.
I think you're crossing the finishing line and I
To celebrate that, we have a cake.
So the board will recess a bit to bring the cake in and we invite the audience to share in the cake.
And the board members, I think our lunches are probably here.
I know I'm between you and Kate.
I apologize.
But I did want to take a moment on behalf of all the partners and staff at Capital Advisors to thank you for all that you've done and for on behalf of our clients who have enjoyed working with you and your staff as we have
I'll work to serve the students of California.
Particularly want to thank you for your tremendous commitment to career technical education on behalf of KROP and the Longstreet.
They have been a partner with you and you've done tremendous work and you've kept that light burning when others weren't as strong on it.
Also on behalf of the small school districts, I want to thank you for recognizing the unique needs of small districts, your visits to all of them.
They remember that and they thank you for that.
And I do have a message from Jack O'Connell who said, you won't believe how much better you'll sleep when you don't have to worry about another election.
So congratulations.
Enjoy your well-earned retirement.
Thank you.
And thank you all of you.
Your comments are so meaningful and it's been a joy working with you.
And I'll continue to be there with you.
Okay, so we'll recess and cut the cake and... We also want... We have... Dean is here to take a photograph of the board with Tom.
And so you want them right down here in front?
Is this a good spot?
Right in front here.
You got it?
The people here for item 4, Cindy and so on, are you ready?
Yeah we're going to reconvene.
Okay the board will reconvene.
And we will now hear item four.
This is an action and information agenda as well.
So we have to take formal action.
And how we're going to handle this is we're going to, this is very technical with many different attachments.
And so Cindy's going to present one after another these indicators and criteria and so on.
And then the board members can ask technical questions after each one, because they're really all different kinds of things.
And so if you want to, we'll pause after each attachment and allow questions from the board.
And then we'll have the public comment at the end of the whole array of this multiple thing.
So here we go.
Good afternoon.
I'm Cindy Kazanis, the Director of the Analysis, Measurement, and Accountability Reporting Division, and I'm here to get the accountability system over the finish line today.
So Superintendent Torlakson started us off very well.
Thank you and congratulations on
terrific eight years.
We have come a long way, and so this item will take you through some way back.
We'll go a couple years back and talk about where we've been and where we're headed.
I need to start, though, with thanking not only my immediate staff and the leadership of Jenny Singh and Jonathan Eisler and Tom Bjorkman and Randy Bunnell, but really
folks throughout this department.
This has been a team effort.
We can't do accountability in isolation at the department.
We can't do accountability in isolation in Sacramento.
And so we have been, if you've noticed in one of our attachments, we've been up and down the state only in the last 60 days, but really in the last couple of years.
And just in the last 60 days, we had about 4,000 contacts.
So there has been a tremendous thirst for information around the accountability system
And we are trying to get out and trying to make this as commonplace as CASP and Smarter Balance and things that we implemented, we started on rather five years ago when my first child was born.
She didn't get swaddled very well, but that's okay.
She survived.
So I'm going to walk through the attachments very briefly, and then we'll go into them in depth.
Just as a start, the California Petitions Advisory Group met last week.
We had a good discussion via a webinar interface.
And so where I can, I will give you a verbal update of their thoughts on
on the items and then we also since then have had a webinar just about the Every Student Succeeds Act and we got to also talk about the indicators and where we're headed for this meeting.
So this item did include over 70 data tables.
I hope you enjoyed them as much as we enjoyed putting them together.
But there is
There is a wealth of information and that's really not to overwhelm you.
I want to put that out there.
It's to give not only you but members of the public a thorough understanding of how in-depth these data analysis that we take the state analysis very seriously.
We look at it from a variety of perspectives.
We want to make sure that we're adding that level of transparency to the public as well.
So with that, we are going to walk through the last pieces that we need to put in place for the Chronic Absenteeism Indicator, as well as the Graduation Rate Indicator, and an adjustment to the Graduation Rate Indicator.
Kristen Wright's going to help me with that attachment.
We'll then step into the College Career Indicator, and then go into our Academic Indicator, and then
talk briefly about differentiated assistance and making some adjustments because of our local priority access to broad course of study.
We will also pick up a technical revision that we're recommending for the local indicator for implementation of state academic standards that Jeff Breshears will come up and join me for.
And then we'll balance it out with the dashboard and where we're headed with that.
Great, so this is the recommendation.
It is more than one slide, so just bear with me because I'm going to say it out loud at least once today, maybe twice or three times.
The California Department of Education recommends that the State Board of Education approve first status and change cut scores in the 5 by 5 grid for the chronic absenteeism indicator and the application
of that for LEAs, schools, student groups with fewer than 150 students.
We're also going to talk a bit about asking you to revise the status cut scores for graduation rate indicator and then modification of criteria for students earning the special education certificate of completion.
We're also recommending a change in cut scores for the 5 by 5 grid for CCI.
And rather change cut scores, not a change.
You have not approved the change cut scores.
And then number five, status and change cut scores for the five by five for the high school academic indicator.
So grade 11, bringing that into the dashboard.
And then finally, rounding out with those two technical changes around the criteria for differentiated assistance and a technical revision to our academic standards local indicator.
So I heard Nancy Burnell's name this morning.
I was going to use her name as well.
She started us on this journey back in 2000, probably 13, 14, 15, and left us in 2016 to, I think, retire.
But it sounds like she's back at work again, according to folks this morning.
So with Nancy's leadership, as well as Janelle Kubanek from WestEd, you all started down this path during your tenure.
So the three components of LCFF are now in place.
We have a little control accountability plan that's been around for several years.
Dashboard is entering its second operational year with this iteration this fall.
And then, as you heard that preceded me, our system of support is really developing and is becoming robust.
So this three-part process, it made me think about why do we have a dashboard.
And of course, we're required to by law.
But let's go into what the law says according to education code.
So we are using it to support LEAs in identifying strengths, weaknesses, and areas of improvement.
We also are using it to assist in determining whether LEAs are eligible for technical assistance.
And then finally, it's assisting the superintendent of public instruction in determining whether LEAs are eligible for more intensive support or intervention.
So since, you know, the dashboard was just a glimmer in everybody's eyes, we now have created a partnership with our California Collaborative on Education Excellence.
We've done some great resources, put together some great resources with them, and really the statewide system of support is where the dashboard is now headed.
We're putting out some very robust policy
Behind very robust policy, we're putting out some data that will show that we need to identify not only our strengths at the state level, but also weaknesses and how can we help inform policy decisions moving forward at the state level.
So now that we have, for example, two years of
Data for chronic absenteeism We now can use that to compare against not only district to district but state to state and we know from From work that has been done by attendance works that we are actually lower than other states for chronic absenteeism.
That's just an example
We also know that there are measures where we are performing well and I think the graduation rate is a great example and we're showing progress.
But you will see today there are measures where we need to make some improvements.
So I'm looking forward to that discussion.
So do you remember this chart from 2016 that I think Dave will probably get squeamish about?
We used this as a concept back then, right?
This was a concept about what the dashboard could become.
And with this, and I think it started out on a whiteboard in the state board offices,
We've now developed this into a very robust dashboard that we then got extra funding for, the governor gave to the department and to San Joaquin County to take another look at it.
So there are other states where they're implementing their dashboards for the first time this year.
So it's very loaded.
This is the first time they have to do it under federal law and we are
really one to two years ahead of a lot of other states and so you've given us the opportunity to continuously improve in the accountability system and we're grateful for that because the anxiety that came out in last year's prototype and then also in in the first operational in 2017 it exists it still exists but it's not as as
as high of an anxiety level as I felt like we had last December.
Folks have taken the year to get used to even more what suspension rates are, what is the English learner progress going to be, how are we going to onboard college career and chronic absenteeism.
So we've come a long way.
I also wanted to mention, I know that this is, of course, our equity report, and we're really proud of these baseball cards.
We've gotten quite a bit of compliments about the prototype, and so we do have a flyer that's out there, but we will be releasing this privately beginning next week.
So I'm getting I think I feel like I'm getting hourly updates from the contractor about we fix this and this is ready to go So we are on track to release this publicly in December and we're really Excited about the changes and how this will be much more intuitive look and feel
I know that Marguerite's next and she's going to be talking about the Every Student Succeeds Act, but I wanted to mention she did get an invitation to come to D.C.
to talk about our dashboard and to show it off with other states in December.
So she's going to be representing California, but we are being used as a model, which is a nice place to be.
They may not like it, but we are being used as a model nationally about continuous improvement.
So we listened, we've made those improvements, and others are noticing that we've done some great work.
So I also wanted to mention while we're talking about this prototype is that there is an about the dashboard.
That is something that the user design folks felt very strongly about.
It's written very simplistically.
We're trying to get across to those that are using the dashboard what the purpose of the accountability system is.
And in that we do talk about the fact that we have alternative schools coming on board that serve high risk populations.
But we also talk about the fact that we are going to be onboarding, at some point in the near future, a science test.
So we do mention the science test in our About the Dashboard section.
I want to make sure I said that because it's not in any of my other slides because, of course, it's in the future.
We also have brought on new pictures.
There is a selfie for students that are graduating.
There is a group of students that have taken their own picture which is I think very trendy for this day and age.
We have a female student who is doing career technical education and then Kristen helped us pick some students, young students who are students with disabilities.
I think that the pictures tell a story by themselves on the dashboard.
And so I would say look out for those because it took us a while to select them, but we did it based on feedback we were getting from others about what's on the current dashboard, which is no students.
So we're making some gains there.
The other piece I wanted to mention to you is that with this new prototype, we are bringing on board a comparison feature to the dashboard.
So you can see that state block there right next to student group.
That will be throughout the dashboard.
There will also be a state display.
And because we have not done this on the current dashboard, it is something that has been
There's interest in the field to show how you're doing against something and so the state comparison feature will be live come December and those districts that will be looking at it during the private period will also be able to see again how they're doing not only at the indicator level but the student group level against the state.
All right, so one of the things I thought we could also go back and just talk a little bit about, because this came up a little bit during the California Petitioners Advisory Group meeting, was how did we arrive at our cut score methodology?
And so that was actually the meeting before you saw that top level display back in May of 2016.
And in May of 2016, you asked us to look at using equally weighted percentile cut scores for status and change.
And I have an example of that on the next slide.
So what we are applying, as we did with not only the spring version of the dashboard, but the operational version of the dashboard in the fall, is based on distributions established using actual results.
So we have
This is an example of how for very low for example you see in the 10th It goes up to the 10th percentile the 90th percentile right after that is where we start are very high So we're trying to have you know a normal distribution these Cut scores many of them were set prior to bringing prior to onboarding our dashboard alternative school status.
We are not suggesting that we
completely change all of our cut scores because of onboarding our Dashboard Alternative School Status.
We think that it's very appropriate to hold them to the same standards as our traditional schools.
But you will see as with the graduation rate we talk about, it's not due to those alternative schools, it's due to a change in methodology as an example.
But this is an example of the methodology we've used and the recommendations we're making today.
It's consistent with this guidance that you gave to us back in May of 2016.
So let's move into the attachments.
And for attachment one, we're going to start with the chronic absenteeism indicator.
If you had been here yesterday in the building, in this room, at around 9.30, we had a special presentation from UC Davis.
UC Davis partnered with Attendance Works.
Maybe it was the other way around.
Attendance Works partnered with UC Davis to use our downloadable data files to tell a story about our chronic absenteeism rates.
And so yesterday was Geographic Information, GIS, Geographic Information System Day, that's the correct verbiage, GIS, which is mapping.
And so what UC Davis did for attendance work was to show where there was high concentrations and low concentrations.
And so the researchers or the data analysts that put that together gave a short presentation yesterday.
And it was very interesting to hear that, you know, again, compared to the chronic absenteeism rates we see in California, there are other places that have higher chronic absenteeism rates than us.
But this is an indicator that we have been working on, like many of the others, for several years now, but we are just now onboarding with a color.
You can see the series of actions that you've taken to date to get to this place.
And what we are recommending is not only the approval of the status and change cut scores, but the application of what we call the three by five grid to the indicator.
And so the three by five grid, of course, currently is for has been adopted for the suspension rate and the graduation rate indicator.
And it's meant to prevent extreme changes in our small student populations.
I also wanted to mention that with chronic absenteeism we have over the last couple of months engaged with our student attendance or attendance clerks and so there is now a formal
title for them in state law, but there has been a strong thirst for information around chronic absenteeism and how to get at making sure the early warning system doesn't fail because by the time you get to the dashboard, it is much too late for that early warning system to be effective.
So with that in mind, here's the graphic that shows that three-by-five grid and how we are trying to prevent the large swings.
But here's the impact of that grid on our various school types.
So we wanted to make sure we always look at charter schools, we always look at small schools and alternative schools.
So all these are listed here.
So for charter schools, we don't see an impact, very minimal impact.
For dashboard alternative school status schools, we see a number of schools, 22% moved from yellow to orange.
So there is a decrease.
And then for small schools, there is an increase in number of schools
receiving red and yellow and a small increase with orange.
So you can see that the impact of applying this grid which is again supposed to help with those large swings.
So we are recommending that you approve the post cut scores and performance levels for the academic indicator and that you also approve the application of the three by five grid to the chronic absenteeism indicator for the all students and student group levels whenever there are fewer than 150 students.
So with that I will turn it back to President Hurst.
OK.
Other technical questions on this.
Board Member Strauss.
Cindy, I know we've been working on this one a long time and I just appreciate all the work that you and staff are doing on this.
We had a couple questions in the letters and ones that we've talked about before.
I thought it might be good to clarify why chronic absenteeism is not, we're looking at it and not at the high school level at this point.
Is this appropriate time for you to clarify that?
Sure, I'd be happy to do that, and I think I had a slide on that in last meeting's presentation.
I didn't bring it back in, but verbally I can tell you that our approved state ESSA plan indicates that it will be a K-8 indicator.
If we were to onboard it as a high school indicator, we would have the waiting be
unequally weighted for high schools versus elementary schools, but we also see chronic absenteeism really appear in our graduation rate and our suspension rate for high schools.
So students that are not attending school are less likely to graduate and so therefore we do believe that it's reflective in the graduation rate directly.
And just to clarify, what you're talking about as far as the ESSA plan is we have to have the same number of indicators, is that right?
And so we can't, that we had to make a choice?
There has to be an equal weighting of the academic indicators.
Thank you.
Ortiz-Lacombe.
I know that we had this conversation, but I'm wondering, one of the other recommendations was if we can include it as a formal indicator with status and change is just including the data, which is what we did and which is what caused the confusion.
So why, is there a reason why we couldn't include the data for high school, just in our state in the dashboard, but not necessarily with the color, but the data itself?
So the data itself will be on DataQuest as which that's where we've been directing everybody to regardless.
When we look at the View More reports for an individual school site or a district site, it will definitely take them to their full complement of reports in not only DataQuest but the complementary reports for the accountability system as well.
So it's something we can take back.
We have not calculated status and change for high school, so it's not something I can push out in December, but it is something we can definitely take back for evaluation.
Great.
That would be great.
Okay, any other?
If not, we'll keep going because we have a lot of them.
We do have a lot of them.
We have several actions.
Okay, so attachment two is the revised cut scores for the graduation rate indicator.
And this was, of course, approved back in 2016.
But in June of this year, we did make you aware that we thought there may be a potential of needing to adjust the scores, the cut scores for the graduation indicator.
in part due to a federal audit that we had been expecting for a number of months from the U.S.
Department of Education Office of Inspector General.
And what we found in calculating the 2017 rates was about a 2% reduction statewide in the graduation rate.
We also are bringing on board our dashboard alternative school status students with 30 or more students in the status and change year and so they will also be incorporated not only in their school level graduation rate which is for the first time but also incorporated into district rates so they're aggregating that information up to the district.
And then the other thing that we have
Moved beyond is the three-year average.
So this was the one indicator that we had Down as a three-year average and we're now using a simple The prior year's graduation rate versus current year's graduation rate.
So it's a more of a good more simplistic methodology, but with all of those factors involved we do
We did run the data.
We have, like others, have run it through the Technical Advisory Group as well as the California Petitions Advisory Group, who didn't have a lot of questions about the policy change.
I think there was more questions around clarifying the calculation for the alternative schools, the fact that we're using this one-year modified method.
And so there was quite a bit of questions around that, but they were in general in support of
of the new cut scores.
With this, I also wanted to mention that there has been some of the letters that have addressed this and there's been comments made over the last several board meetings about the shifts of enrollment that this may cause.
So by allowing students to enroll in a dashboard alternative school and having a 90-day enrollment window, you may
You may see more shifts happening.
So you may see some unintended consequences or some inappropriate behavior made by adults moving students.
And so we are going to be working with a couple of county offices of education who have a very fine-tuned data system to monitor those shifts this year and for future years, but in particular for this year to see if that is the case.
If we do see
If we do see shifts, we will come back with some recommendations on how to hold the prior school accountable, as an example, or the prior district accountable.
So I just wanted to make you aware that this is something that we are keenly aware of, but we're also, I think, also aware that alternative school education is
is tough to run too.
It tends to be more expensive.
You have students that are high need or high risk.
And so they do involve tend to involve a lot more intensive instruction.
And so we want to make sure that we're incentivizing schools and districts to continue to operate alternative schools and not walk away from it because for accountability it's going to harm them as a district.
So I just wanted to make sure I said that out loud because of the noise that we've had around this issue.
We also, in looking at the graduation rate, so what we are specifically recommending are new cut scores for status, only for status.
We are suggesting that it'll be applied to, of course, our high schools.
So high schools with a four-year graduation rate and then LEAs that have comprehensive high schools and dashboard alternative school status.
So what we did in the
Just to give you a background so that this the chart makes a little more sense when I show it to you This indicator is different than all the other indicators because we have this this bottom threshold of 67% So that is what's considered very low by federal standards.
And so we have to apply that in in the 5x5 grid so this 5x5 grid looks different than all the others because of that that bottom threshold and
The high status, just in the exact opposite, we have a 90% graduation goal for all high schools.
So that is how we get to our high status.
So what we are recommending today is some tweaks to not the very low and not the very high and not high, just looking at the middle piece between our low and our medium cut scores.
We are not proposing any changes to the change cut scores.
So we are recommending that the board approve the status cut scores for graduation rate and apply it to districts and comprehensive high schools.
Let's stop there.
Is that it?
Technical questions.
Board member Strauss.
So I'm just following up to clarify a discussion that we had following on CPAG, because we've had some letters and some discussions and some questions from our groups about the one-year graduation rate.
The issue of certificate of completion, if students are in the alternative school, they're getting credit for graduation, but if they're in the regular four-year high school, they're not.
And you had shared that they have never been
in the graduation rate while they've been in comprehensive, because we didn't want to, we want the comprehensive high schools to keep the students that might qualify for a certificate of completion rather than transferring them to, as you just addressed.
So I just wanted you to review that.
And then also, I appreciated your proposal from CDE to pursue legislation around an alternative diploma.
So.
I'm sorry, can I, that's for, that's the next attachment.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Okay.
I thought it was the graduation rate.
There's two graduation rate pieces.
So one of them is for our traditional schools, and the next one is going to be for our DAS schools.
I did get you confused because I mentioned DAS schools in the middle of this, but I'm sorry.
Any other questions?
If not, Patricia Rucker.
I just want to make sure that I get you to repeat again what this indicator gathers its information from.
Is this still a lagging indicator, meaning it's taking the data from the previous school year, the previous cohort?
Could you explain that again?
I can't.
Thank you.
You just need to keep hearing these things to make sure everybody understands that.
I guess I should have started that.
We have no lagging indicators this year.
We have caught up on graduation rate.
We have caught up on suspension rate.
We have caught up on chronic absenteeism.
So you will hear, I think from our superintendent in the next maybe week or two, our 2018 graduation rates and the
2018 which is a first for us.
So thank you for allowing me to give us a little bit of credit and I know that he'll take some credit for for those results.
Okay, now we're gonna move on to attachment three, and Kristen is going to help me with a piece of this.
So, the last, there's been two actions that you've taken this year on the dashboard alternative school status graduation rate, or we also have referred to it as the one year graduation rate, but are trying to rename it to the DAS graduation rate.
You adopted the methodology back in May, and then in September, you approved the status and change cut scores.
What we are suggesting today is we have had quite a bit of conversations.
Kristen has come to us as well as some of the others in the field and one of the equity groups concerned that the certificate of completion doesn't have any guardrails in place.
county offices, districts can give a certificate of completion but there's varying methods of applying how it is issued throughout the state.
So we over the course of the last two months have developed
not only a long-term solution, not only a short-term solution, but a long-term solution.
And we were able to take this to the Advisory Commission on Special Education in which they were supportive of this.
We also took this to the California Petitions Advisory Group.
And there was some of the questions that member Strauss is asking, they were asking.
So we will clarify that during this presentation.
So with that, I'm going to turn it over to Kristen to talk about our long-term solution first.
Board members, superintendent.
So I spent the last three days with 1,200 transition age youth providers, Department of Rehabilitation staff members, and other stakeholders who all are serving transition age youth.
And one of the overarching themes, if you will, was really about how are we going to ensure that our students with disabilities who are leaving high school are well prepared to get jobs.
And I sat, I moderated a panel with four high-level corporate partners, AT&T, Anthem Blue Cross, among others, who basically said, we are here and recognize that we want our workforce to represent the community that we serve.
But we really need from education our students to be prepared and be able to actually meet basic requirements to even get in the door for these jobs.
That brings us to this conversation today about the alternate diploma.
And we have an opportunity under ESSA, an opportunity we haven't had before, which is to use, to develop an alternate diploma based on alternate achievement standards, which we have set in place already.
to be able to offer this diploma that would count in the four-year graduation rate federally.
So there is one opportunity there that's sort of waiting for us.
There are other states who have already developed this opportunity, but the key is
Our current certificate of completion doesn't meet the requirements under ESSA because there are no guardrails.
There is no criteria that says here's what you have to know and here's the courses that you need to take, which are very similar courses, not to the same degree, but similar courses to your traditional school counterparts that don't have disabilities.
So what we would like to do is
work on with our legislature on looking at how we get statute changed to evolve the certificate of completion into an alternate diploma that would be used not just for death schools, but across everywhere.
And I think that's to your point, Eileen, that really this, you do the great on-ramp for this conversation.
No, it was, I was like, yay, perfect.
Well, right, and I think the point is that we don't want districts to feel like it's a disincentive to have students with disabilities or who are not on a traditional high school diploma track in the schools.
It runs counter to all of the work that we're doing around more access to general ed and inclusion for students with disabilities.
So if we did this, it would take a statutory change.
Currently, the certificate of completion, the statutory requirements for a certificate are really that locally they decide what the criteria is and they go to school and then they meet the goals of their IEP.
But there's no more than that.
And so I think in this whole era of high expectations that we're really saying even our students with the most significant disabilities
we would have those high expectations for because the employers are there waiting for them and the supported employment from rehab is waiting for them.
And everyone's waiting for them, but we have to get them ready.
One other caveat to all that is that in the past, if you got a high school diploma, you couldn't get any more services under IDEA.
You know, we serve students from 0 to 22.
and you can get services until 22 unless you get a high school diploma.
Under the provisions of ESSA, and we checked with OSEP to make sure this was okay, your students can still receive those transition services even with an alternate diploma, which is different.
So as we're thinking about what's next, this was sort of a short-term solution in that not every student that would receive a certificate would count because really this option, and under ESSA this option, is for students with the most significant cognitive disabilities, otherwise known as the 1% of students who take the alternate assessment.
And I don't know, we'll have to decide as a state what we want,
For the most part, we want every student to get a high school diploma because that's how they get jobs.
And so for that small group that wouldn't be able to get a traditional high school diploma, we're providing another option.
And there may be some other numbers in between there that we'll have to talk about as a state.
But I think for the purposes of now, this is a great solution.
And our stakeholders have also agreed that this would be a viable solution.
And we'd hope to have your support.
moving forward.
Kudos to Cindy and her team for really being collaborative around this and reaching out and really trying to come to a solution.
And also to our stakeholders who've been very patient, trying to help us figure this out as well.
So there's no action today on this.
This is just... Well, you would have to... Yeah, because... Go ahead.
Here's the action.
But you can stay.
We're in this together.
Really together.
So we...
The board took action on this measure in July without any guardrails and so what we are suggesting today is that there be a small tweak to the language that says students who earn a certificate of completion who are in a dashboard alternative school
status school, they need to be either, if they're under the age of 20, they must be eligible to take the California alternate assessment.
So again, that's that 1% that Kristen has just mentioned.
And then if they're over 20, we would automatically count them as graduates.
And part of the issue with our students that are over 20 is we did change our assessments.
And so it is a little more difficult to track our older students.
We did
Get some help from from Kristen and from her data staff that gave us some some insight into the data But again, this is a this is probably a two-year solution until the legislative process works and assuming you know
our new superintendent, whoever it is, is supportive of this measure as well as the new governor and new legislature.
So that is the request that is being made today is that you approve this revised eligibility criteria for accounting students who earn special education certificate of completion as graduates with that small tweak.
So with the legislation is to be forthcoming, which would be the longer term solution.
That is the longer term solution.
Board member questions on this technical issue?
It's not exactly technical.
Okay, so let's move to the College Career Indicator.
So the College Career Indicator, of course, you've been working on this for a long time, probably longer than almost any of them, but we're only taking you back to 2016 when you improved the College Career Indicator as a state indicator.
Last September you approved the status cut scores so schools and districts are very familiar hopefully with their cut scores based on status from last year and in fact you had the privilege or we had the privilege of hearing from San Juan Unified back in May.
It was not the superintendent it was an assistant superintendent and then their lead for assessments and accountability who gave us an indication of the data that they've looked through and so
We have, in doing that, we've also given you several information memorandums that you've been asking for about how are certain metrics developed, how do we make sure that they were all, there was some equal treatment amongst all of the measures.
And then in the May piece for San Juan what I wanted to also mention is that there they had a really what I thought was a very powerful statement that They have a four-year plan to to develop or rather.
They have a long-term plan on how to work on this indicator and
And part of it was to not only educate their students, but their parents.
And they talked about beginning in middle school around this indicator.
And it was going to take time to build these partnerships and do yearly benchmarks.
So one of the things that we are, let me just go back.
You did have a long discussion about this indicator at your last meeting.
So I wanted to recognize that action as well.
The other piece is that we are starting to see the vendor community come on board with this indicator and so there is several districts that have made us aware that they have a college career readiness guide and one of them that we had the presentation or rather presentation from was Christopher Lund from Long Beach Unified and so they have an eight-page document that tells a student on a yearly basis or even more often
Are they on track to not only be prepared to go to college, but for career?
And so this indicator has made, has actually, I think, invigorated some of our high schools and our comprehensive districts to look at this, not only from the high school perspective, but as early as middle school.
I'm showing you two data charts, and the reason I wanted to show this to you is these are the distributions for status for both the fall 2000 dashboard, so class of 2016, and then while we do skip ahead to 2018 because of the fact that we caught up on our lagging indicators,
I just wanted to show you that there is, you know, it's pretty even as far as status.
There wasn't a lot of swings and so what we put out there last year for consumption for districts to get ready for this indicator I think is still, we're still on track and there should be
not as many surprises, although I think some people will be surprised about the color of their indicator on the college career indicator because they're used to seeing their graduations rates be very high, right?
So their graduation rate may be high, but their indicator may be
an orange or a yellow or who knows.
So just to just to give a brief overview of the CCI, of course, it's based on the graduation cohort for our comprehensive schools.
We're looking at the four year for our dashboard alternative schools.
We're looking at that DAS graduation rate and it does include special education schools.
We are including all students.
So we are looking at students who take the California Alternative Assessment.
This is something we brought in this year due to our Every Student Succeeds Act State Plan.
Then we are also looking at students.
So who will be attributed to if they are not enrolled in a school or left a school prior to the four years.
And it's of course to the last school in which they were enrolled.
So, as we've just wanted to give you, you know, you are aware of our three-year plan under the College Career Indicator, but we have also given you in Attachment 9 really a plan up until 2020 on how to incorporate new pieces into, or rather, analyses into the College Career Indicator.
And so, we will be definitely looking at ones that we have a couple that we're going to onboard that will help our Dashboard Alternative School Status become
So we'll see more opportunities for them to show that they're doing well under this indicator.
And so we anticipate seeing the number of schools in the red performance to actually go down as these new measures get onboarded.
And then I would also say that we know that small schools are represented in that red performance level and we did not have the time to conduct the analysis but we'll definitely conduct the analysis between this dashboard and the next to bring back a recommendation on applying that three by five
grid to the college career indicator.
We also will continue to provide very specific data on the college career indicator about how the students, which category they demonstrated that they were prepared or approaching prepared.
So we have that available now for the 2017 dashboard.
It is on a link on the department's webpage but there is a link off of the dashboard.
We'll do the same
for this coming year and because we've caught up with our lagging indicators, we'll not have three years of data for districts to look at.
So it's a really rich data set as we move forward.
So with that, we are recommending that the board approve the proposed change cut scores and the performance levels for the college career indicator.
Okay, questions on that?
So we had a lot of discussion on the college and career indicator, and this is a long road.
And I think it's important for us to note that we're not done yet, that we're still going to be working this coming year on lots more college and career indicators, particularly CTE pathways.
And actually, the Credential Commission is looking at that as well, because that's really important in our full look at offerings for kids.
But I think that in this CCI, where we have a couple of CTE items, but not fully built out,
We know that a lot of high schools have been implementing CTE pathways, which takes a couple years to put in place, because kids have to take several years with completion.
So we're not gonna see full impact of the
Transition to putting more CTE options into this and so I just wanted to make that point that and that this the CDE the Department of Ed still has plans to do more work on the CTE pathways So just to highlight that for everyone who's now looking at oh my goodness.
What does
What is a CCI now?
What's it going to be?
And then the new dashboard will have links to the CDE website, which also breaks out how students are doing on the pieces of the indicator.
So that was a real highlight, I thought, of what we offered.
So you could see who's approaching PrePARIS, how your subgroups are doing, what's the A to G.
access and completion because those areas are areas we've identified, access to rigorous coursework, things like that that are important and that have actually created some focus for high schools to pay attention to some of those things.
So just my comment that there's more CTE pathway work to come, that the results may not be showing yet on this year's
Rating and that there are extra data sources that CDE provides to districts to look at each of these Parts of the indicator and how the subgroups are doing.
Thank you.
And I know we've been working with executive director staff Walters to make sure that you have a study session early next year as we Gear up for 2019.
So that is scheduled in our plan for for March
for that study session.
And then we are partnering with San Juan for next week.
We have a presentation at the California Education Research Association conference to talk about the CCI.
And so I mentioned there's been great interest.
Two weeks ago I was invited to talk to guidance counselors in San Bernardino County.
So we are getting down to the level of staff who make a difference on which classes students take and the path that they're involved in.
So there's some really strong interest in this indicator.
One area I think we should look at is the WorkKeys assessment.
It's an assessment done by ACT.
It's all updated from before.
It gets at segments of the labor force that tend to work in jobs below four-year college.
And generally, it's been getting some pretty good reviews.
And I don't know whether we can use it at the state level, but I'd like the work group to look at it and just give us an impression of what they think about it.
It might be something local districts would want to use in that regard.
So I want... Oh, that's on the list.
I guess I'm asking for the study group.
Well, we definitely still have the College Career Indicator Workgroup.
They still exist and hopefully they'll come back as we bring on more or rather onboard, suggest onboarding of more indicators.
But the work piece I know we've looked at in the past.
We can definitely give you an update in the future about our analysis around that as well.
Okay.
Specifically.
So it's still alive.
Board Member Roker.
You know, along with Board Member Sung and Board Member Ortiz-Lacon, I sit on the Joint Advisory Committee on Workforce Pathways.
Try saying that three times really quickly.
But in part of the work that we've done, we had a single day where we took a look at a lot of data systems about community college students as well as K-12 students.
And there are some data systems and data gathering functions that they have
that actually are more detailed and have a level of granularity of information about our students with a capacity to collect that data that we don't seem to have.
I think that's another and I keep repeating this every time the opportunity comes up.
I think we need to take a look at those elements as well, even though we're limited by the law to use
only currently available information.
That's currently available information from a different system.
But I think that that's information that needs to be put in front of this work group as well.
Because it actually will serve some of the data needs that we're saying are currently lacking in our capacity to collect the data that's needed for the CCI.
And this information would be information we saw during our data study would be very helpful and very useful.
Other comments?
Board Member Sun.
Just to also add on to Board Member Rucker's comments around the California Workforce Joint Workforce Advisory Pathway.
Workforce, sorry.
Workforce Pathways Advisory Committee.
Thank you.
So we are also looking at metrics that for high quality career technical education.
And it occurred to me as we're having this conversation
that we really need to have a link back to the CCI work group as well so that we're consistent.
And as we are developing and looking at these metrics that we have the consistency across the board of what that is important.
So just wanted to raise that as well as we're looking at developing and maturing the CCI.
Okay, Ortiz-Lacombe.
I thank you for putting out that memo that gave us a sense of what's ahead in terms of the work.
And I'm glad to see that we're going to have a study session in March because some of the letters that we received, I think we put out some alarm, shocking waves when there was a lack of common understanding of what we as a board meant by CCI.
And so I think it's important for us to continue working on this and continue the conversation so we're all on the same page.
And that's going to be critical moving forward because there's going to be some changes on this board.
There's going to be some new leadership coming in.
And it's important that we have some clarity given to the field about the CCI.
With that said, I think that I had another point.
Oh, Lord, I never forget.
I have it in one of these Post-its here.
I can't remember what I was going to say.
We could come back.
We'll come back.
Maybe in a half an hour.
Half an hour, we'll come back.
See, I have a caffeine headache, but then I need more coffee.
Thank you.
Yeah.
We have more attachments to go through, so.
Okay.
All right.
Go ahead.
Okay so attachment five is proposed change and status cut scores for the high school academic indicator which of course you approved back in April when we brought you the every student succeeds plan for maybe the third time.
So, we have included that.
We have done the necessary analysis using the most current data and looking at prior data sets.
So, of course, the state plan requires that we include the academic indicator
We now include grade 11 in there, but also we have to look at participation rate because if students at the student group level or the school level or the district level do not have a 95% participation rate, there has to be some kind of deduction made to their academic indicator.
So those are the changes that are being onboarded for the dashboard in 2018, but this specific attachment walks through
all the simulations that we did related to our assessment results.
So when we looked at applying grade 11 to our existing cut scores for grades 3 through 8, we saw that many more districts had a high or a very high status.
So it did have some effect with our English Language Arts assessment.
When we looked at the mathematics assessment grades 3 through 8 the cut scores being applied to grade 11 We saw that many more districts received low or very low.
So a different set of results we felt that based on
these applications that it was necessary to develop new cut scores.
And we did that over the course of more than one conversation with our technical advisory group.
And we also shared this information with the California Petitions Advisory Group.
and have shared it since then of course with stakeholders over the last several days since the board item has been out.
So what we are proposing today is that new grade 11 status cut scores to be applied to high schools and high schools sometimes have grades 7 through 12 so we wanted to make sure we say that out loud and then to high school districts.
Unified districts and K-12 schools will still have them maintain the 3-8 status cut scores.
We didn't see, our data didn't show that there was a need to set separate cut scores for them.
The existing cut scores are still applicable for those types of schools.
So we are recommending that the State Board approve the status and change cut scores for Grader 11 academic indicator for English language arts and mathematics.
Board members, Strauss.
So on a follow-up on the CPAG conversation last week, and then member Valdez was also on the call, so we might want to talk about it.
But the cut scores for high school in literacy and math, and particularly in math, are incredibly troubling.
And I think they reflect a clear issue in mathematics achievement and the achievement gaps that we're seeing.
I believe orange and red were 48% in math, and I believe in literacy around 38% or so.
So again, I think there was a lot of discussion about and valid conversation and recommendations from our technical design team and the input from CPEG.
on where the cut scores are.
So I'm not challenging where the cut scores are.
What I am saying is I think we need to look at mathematics.
I think statewide we have some issues in mathematics that many of us are concerned about, and there are several reasons.
So I'm actually requesting that we also do a deeper dive into math early in the year for a couple of reasons.
One, it was our first standards and framework that we did after the freeze, and
It was a little faster process when we did our math framework and the materials adoption.
And one of the things that I've discovered in some of the work out in the field is that a lot of people are teaching the math books that are adopted, which are not necessarily fully aligned to the standards that we adopted.
So their pacing guides teach if the publisher has certain units in it, that's what's taught, and they're not necessarily everything that we assess.
And so in some cases, there are things that are missing on the books, and sometimes there's things that didn't need to be taught.
So a lot of districts have done a lot of work in redoing their pacing guides, looking for supplemental materials, getting some online materials.
And even the California Collaborative on District Reform, which is a lot of the core districts, are actually looking at the problem of practice in math in early December in Long Beach and kind of looking at what they've discovered about improvement.
SESASA through Bechtel Foundation not only supports
science implementation, they're supporting math implementation.
And I think we're learning a lot about what we need to do to address the math.
But I think my summary point is to support the recommendation, but to request early on that we take a look and revisit mathematics.
Particularly because we've been talking about needing to do an update on the framework that we need to take a look at the areas that we've now been out in the field realizing there's a problem.
And Stephanie Gregson, we've been in talk about that.
I think there's some real issues with some of the alignment of materials, I think.
the issues that our teacher leadership will tell you about coaching teachers and building capacity for teachers in mathematics is really important.
And I think this just highlights, I think the standards are rigorous and appropriate.
I don't think all of our teaching practices have lined up fully to it.
So that's a long story to say.
I'm seriously concerned about our achievement gap and our issues in mathematics, particularly, and I'm gonna request that we take a look at that.
early in the first few months of our next several meetings and see if we can pull together and do a Deeper look at what we know about math and where we need to go board member Rucker I Was the liaison for the work that was done with the math curriculum committee to create the framework as well as to do the develop make the decisions around the curriculum adoption and I was also involved with dr. curse in the conversation that followed after the math adoption and
where there was a great deal of criticism about the decisions that were made about the programs that were recommended by this board.
I think it's important to remember several things about the conversation that happened at the time.
It's not enough today to say we need to go back and look at math.
I think there's a conversation.
We need to remember.
Let me say, when I was a kid, Bullwinkle was my favorite cartoon.
And there was this character who had a Wayback Machine.
I think it would be nice if we could step back into that Wayback Machine and go back in time to sit in this room where the conversation and drafting the framework actually occurred.
Because there was a great deal of cognitive dissonance
in the room at the time when the math framework was being developed.
The cognitive dissonance was not around whether or not we're going to teach math.
The cognitive dissonance really was a disagreement about what the actual instructional shifts in the Common Core state standards actually meant.
And then we need to take a step further back in that way back machine
to that meeting that happened over at the County Office of Education, which by the way, around the corner from the county office was the sandwich shop that had the best brisket sandwiches.
Everybody was lining up every Tuesday to go there and get it, but that's a different story.
But the conversation that happened in the development of those standards, we stayed almost until midnight to do the adoption on the Common Core.
that cognitive dissonance actually started with the conversations around the adoption itself and the alignment of those standards.
So the problems that you are seeing with the instruction or the concerns about curriculum are not with the program.
not with the adoption, but it still rests with the fact that people do not have a fundamental consensus about what the instructional shifts for math instruction actually mean.
It was never fully cemented in the framework.
And what happened in the purposeful adoption of the math was to create a continuum of options for the implementation of the standards, not the implementation of the framework,
but the implementation of the standards themselves.
The adoption was intended to be a purposeful guide, but not the full definition of instruction or to be the only resource for instruction in math.
So if there is a gap in the instruction, the message was not lost in what was done with the rollouts.
I think the department staff did an excellent job with the planning they did on the rollouts, not only to talk about the use of the adoption in the framework,
in supporting math instruction, but also to build out and frame for LEAs what their responsibilities were to build out an instructional program, to help teachers understand it through their professional development, to purposefully look at the definition of those instructional shifts.
So it's not the curriculum, it's not the instruction, it's not the professional development.
What remains is what was seeded in the implementation of the math standards is this fundamental disagreement in the field among those people who say they know better than I do what math instruction means, about what it means to implement those instructional shifts, what the difference in the instructional shifts and the math progressions that everybody kept yelling about, and how that was supposed to work.
I'm fine with going forward with what we're doing here.
I think the issue about what the outcomes of the assessments look like and the fact that we have this great disparity in performance that everybody's concerned about is separate and distinct from the arguments that people continue to have
about the math program.
I think that we do need to have a conversation about the math program, but again, that's an input.
We need to still talk about the processes and the work that's to be done in a holistic way to look at math and math instruction.
That framework is different from
all of the other frameworks we've done.
It was developed differently and it was developed for a specific purpose and a specific idea about implementation, separate and different from what we did with English Language Arts, separate and different from what we've done with the other frameworks.
I think it's important to remember that.
So I had an opportunity last week with our cabinet in my day job to walk through classrooms at high schools.
And so I had an opportunity to speak to an intervention, a math intervention teacher, talking about just the concerns that he has.
And I agree with Member Rucker that it is about the mathematical practices.
That's the shift, if you will.
And so I think we have to answer the why, because the data is telling us, and we need to understand that, and we need to know how to get closer to the aim and whatever that aim might be.
We need to identify that.
One of them is the capacity of the workforce, and I know we have subject matter, you know, math subjects and so forth that can help with that.
I agree with member Strauss as well that I think we as a as an entity we need to be responsible for that data and really understand the why and
Together, I think we need to solve this problem, because it's not something that we can do up here.
There's capacity at the district level as well.
But we also have a generation of students who took it in 11th grade, didn't start out in the Common Core world.
So I think that's one of the things we do have to understand.
The rigor that we have put in, we are asking adults and students to think differently, and we're assessing them in a different way.
And it's not that it's a good way to assess them, but have they had that?
And it's not an excuse, but it is something that we have to take into consideration.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
I think you're right, because when I see my kids who are Common Core children, some of the math that looks so different to me, and I'm just grateful I have somebody in the classroom, my husband, that could assist.
But I think that in order for us to make that assert that maybe the younger kids who are Common Core babies are doing better, we need to have the data in front of us, right?
Because we need to validate that.
And if we see that that is still not the case, then we need to go a little further.
I heard Long Beach and so that's Long Beach Unified.
That's who I forgot.
See the college and career, college or career, college slash career indicator.
You referenced Long Beach Unified and I would love to see that.
That would be great if they could also maybe be part of our March meeting or the work group because I would like to see what other folks are doing.
It was also referenced Long Beach Unified for the math initiative.
So I would like to see what is Long Beach doing.
But I do want to say that there was a lot of concerns about this particular indicator not including 11th grade data back sometime, including it by using 3rd through 8th grade.
So I want to say that I think we've come a long way with this particular indicator that we're using 11th grade cut scores
11th grade data to identify 11th grade cut scores.
And we're also using the 95 participation rate, not an asterisk, but meaningfully included in the calculation.
So I think that's a really good thing for us.
Okay.
Are we ready for?
We have more.
Okay.
I know.
Sorry.
There's always more.
We're close, we're close.
Okay, so attachment six is about differentiated assistance criteria and you do have a table that now has that nice alignment of what state indicators will be used for differentiated assistance and what local indicators are.
And what we neglected to do when we brought forward the adoption of broad courses of study a year ago is contemplate how it would fit into differentiated assistance moving forward.
So the adoption in March of 2018
we probably should have brought this to you then.
Now that we're getting ready to run the data for differentiated assistance, we realized we had this overlap.
So the recommendation that we are bringing, well, this is the description behind it, is that
We want to make sure that students, of course, have that access to a broad course of study.
And I should mention that that guidance counselor conference that I attended in San Bernardino, they actually talked quite a bit about the broad course of study and the local indicator and what guidance counselors could do to help the school and the district respond to this local indicator.
So I thought that was really interesting.
But the recommendation is that we update the criteria for differentiated assistance to incorporate the new local indicator for a broad course of study.
So in doing so, the college career indicator for priority seven shifts out of that and remains in our outcomes piece, so priority eight.
Okay, questions on this?
Okay, so our last item that brings up for action is Jeff Breshears is going to briefly discuss.
Hi, good afternoon.
Jeff Breshears, the Director of the Local Agency Systems Support Office.
Before I start on this last attachment, I just wanted to make a reference to attachment aid and the outreach to stakeholders and also PD that was directed for local educational agencies around local indicators.
My office, or our office, with the support and the work of the Integrated Planning Support Team, which is a cross-branch, cross-division team, we put together a training, a two-season, two-webinar series for local indicators, going beyond just the nuts and bolts of how to do the local indicator and the self-reflection tools, but also then how to encourage the use of that data that they collect at the local level
to incorporate that into the LCAP planning process and then incorporate that data into the LCAP.
So that series, Tuesdays at 2, we reached right at 2,000 participants with an average of just over 300 for each session.
So I just wanted to take the opportunity to highlight the work of the Integrated Planning Support Team and thank them for the work that we worked together on that.
So to Attachment 7, we're just asking for two, a permission to do two things with the local indicators and self-reflection tools, specifically on Priority 2.
The second option for that self-reflection tool made reference to a specific year, 2015-16, which obviously is now out of date, so we'd like the ability to change that into more generic wording so it will be effective from the year moving forward.
And then also the self-reflection tools are no longer meeting the requirement for accessibility and posting 508 requirements.
So we're just looking for the ability to make work with state board staff and make those technical revisions to the self-reflection tools.
Question on this?
Board member Burr.
I don't know what 508 compliant means.
Could you explain that?
Sure.
So the Federal Section 508 of the Rehabilitation Act and Section 255 of the Communications Act were updated to clarify certain accessibility requirements for posting and for electronic communication.
So that's the reference to those.
You bet.
Okay.
Go ahead, Cindy.
Is that... I think we're working our way through it here.
We are almost there.
So attachment 8, I had already mentioned our contacts over the last... since the last board meeting.
So this is just in summary of attachment 8.
And then attachment 9 gives you our work plan, which is always subject to change.
But those are what we're planning on doing through
November 2020 we of course have March as our check-in with you about what is our work plan for the actual next couple of months so March will be that that time to engage on specifically what you're expecting for 2019 for the dashboard and then to roll to roll out we are on a
We are on target.
I'm assuming that everything we've presented to you today is is Passed to start a rolling preview of the dashboard next week We are going to host three separate webinars on the state indicators And we're also going to do a webinar on system of support after the dashboard is released So we we've had from our experience from a year ago taught us that this was really important to sort of lay the foundation and then
release the indicators on a rolling basis.
And so the first two indicators that districts will have a chance to make sure that the calculations are correct for are our high schools.
So we're going to look at college career first and graduation rate.
And the last time I looked at the deck, it's about 100 slides.
So we're going into deep, very deep in the weeds.
But our accountability directors will love us for that.
This is something that they really, really enjoy spending time on.
Those of them that really like the data and the
technical pieces.
The rest of, exactly, need a balance in their life.
And then Jeff mentioned the local indicators.
The submission date is a week from Friday, so November 16th.
And why that's important for us is because this is the first time we will encompass, differentiated assistance will encompass local indicators because we've hit our two-year mark for local indicators submission.
So, we are all on track to release the dashboard in early December, probably really close to what we did last year, which was December 7th.
And we are working with our state partners, our state agency partners, to make sure that all are on board for what will be needed next, which is building up that system of support to support districts that may now be eligible for technical assistance.
We no longer have a sanction and punish system.
I saw an article today that referenced that and it made me think that they hadn't been paying attention for the last couple years on this new system.
But I just wanted to mention that, you know, this whole system of support is, we're working hand in hand together.
We're trying to provide additional data analysis where it is needed for our geographic leads, our SELPA leads, the communications outreach.
So there's been
tremendous collaboration and with that I will turn it to President Kirst for the recommendation and public comment.
Can you just explain to me quickly what you said at the very beginning of this item about there being a note on the dashboard about the science?
Yes.
I should have written it verbatim.
But what the note says is that in future dashboards, we will be incorporating the science assessment into the dashboard.
So that is in the about the accountability system, which is a very high level description of the purpose of it.
And last thing, my colleagues at the California Science Teachers Association have brought to my attention that the schedule of significant events of the rollout has no mention of that in it.
And they would like to have that, especially since we're getting ready to have a leadership transition, to go ahead and have it in that schedule, even if it's approximately this time, you know, first best guess.
Can you do that?
We can definitely look at where we can, where we will work with our assessments office to make sure that we're doing it in a manner that which makes sense for the assessment.
Okay, perfect.
Thank you so much.
Board Member Burr.
Well, first, I just want to say thank you.
You might win the prize, Cindy, for the longest agenda items.
Although, although Deb is always right there because she posts the contract with ETS, which I think might might win out.
But just kudos to you and to your whole staff and Jenny for all of this work.
It's unbelievable what it takes to pull this all together.
So I want to express my appreciation.
I'm ready to make a motion whenever you want to.
But I also just wanted to sort of preview something that we talked about in our liaison calls because I always sort of worry about be careful what you wish for because once we said multiple measures, boy, did we get multiple measures.
And I do think it's pretty, it's starting to become clear that a lot of these measures kind of overlap with each other and are highly correlated to each other.
You mentioned, for example, the question about chronic absenteeism.
We know it's very, it has a very, I won't use the term correlate, because I know my data friends will say that's not exactly right.
But it's very related to and measures similar characteristics to graduation rate.
So one thing that we talked about is now that we're caught up and we have the data, then I think it's really important to engage probably outside evaluators to help us with this, to identify where those things are closely correlated.
So that potentially we can combine indicators,
or we can create a mega indicator or whatever.
Because as we talked about this morning, we're just scratching the surface with differentiated assistance and with districts really being able to kind of pull things apart.
The more stuff we throw at them, I think the harder it becomes.
And so if we can simplify it a little bit, I think that could be helpful.
So I just hope as we talk about this, maybe in March or whenever we're going to do this workshop, that we start that conversation so that we don't overwhelm LEAs with, you know, so much data that they don't even know where to start.
Okay, Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I think throughout the item, there was a lot of things that made sense to me.
I didn't have a lot of questions, but I just came to the schedule of activities.
And I do have a question about the LPI.
So, May of 2019, we're looking at options for including it in terms of identifying schools for support.
And I know that we don't have, we won't have the years
the LPAC data that we'll need to have the status and change.
And so I appreciate that we're looking at different ways to explore using the scores to identify schools.
But it says update on options for using the LPI status in the identification of schools for support under ESSA.
So I'm guessing that means not under LCFF or LEAs.
Is that correct?
At this time, you will hear about the incorporation under ESSA in the next item, but there has not been the consideration of bringing it into the LCFF differentiated assistance at this time.
So what is the timeline?
Because again, we're moving into
two-tier system of support, and we want to have one system of accountability.
And so the minute we say under ESSA, we'll identify schools, but not LEAs, and I just picked up on it right now as I read it a little bit more.
So there is going to be staggered timelines.
There's going to be a year where we'll identify, use LPI to identify LEAs, but then there's going to be a separate timeline for identifying schools.
That would be the proposal that you're going to take up next, under the next item.
We can definitely take that piece of it up in March.
So as we bring on more data, we can move towards that.
I understand what you're saying about differentiated assistance.
So we can definitely bring that back.
Can you move it from May to March then?
Because right now you have it under May.
Maybe add that to the March.
You know, I will work with the executive director and state board staff to see where it makes most sense.
I know you have, as you mentioned, there's going to be new members coming on board and we're cognizant that we can
be very overwhelming in this multiple measure system.
And so, you know, we want to make sure that we're working with making sure we have the priorities in place so we can definitely work together to figure out what's appropriate.
Okay.
Thanks.
And then Board Member Cardenas.
My comments relating the local indicators are like student engagement and I know the dashboard is coming up but just looking in the future and things to add is how can we look at local indicators for student engagement similar to the parent engagement and how can we start measuring how students are making decisions on their campuses like the parents because I feel like
When people are talking about student engagement a lot, they're always talking about like absenteeism and graduation.
But how are we going to talk about engagement in forms of how are they engaging in the classroom?
And how can we measure it in that way?
So just like a comment and looking forward to seeing the dashboard.
Maybe it's a holistic comment that member Burt has asked about how not only our state indicators are acting, but I think what you're suggesting is how the locals are interacting.
So maybe.
Thank you.
Karen Valdez.
I think one of the opportunities in having all of these different indicators is it's changing the mindset of districts, and they're moving from the indicator to actually looking at their practices.
But I just wanted to thank you, Cindy, and your staff for the rollout that you're going to be doing with the dashboard.
I think it's very thoughtful, very intentional.
It's going to be very practical and digestible for the districts to hear a little bit, see a little bit, hear a little bit, see a little bit.
So thank you very, very much for that.
Public comment.
Will the following people please line up?
Doug McRae, Eric Premack, Jessica Sacco, Stephen Blake, Brian Rivas, Martha Diaz, Samantha Tran.
Good afternoon, I'm Doug McRae, Retired Educational Measurement Specialist.
The cut scores for the 2018 dashboard academic indicators for grades 3 through 8 only are currently based on 2017 Smarter Balanced results.
If the cut scores, 2017 cut scores are left in place for 2018 and future dashboards,
They will not represent credible achievement targets for 2018 or future years.
Rather, 2017 cut scores need adjustments to reflect the 2018 Smarter Balanced scores, which are somewhere between the healthy gains from 2016 and the much lower gains 2017.
Analysis for this important issue is found in materials submitted to electronic folder, including a handout.
The 18 academic indicator cut scores need to be set somewhere between the optimistic targets established in 2016 and the lowball pessimistic targets established in 2017.
I'd urge the board to address this problem before the 2018 dashboard is released in December.
To my knowledge, this issue has not been in public before.
Thank you.
Good morning, or good afternoon now.
Jessica Sacco representing California Science Teachers Association.
Thank you to Member Williams and Ms.
Casanas for your conversation about the science on the dashboard.
That was very helpful information and we certainly look forward to working with Ms.
Casanas' team as well as the center team to figure out when that makes sense to put on there.
We would really encourage the State Board and the CDE to take the same approach of thoughtful planning when adding an indicator to the dashboard.
And to that end, given that data is going to be available as early as next year, that that planning begins sooner and more along the lines within the next year or two, rather than waiting until we have multiple years of data before we even start the planning process.
So we would just encourage that planning and conversation to be occurring now.
And thank you.
Good afternoon, Samantha Tran with Children Now.
Children Now is really encouraged by the development of the multi measures system in California and all the progress that's been made.
As this work continues, we have a couple of recommendations that are grounded in the materials you have before you.
First, we're really excited that alternative education students are going to be incorporated into the system for the first time.
However,
The particular proposal around the one-year graduation and the four-year graduation rate seems to create a loophole that we would like the board to look at for those students who are deficient in credits more than a year.
They won't be included in the calculation and so these are among our most vulnerable kids and we need to make sure that they're visible.
So we'd encourage the board to get clarity on that to make sure we're counting all kids.
In addition, on chronic absenteeism, as we were looking at the cut scores, we'd encourage you to revisit that 20 percent at the very high level.
If it takes one out of every five kids to be chronically absent before you get a status of red, that's a concern.
And it also echo the comments of Ms.
Sadakow on science.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, Leigh Angela Reed on behalf of the Association of California School Administrators and the Small School Districts Association.
Real quickly, ACCESS supports the CDE recommendations relative to the three by five grid and for the chronic absenteeism indicator, the inclusion of the seal of biliteracy and leadership military science in the CCI, the revision of the cut scores for graduation rate for low and medium status levels,
the adoption of the one-year modified graduation and revision to the self-reflection tool.
They look to convene their accountability task force this fall and put together some concrete recommendations when the board goes to revise for the annual process of revision in March.
And they would ask the board to consider making November 19th kind of the pause point for modifying indicators
so that there's some stability if possible.
On behalf of SSDA, dang it.
I just wanted to thank you all for the comments and work relative to being sorry, trying to choose hard.
Thank you on behalf of the Small School Association for the comments relative to the graduation rate changes.
And we think that's very important and it helps protect regional programs.
Thank you.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing CABE and Californians Together.
My first point is specific to the academic cut scores for grade 11.
When examining the five by five grids for districts and schools specific to English learners in ELA and math,
We see that there are a high number of districts and schools that fall in the red and orange categories.
This is a concern of ours.
To us, this clearly demonstrates the need for targeted support for these schools and for these students.
And to please bear this in mind when discussing how we're going to identify schools for targeted assistance.
We are also concerned about the gaps that we've seen specifically around math, and we agree that there needs to be another in-depth look with regards to why and what can be done to address the achievement gaps.
My second point relates to attachment six, table one, with regards to the priority seven, just to include information by student subgroup.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm Stephan Blake representing the California STEM Network.
We appreciate Dr. Williams referencing in Attachment 9 the need to include some reference, some indicator of science assessment on the dashboard.
Our 14 regional cross-sector networks work with a lot of local districts and
We continue to hear that as we've expressed to you in the past, local districts are making decisions on planning and budgeting based on accountability, on what they have to do at this time.
We know that so much is on their plate.
So we think it's critical that as quickly as possible you move to include reference to science onto the dashboard so that they're planning now.
We don't think you can wait another two years before the planning begins.
We greatly appreciate Ms.
Kazanis indicating her willingness to work within the department to move this forward.
In the meantime, we also want to reiterate our recommendation of the past that you include a placeholder on the dashboard basically to signal to LEAs how important science is to this board and all the work that you've done in the last five years and that they begin to think about that today.
Thank you.
President Kirst, I'm Brian Rivas speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
First, I want to say we need to study the interplays, so to speak, between the four-year graduation rate and the one-year rate.
And I want to ask you to maybe think about doing a deeper dive on that issue.
Some of our most trusted partners have flagged that perhaps there could be a blind spot where there could be a cohort of students who
are invisible in accountability if they arrive at an alternative setting before they've reached, I believe, grade 12 status.
But we're going to be studying that more carefully, and I think it's an important wrinkle that you take a look at.
I agree with my colleague, Mr. Blake, about the importance of demonstrating to the field that you're taking the science indicator and assessment seriously, and you're planning for them.
in the accountability system, and that sends signals to the field about how to allocate resources.
And then lastly, we continue to feel that the decision on chronic absence was a missed opportunity.
Would really love to have that on the dashboard at the high school level.
Thank you.
Okay, that concludes the public comment, and now we're ready for a motion.
Board Member Burr.
I move the department's recommendations as articulated on these two slides.
Recommendations one through seven, I think.
Second.
All right.
Any further board discussion?
If not, I'll raise your hand.
It's already been done.
Well, on the dashboard you're asking about.
We will add it.
Okay.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, good.
Passes unanimously.
And now we're on to item five, which these are two interrelated items.
A short break.
Okay.
We will take a short break to 210.
Okay, the board will reconvene and we will take up item five.
on the ESSA update issues and tying into our last discussion.
Go ahead.
You may begin.
Good afternoon, President Kirst, Superintendent Torrelson, and members of the board.
I've jokingly been asked to move this along so people can go back to their offices and warm up because it's so cold in here.
An important item, so thank you for your time this afternoon.
So as President Kirst suggested, I will provide information related to this item.
The update on the development of the California State Plan for the Every Student Succeeds Act.
Approval of the revisions to the state plan for resubmission to the US Department of Education.
I know it feels like I was just here talking about the state plan.
Here we are again.
There are a number of suggested amendments for you in your materials today and the majority of these amendments are related to action that the board has already taken related to just updates for our dashboard and accountability system.
So I give this slide in every presentation.
It never hurts to remind us that it was one of the final actions of then President Obama to reauthorize the Elementary and Secondary Education Act to become ESSA, the Every Student Succeeds Act in December of 2015.
ESSA maintains the original purpose of ESEA to provide equal opportunity for all students and to ensure that disadvantaged and high need students receive the same educational opportunity as their peers.
Given that this board has heard a number of updates related to the state plan, my comments today will be related to activities of the last few months.
So, at the board's April meeting, you recommended approval of the revised state plan.
At that time, the board also directed CDE to develop a waiver request to the U.S.
Department of Education related to the English Learner Progress Indicator, or LB, which I will discuss on future slides.
At the July 2018 meeting, the state board took action to approve a revised state plan which was submitted on the 12th of that month and approved less than 24 hours later.
We have an approved ESSA state plan.
In August, the CDE provided an ESSA implementation information memorandum to the board.
This memo includes an implementation timeline, key ESSA implementation activities and decision points for 2018, and a comparison chart of LEA and school identification under the local control funding formula and the ESSA.
ESSA and LCFF stakeholder meetings have been held since the plan was approved in July.
Most recently, the CDE hosted ESSA public in-person and webinar meetings on October 5th and November 2nd related to various aspects of ESSA implementation, including school identification, the dashboard, and the per-pupil expenditure reporting requirements of the state educational agency
and LEA report cards.
All stakeholder sessions were very well attended with over 300 participants at the October meeting.
And it is a format that the CDE will continue to use next on December 10th and approximately once a month in 2019 to reach our intended stakeholder audience.
At the January 2019 State Board meeting, the CDE plans to present an agenda item regarding ESSA implementation that my colleague Cindy Kazanis mentioned, building upon the August 2018 information memorandum.
So here's the slide for the recommendation today.
I'll read it now and repeat it again at the end of my presentation.
So the California Department of Education recommends that the State Board of Education approve the amendments to California's ESSA State Plan for submission to the U.S.
Department of Education pending the State Board of Education Executive Director approval of final revisions requested by the State Board, correction of any typographical errors, and any necessary non-substantive clarifying edits.
There are three attachments related to this item.
Attachment 1 includes an overview and summary of the recommended state plan amendments the board will consider today.
Attachment 1 was revised to update the page number references in the section November 2018 summary, refine the status cut stores for the graduation rate indicator, and on page 4,
To include a summary of an additional proposed amendment in the section, other proposed amendments, summary, typographical and other corrections, comprehensive support and improvement schools, section 6B on page 7.
Attachment 2 is the ESSA state plan inclusive of the proposed plan amendments.
And attachment 3 is the letter from the U.S.
Department of Education signed by Secretary DeVos approving our state plan.
At the board's April meeting, as I mentioned, the board directed CDE to request a four-year waiver from the U.S.
Department of Education.
If granted, the waiver would allow California to include recently reclassified fluent English-proficient students in measuring the progress of English learners to achieve English language proficiency and provide additional weight for long-term English learners.
The CDE submitted the waiver request in May, and on October 9, California received what is known in ESSA statute as an initial determination of denial from the U.S.
Department of Education.
ESSA statute does not allow for an appeals process per se of our waiver, but states may revise and resubmit their waiver request within 60 days of receiving that initial determination letter.
California submitted our request on October 17th.
In writing our response letter, we did not change the content of the waiver request itself, but rather updated the arguments in support of our waiver based on the content of the letter we received earlier that month.
The Secretary of Education has 30 days to respond to California's letter.
If the waiver is again denied, California may request a hearing as the final opportunity in the waiver request process.
The CD will work with the board and board staff to determine next steps based on the outcome of the Secretary's final decision.
When I'm out and about and sharing this information with other stakeholders, I'm often asked, well, how do you think the secretary will ultimately decide?
I have two small children and I naively thought when the second one was born that they would be the same child, they would hit the same developmental milestones, that they would have the same likes and dislikes.
My older one
hated to be swaddled.
She used it as a Houdini opportunity.
My second one loved to be swaddled and would just fall happily asleep when she was all bundled up.
So all of this to say, you can't predict what the people in your lives are going to do.
I can't predict what the US Department of Education is going to do.
So again, based on what the ultimate decision is from the US Department of Education, please be assured that we are working closely with board staff and your liaisons
to take this as far as we can through the process to ultimately, hopefully receive the answer that we want, which is an approved waiver.
But we will see and we will work with board staff on whatever that outcome may be.
So I also want to highlight that the proposed amendments to the state plan included in this item do not include any of the changes based on the pending LP waiver request.
They really are separate and apart.
I understand how they can be confusing because they're both about the LP.
So I'm going to endeavor to describe how they are different issues.
So the proposed amendments today before you fall within three groupings.
Those revisions to that dashboard and accountability system already acted upon by the State Board in September and just moments ago with your recommendation action related to item four.
and other proposed amendments.
Those are the three areas.
So in September, the board took action on new measures for the College and Career Indicator and adopted a revised methodology for the Chronic Absenteeism Indicator.
As a part of the item you just heard with Cindy Kazanas, the board adopted cut points to prepare for the inclusion of two new indicators for the 2018 dashboard, the College and Career Indicator and the Chronic Absenteeism Indicator.
You made the decision to include grade 11 Smarter Balanced assessment results in the academic indicator and refined the status cut scores for the graduation rate indicator to take into consideration modifications made to the calculations of the four-year cohort graduation rate.
So before I begin this slide, I wanted to offer a correction on behalf of Cindy.
Your board materials for item four were correct, but she wanted me to let you know that she misspoke.
When you think about school identification under ESSA, as well as LEA identification for differentiated assistance under LCFF, the use of the LB and sort of the ramping up of information that will be available each year,
will be identical processes for both.
So we apologize for the confusion, but the way that school identification is happening is the same for LEA identification.
The two methods will be the same.
So the CDE recommends that the board include amendments to the state plan that include additional detail about the plan for English Learner Progress Indicator, or LB, to transition to the new assessment of English language proficiency, including updating the timeline for identifying schools under ESSA to include an additional cohort of school identification based on the 2019 dashboard.
and including the LP based on status only.
The board will recall that California has transitioned to a new assessment of English language proficiency, the English Language Proficiency Assessments for California or the LPAC.
The 2018 LPAC results will serve as a baseline from which future English learner progress for accountability purposes will be measured and should not be compared to results from the state's previous assessment, the California English Language Development Test or CELDT.
Most other dashboard indicators need only two years of assessment results to calculate status and change.
In contrast, the LPA must measure progress towards proficiency rather than the end goal of proficiency itself.
To measure progress towards English language proficiency, two years of LPAC summative results are required.
To determine if schools and LEAs are improving at the rate of their progress in moving towards English language proficiency, three years of LPAC summative results are required.
In 2018, excuse me, in July 2018, the State Board approved a three-year plan for the LP.
Under this plan, status will be reported on the 2019 dashboard when two years of LPAC summative results are available.
And the CD anticipates that for the 2020 dashboard, both status and change will be reported, thus generating a color on the dashboard in 2020.
After the CDE published the August information memorandum on ESSA implementation and the associated timelines, several stakeholders, including several of our board members, including member Ortiz-Licon, have noted correctly that an area of potential misalignment between the LEA level planning cycle under the LCFF and the school level planning cycle and improvement timelines required under the ESSA, they're misaligned.
Under the LCFF, every LEA must adopt and annually update Local Control and Accountability Plans, or LCAPs, a three-year plan describing the LEA's goals, actions, and expenditures to advance those goals within statutorily defined priority areas.
Based on the current cycle, LEAs will develop a new three-year LCAP in the spring of 2020 based on the 2019 dashboard and other local data.
Under the ESSA, states must identify schools for assistance beginning in 2018-19.
For two of the three categories of assistance mandated under the ESSA, what's known as CSI or Comprehensive Support and Improvement and Additional Targeted Support or ATSI, the identification must occur at least every three years.
The current version of the state plan includes an every three-year cycle of initial identification for schools for CSI and ATSI based on the 2018 dashboard.
As I mentioned, stakeholders have noted that this potential misalignment of developing school-level plans as LEAs are in their final year of their fixed three-year LCAP.
They have noted the opportunity for the LEA and school-level planning processes to feed into each other and inform each other of the three-year cycles, and they should be, could and should be aligned.
Therefore, the CDE recommends the State Board adopt two amendments to the State Plan to address these concerns and issues.
Number one, the revised state plan includes language clarifying that California will report status for the LP on the 2019 dashboard.
And number two, the revised state plan modifies the timeline for identifying schools for CSI and ATSI, stating that California will identify schools in these categories in consecutive years based on the 2018 and 2019 dashboards before transitioning to the every three year cycle.
This will allow the LP to be used for the LEA and school identification
based on status in the 2019 dashboard.
The CDE anticipates that by aligning the three-year LCAP cycle and the school-level planning cycles for schools identified for assistance under the ESSA, it will strengthen both planning processes and lead to greater alignment between LEA and school-level goals and actions.
The CDE also recommends the board approve an amendment to reflect the incorporation of the participation rate into the calculation of the academic indicator, as well as revisions to reflect the evolution and additional details regarding the system of support.
Included in the revised state plan are other typographical corrections and removal of the language inadvertently left in the final version of the state plan approved by the U.S.
Department of Education in July.
One of those was related to the final paragraph in the Comprehensive Support and Improvement School Identification Criteria in page 77 of the plan.
Staff initially flagged that this paragraph as potentially needing to be updated, but it was ultimately concluded that it didn't need to be updated, but was inadvertently left in.
A second correction relates to the new cut scores for the graduation rate indicator on page 50.
The revised table was inadvertently not swapped out in attachment to the revised state plan, but it will be included in the final version submitted to the U.S.
Department of Education.
So here we are, the final recommendation and to President Kirst, thank you.
Some of this we've discussed in the prior item.
So this is aligning some timelines and other things.
So board member questions.
Ting, yeah, Ting Sun.
Thank you for your presentation.
I think we are at a point where we are just ready to move forward and we're doing all of the cleanup that we need to do and we will await the waiver request.
Seeing no other board questions, public comment.
Will the following individuals please sign up at the podium?
Brian Rivas, Martha Diaz, Rigel Massaro.
If you don't mind me going out of turn.
Good afternoon, President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
My name is Rigel Massaro with Public Advocates.
My comments regarding CSI, TSI, and ATSI are aligned to the letter submitted by the Equity Coalition.
First we suggest the state provide some assurance to CSI schools and their LEAs that a minimal level of funding will be provided for them to make coherent three-year plans so that they're not planning and then wondering whether they're going to be supported in future years to realize those plans.
Second, we'd like to see some explanation or plan of how the school's identified support will be made known to the public.
Our current state system, it's pretty cumbersome for families and advocates even to understand why districts are being tagged for
assistance and support from county offices.
And finally, we know that ESSA requires schools to plan for any resource inequities.
We have yet to see an explanation of how the school plans, the LCAP, will specifically address those issues.
Thank you.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing CABE and Californians Together.
We are supportive of moving forward with the resubmittal of the EL waiver to the USDOE, allowing California to include recently reclassified students in measuring the progress of English learners in their proficiency of English and to provide additional weight for long-term English learners.
We do respectfully request the board to include in the state plan references to the English Learner Roadmap again where appropriate.
We believe in doing so it would provide visibility and assist in the implementation of the roadmap approved by the State Board of Education.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Samantha Tran with Children Now.
We applaud the recommendation to include the ELPI in 2019 and also agree with board member Ortiz-Lincoln's point about trying to create greater alignment between school and district implementation.
In addition, we support the inclusion of the 11th grade data in the academic indicator and thank the board for moving in that direction.
And then finally, we're supportive of the overarching vision around the school identification for 2018 and 19.
But I feel like there's some further discussion around how the funding will work and the allocations as well as some of the exit methodology.
And so look forward to working with the board, staff and CDE to have those conversations.
Thank you very much.
President Kirst, I'm Brian Revis, speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
First, with regard to the identification of low-performing schools under the ESSA requirements, we'd like you to consider establishing some minimum standards for transparency or notice to the public.
We think it's important for parents and communities to know when a school is identified under one of the categories.
It's an important indication of school quality
It's also important for people to know that they have an opportunity to participate in the planning for improvement.
So we'd like to see some minimum standards there.
Secondly, I agree with what my colleague, Ms.
Massaro, from Public Advocates said around the need to ensure that these schools are aligning the planning requirements associated with, and I forget what the acronym now stands for, but it used to be the Single Plan for Student Achievement, I believe.
Okay, well thank you.
And the LCAP.
But we want to make sure that that conversation includes a look at resource inequities.
Thank you.
I'm Caitlin Jung on behalf of the Small School District Association.
We appreciate the work that's being done to align SPSA with the LCAP, in particular the recognition of the unique circumstances that face small school districts.
I especially want to thank Sunita at the department for working with SSDA on the FAQ and the guidance for both the SPSA and the school site councils.
Thank you.
So good afternoon.
LeAngela Reed on behalf of the Association of California School Administrators.
ACSA is very pleased with the monthly stakeholder meetings and the three webinars that are being hosted to discuss how ESSA implementation will fit into the state's overarching accountability system and the emerging state system of support.
ACSA is very disappointed, as we all are, that the Federal Department of Ed rejected
our initial waiver request.
And we commend the department and the state board staff for their thoughtful considerations in crafting a really balanced state indicator that indicates the, that recognizes the trajectory of our English learners students on their journey to become reclassified as English proficient.
And we have every hope that the revised waiver will be approved this next time.
Thanks.
Okay, that concludes the public comment.
And so we're now ready for a motion.
Ortiz-Lacon, further discussion?
I do have a question.
And I try to go back to the ESSA state plan.
And after reading it so many times, I'm like, I'll just ask the question.
The identification.
So I know that if you open the dashboard and you see a school with predominantly red and orange,
And I think there are some training modules that parents are receiving, and you'll have a sense that, well, perhaps the school's under comprehensive or targeted intervention.
But there's nothing right now that will really indicate that and indicate to a parent where your school is ranking, if it's under support.
So how are we hoping to do that?
I know that we've had this conversation before and it said, well, we'll get to it when we're proposing new changes to the data dashboard.
I know that at some point we said maybe we could have a little icon that indicates what level of support, but we never really landed anywhere.
So, can you give us an update?
I know that there was a couple of comments regarding that as well.
Sure.
So, CDE and State Board staff have been working together on the rollout of identification that will happen.
So, of course, it will begin with the dashboard in December, but then the identification of schools will formally happen in January.
And we're still working out the final details, but what will likely happen is in early January, there will be a preview period.
for LEAs so they can be aware of what the results and different types of identification for their particular schools and their LEA will be.
So they have roughly a week's heads up before the information is made public and then the information will be shared publicly.
We're shooting for mid to late January of the data file that will be available for the public of which schools are identified.
as a data file or within the dashboard?
As currently planned, there will not be an indication on the dashboard of the school's identification status for the ESSA for CSI, TSI, or ATSI.
It will be included in the data file.
OK.
And I think that's something that we should probably bring to some of our bodies just for feedback, PTA and others, because some of us will know how to get that list and navigate and try to figure out where does my school fall, but not every parent has access to the resources we do.
So I know that I'm in a privileged place as a parent, but I also know that there is a lot of parents who may not have access to that, the language, the navigational skills.
So I think it's important for us to bring that level of transparency for our parents.
Okay.
Board member Valdez.
So just a comment.
One of my greatest concerns right now is the sense of urgency of getting this information in front of local school boards as cabinet members and as district leadership.
And I feel like there aren't enough tools.
I know going forward we have great systems of communication and so forth.
But in the next six weeks, probably districts have one more board meeting to do something, to tell them something, because we need to get this out there before it goes public.
And I'm afraid we're not going to put our leadership in the right place in terms of being able to communicate clearly.
So I know one of the slides that Melanie showed did show all three or four areas, if you will, but I feel like those tools need to be out there.
And I think
Um...
It was shared this morning that the superintendents didn't know much even about systems of support.
And so this this part is going to be even more difficult and confusing.
And so I think it's just really important.
So I encourage the department to look at that.
Thank you.
I will say that those materials and resources are well underway.
And my colleagues like Cindy and myself and many others have really been out and about sharing the word.
But certainly working with school boards is an important stakeholder audience.
Thank you.
Okay, Ting, are you ready for a motion?
I'd make the motion for CD's recommendation.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Carries unanimously.
Okay, we're now on to item six and this is a public hearing, but we're going to start with Stephanie Gregson who is going to present it.
Then we'll have some comments from Eileen Strauss, our liaison, and then
We'll open it up to board questions and then we'll open up the public hearing after that.
Yeah.
Let's see.
All right.
Well, good afternoon, President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson and esteemed members of the board.
I'm Stephanie Gregson, the Executive Director of the Instructional Quality Commission and a card-carrying member of the Rocky and Bullwinkle Fan Club.
This is such an exciting day.
We are concluding the process for the largest adoption the state of California has led, and it's science.
I'd like to give a huge thank you and shout out to the Curriculum Frameworks and Instructional Resources Division staff for their amazing coordination of this work.
They are definite swaddling experts, secret rocks.
To help me present the process and recommendations of the Instructional Quality Commission, I have with me Dean Reese, Chair of the Instructional Quality Commission.
Commissioner Reese will briefly review the instructional shifts from the California Science Framework
that are represented in the instructional materials recommended by the IQC, and then present the recommendations of the Instructional Quality Commission.
But first, I'd like to walk you through the process that has brought us in front of you today.
The adoption process is a lengthy one, but an inclusive one, with many steps that are defined in statute and in the California Code of Regulations.
The next few slides will be an overview of the major milestones that have brought us to this meeting today.
In some ways, this process began in November of 2016 when the State Board of Education adopted the new California Science Framework.
The new curriculum framework has been the basis for this foundation, both because of the new content and instructional shifts throughout the document and the fact that the evaluation criteria used for this adoption is part of the framework.
In March 2017, the State Board of Education approved the schedule of significant events and the reviewer application for the adoption.
After the framework was adopted, the CDE conducted several initial briefings of publishers participating in the adoption.
These briefings took place during the summer of 2017.
We called them Science Tuesdays because they were held almost every Tuesday.
And we had over 70 participants within each of the sessions.
The publisher trainings focused on the content of the new curriculum framework by grade level and how the instructional shifts should translate into instructional materials.
In November 2017, the state board appointed the instructional materials reviewers and content review experts that were recommended by the Instructional Quality Commission.
A total of 120 people were appointed to review the materials.
The board also approved several non-commissioners to serve as review panel facilitators.
On January 30th, 2018, the California Department of Education hosted the publisher's invitation to submit meeting where the statutory and regulatory requirements for participation in the adoption process were explained.
This meeting was open to the public and invited public comment.
Title V regulations require a majority of instructional material reviewers be classroom teachers in the area of science.
The board appointed 75 classroom teachers out of a total of 120 reviewers for 16 panels.
Per Title V regulations, each panel had a board-appointed content review expert with a doctoral degree in the science area.
The panels also included board-appointed curriculum leaders and community members.
All reviewers received a week-long training at the Doubletree Hotel in Sacramento, because they have really good chocolate chip cookies, on April 16th through 20th.
The board-appointed reviewers were trained to evaluate the submitted programs for alignment with the standards, the framework, and the evaluation criteria adopted by the board.
Reviewers had the privilege of being sworn in by Member Strauss.
And on the final day of the training, reviewers attended presentations by the publishers of the programs that they were assigned to review.
The reviewer training was an open meeting and public comment was called for each day of the training.
During the summer, following training, each reviewer conducted an independent and extensive review of the instructional materials assigned to his or her panel.
This independent review was conducted over a two-month time period, with each reviewer spending hundreds of hours reviewing the text for alignment to the standards, framework, and evaluation criteria.
As a former reviewer, I can appreciate the time and table space it takes to conduct this review.
We really thank all of the reviewers for their time and expertise.
They had amazing diligence during this process.
Reviewer deliberations were held at the Sacramento Doubletree again, because they have really good chocolate chip cookies, on July 17th through the 20th.
During the deliberations, the reviewer met in 16 panels to discuss and evaluate the 34 programs that were submitted to review.
Yes.
The panels were forwarded and any public comment related to their program to review prior to deliberations.
And during deliberation, panels took public comment twice each day.
And after much discussion and reaching consensus on their recommendations, the panel members developed a report of findings for each program.
And these reports were forwarded to the commission and they are posted on the CDE website.
Throughout the 2018 Science Instructional Materials adoption process, there were 20 separate meetings with opportunities for public comment.
On August 13th, it was a dedicated meeting specifically for public comment for the Instructional Quality Commission.
Additionally, the CDE received 102 separate submissions of comments from the public, including publishers during this process.
And all public comments received were submitted to the State Board of Education office.
On September 20th and 21st, the members of the Instructional Quality Commission considered the recommendations from the review panels, public comments, and reports from individual commissioners to determine whether each program satisfied or did not satisfy the state board adopted evaluation criteria for this adoption.
Prior to action, the Instructional Quality Commission conducted two public hearings, one during the Science Subject Matter Committee meeting on September 20th, and one during the full Instructional Quality Commission meeting on September 21st.
Over the entire process, the commissioners heard testimony from nine members of the public.
So this brings us to today, an exciting day for the California instructional world of science.
And Commissioner Reese will now briefly describe the instructional shifts from the California Science Framework that are represented in the instructional materials recommended by the IQC.
Thank you, Dr. Gregson.
There are considerable instructional shifts in the teaching and learning of science in California.
These shifts are outlined in the Introduction to the California Science Framework and the grade level chapters.
In summary, the Next Generation Science Standards capture the excitement of learning science from a perspective that allows students to experience science as a practitioner of science and less as a passive learner of science.
This is achieved by using a phenomenon at the beginning of the lesson sequence and throughout the lesson sequence to engage students in the learning.
The phenomenon provides a rich context, allowing three dimensions of NGSS, the science and engineering practices, the disciplinary core ideas, and the cross-cutting concepts to be utilized in the lesson.
Additionally, there is an emphasis on coherency across the K-12 curriculum.
Core ideas are revisited in more depth in each grade band, allowing students to build on their prior knowledge, drill down into complex and abstract topics in middle school and high school, and increase their skill with science and engineering practices over time.
Finally, an important shift that has been included in the California science is an emphasis in connecting science learning to their local communities and to student interests.
Thank you.
So I now have the pleasure of presenting information on the recommendation of the Instructional Quality Commission.
As chair of the IQC, I would be remiss if I did not mention the appreciation the commission has for the participation of the members of the public in providing their input on the instructional materials.
The commission took their role to heart and conducted their review with the utmost diligence.
The recommendation of the commission are in the IQC advisory report, which was provided as an attachment to this item.
The commission is recommending 29 of the 34 programs submitted for this adoption.
The IQC advisory report includes not only our reasons for recommending or not recommending each program with citations in each of the five categories of the state board adopted criteria, but also lists the recommended edits and corrections, including social content citations,
publisher-submitted errata for each program.
It is our recommendation that these recommended edits be considered as a condition for adoption if the State Board elects to adopt these materials.
These recommended edits came from a combination of A, the report of the panels of reviewers that the board appointed to evaluate the materials, B, comments from the public that requested that edits be made to the materials, and C, errata submitted by the publishers.
The commissioners carefully considered all of these sources of input when discussing and deciding which edits to add to our recommendation.
On the next three slides,
show the 29 recommended programs by grade level.
This particular slide shows K-5, K-6, and K-8, and they'll follow on the next few slides too.
So this slide shows the various options for the 6-8 integrated.
And then as I noted, the commission decided to recommend 29 of 34 programs.
This slide shows the options for 6-8 discipline specific.
Having so many choices in our science instructional resources allows districts the opportunity to choose a program that meets their specific student needs and program needs.
Okay, thank you.
And so this is the slide that shows that while we've recommended 29 of the 34 programs, but the commission is not recommending one program submitted by Carolina Biological Supply Company, one program submitted by Knowing Science, and three programs submitted by TPS Publishing Company.
The reasons for this negative recommendation are included in our report, but in short, the commission felt that these programs did not meet several of the criteria statements in Category 1 and 4.
It is our view that the fixes that would be needed to correct these issues would be rewrites, and these are disallowed as part of our process.
If you adopt our recommendation, then you will be adopting more than five programs for kindergarten through grade five.
Therefore, this would meet the requirement in Ed Code section 60200E that requires more than five programs be adopted for kindergarten through grade five.
We know that you have to conduct a public hearing before you take action on the adoption and that there are people waiting to speak.
But on behalf of the commission, I would like to thank the board for its support throughout the adoption.
process.
We hope that the materials you adopt today will provide support for districts across the state in implementing the instructional shifts and the new content in the science framework.
Thank you, Chair Reese.
There have been many questions of what will happen after the State Board takes action today, so I'm going to quickly review those.
Once the State Board takes action today, there's a 60-day timeline for publishers to submit all edits and corrections to be verified by California Department of Education.
I'd like to note that the materials seen linked to the CDE website currently do not reflect any edits or corrections recommended by the IQC.
They are in the original format that the reviewers use to conduct their review.
The final versions of the instructional materials will not be available until the State Board adopted edits and corrections have been made.
I'd like to also highlight that besides the wonderful diversity of California, another beautiful element of California is the local control our local school districts have to make choices that are in the best interest of their students and community.
These choices also apply to adopting instructional materials.
The California process is designed to offer district choices of instructional materials to match the needs of their students.
Not all instructional materials are alike and that is a benefit for districts.
Each district will have multiple options as they conduct their own review of instructional materials that either are on the state board adopted list or not on the state board adopted list.
The state level review is that first level review to share with districts the materials that meet the content of the standards, the framework, and the criteria.
Districts then should engage in their own review of instructional materials to analyze which programs best fit their student program and pedagogical needs.
As a former principal and district administrator, this choice is invaluable for teachers and students.
I have personally experienced the benefit of teachers being able to go through an analysis process of many programs to choose the one that best fits their student needs.
There are several tools that can help districts conduct this deeper analysis of the programs.
One of them specifically was developed by the Science Curriculum Instruction and Steering Committee called the California NGSS Time.
You'll be able to find this tool and receive training through the California County Superintendent's Educational Services Association website and that will be in the near future.
So on this slide, we have provided the CDE recommendation based on the Instructional Quality Commission's recommendation.
As Chair Reese stated, we appreciate your support throughout this process and would be happy to answer any questions that you might have after the adoption process and the commission recommendation.
Yeah, I think the appropriate process now is to proceed to the public hearing.
And so I think we'll hold questions and all of that.
So the public hearing on this one will be held in two phases.
The first is for the publishers to
come before the public hearing and they are limited to two minutes of content.
And after the publishers, we can hear from individual speakers who can speak for one minute each.
So I now declare the public hearing open and we will first hear from the publishers.
We have one publisher signed up, Dr. Kenneth Wesson.
As President Kirst, board members, and Superintendent Torlakson, I'm Ken Wesson, one of the National Science Consultants for SSI and the FOSS Science Program.
And while we appreciate the concern for animals, and I grew up around animals, and so high respect for animals, there's first an official response from the publisher in your online, it should be in your packet as well,
But there's also a copy of the investigation.
And the investigation is called Introducing Milkweed Bugs.
And it says in the teacher's manual, milkweed bugs are alive.
treat them with care and respect at all times.
Later, students make observations.
Oh, sorry.
Let me start all over.
Respect the animals at all times.
The animals are, and it's just insects.
It's milkweed bugs.
They're never dissected, they're never harmed, never bent, folded, or mutilated.
Teachers are asked to look for student behaviors and the student behaviors that treat the milkweed bugs and petri dishes with care and avoid harming the organisms at all times.
And anyone with just a modest degree of experience working with animals in the real world knows that many animals meet an early demise in the real world.
These organisms are milkweed bugs.
Students create a habitat for them.
They have a habitat where they're protected.
They even reproduce.
They go through the life cycle.
So students see milkweed bugs
in probably the most protected conditions possible.
In educational research, we have something called in silico, which means not of the real world.
Kids, particularly kids.
You can close your statement, yeah.
Kids who are not great readers need opportunities to learn through hands-on experiences, and particularly hands-on experiences that mimic the real world.
This is an access and equity issue in addition to an issue that truly reflects good education.
Thank you.
So now we're ready for individuals with one minute.
Will the following individuals please line up at the podium?
Angela Del Ramos, Samantha Souter, Jill Grace.
I'm Sheila Whitley here representing CTA.
CTA is pleased to see that 29 science curricular materials presented from the IQC to the State Board for Adoption.
It has been 12 years since the last adoption of science materials.
CTA commends the Curricular Review Committees and the IQC for their due diligence and hard work in reviewing the publishers submitted materials.
our members will finally see updated materials aligned to California NGSS standards.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, I'm Samantha Souter, college biology professor and senior science education specialist with PETA.
I'm here on behalf of PETA's 6.5 million members and supporters, including many who have already submitted written testimony to you, to respectfully urge the board to decline to adopt any science materials that include live animal experiments or animal dissection.
The act of cutting open an animal is a very archaic classroom activity.
It teaches children that living beings
are disposable and downplays the fact that they were once alive and often killed specifically for that exercise.
This is a very dangerous lesson, especially with the increase in incidents of cruelty to animals perpetrated by juveniles and also bullying.
Because there is no educational value in dissecting animals, all U.S.
medical schools have ended animal dissection.
period.
You don't have to do it to become a doctor.
So clearly there's no reason for our middle school and high school kids to be doing this.
Students there's absolutely no reason for them to be dissecting animals.
Thank you.
We hope the board chooses to support humane science education.
Good afternoon, President Kirsch, Superintendent Torrelson, and members of the board.
I'm Jill Grace, the president of the California Science Teachers Association.
And I'd first like to start by thanking our amazing CDE staff, members of the IQC, as well as all of the reviewers for their hard work in this process.
We're proud to have supported this process from the very beginning, from having board members serve on the state's implementation committee to having framework writers and reviewers, including having three board members and many of our members serve on the committee to review these materials.
With this adoption list, there's now a lot of choice.
So at this stage, I'd like to echo Dr. Gregson's point that it's really important to shift the focus now to local context and prioritize what's in the best interest of kids in your community, as well as thinking about what's needed to support teachers in implementing the NGSS.
We'd like to remind you in the field of our jointly produced white paper, Priority Features of NGSS-Aligned Instructional Materials, as an important and useful frame.
And it's available on our CSTA website at cascience.org.
We also would like to draw attention one more time to the unprecedented effort of the state to actually have a process in place for professional learning and to review these materials.
Thank you.
OK, I now declare the public hearing closed and I think we'll have some opening comments from our liaison board member Strauss.
Well, first, let me just say to everybody who participated in this very thorough materials review process, led and facilitated by the Department of Education, to Stephanie and your team, it's an amazing undertaking.
To Dean for your work, I know you're concluding four years on IQC and you've made such a significant contribution now as chair, but with your work on all the framework and all the science.
You have to know, when Stephanie says people put in tons of hours, they get this big pallet of, they go for the training for a week.
They volunteer.
A week.
Learning all the standards.
Then they get all of it delivered.
We know, member Rucker and I know, they tell people, get it delivered to your office, because in your house, you don't have room for all this stuff.
They spend time going through everything, and then they come back for another week to agree.
a really clear, thorough, aligned process.
And it's gotten better as we've refined it, I would say.
And then every comment is addressed.
So I just would say I have such confidence, first of all, in the quality of the reviewers we appointed, and in the process, and the thorough addressing of all the issues.
So just a compliment to the process.
I know we have another science item to follow this.
The California Science Teachers Association played a very important role in getting us really strong reviewers and participating all the way through as partners in the process.
So I just want to compliment the process and the Instructional Quality Commission.
People volunteer when they get appointed at IQC.
They don't realize they have to go through all the materials review.
So Dean, not only went through science, but I think you also went through history as well.
So you're on IQC, you have to facilitate the process.
So when we see IQC members here, you just have no idea the amount of time and work they've committed to our state process.
So just publicly and as a representative, and I know next week we'll have an outgoing dinner for the four members who've done their duty and service.
And but I don't think people realize that the extra commitment we get from everybody and I just say that it really brought member record.
I know because we've gone through a lot of the review processes.
So I just want to support the process and the inclusion of I think you said there were 20 different opportunities for public input in hearing and
Every item that's brought up has to be addressed.
And so everything you're hearing has been addressed in the process.
So I feel really comfortable supporting and making the recommendation.
And I actually will move approval of the CD recommendation.
But again, we'll have some other comments as well.
But just as a liaison to the process,
When I helped swear everybody in, I think they didn't know yet what was coming in the process.
The energy was great.
All the way through the process, people feel so good about their commitment to supporting the adoption.
We need these new materials very desperately to implement our standards and our framework.
Probably Member Rucker, as my colleague in IQC, would probably have some other comments too.
Sure.
I was at the IQC meeting on the day when the programs themselves were individually reviewed and the adoption recommendation from each of the panels were considered.
So not only did we hear about the programs that were being recommended,
But there was a great deal of in-depth conversation concerning the five programs that did not receive a favorable recommendation.
The committee members took the process very seriously.
They took the appeal and review considerations very, very seriously to the point of going back through and looking at some of the material, looking at and having a discussion on what the criteria particularly
for standard one actually meant to make sure that there was a clear consensus on what was being evaluated, what evidence statements were provided by the panels that did the review and to make sure that there was clear agreement that what the panels reported was accurate as it relates to the standards and what the entire IQC panel understood about the programs and the recommendations they knew and understood
what they were recommending and what they were choosing to vote on for the programs that were not well recommended.
I actually also took time to record the votes.
So I can say I watched it, I participated in it, I reviewed it.
And unlike some of my other colleagues, I also ordered the programs and looked through them as well.
It wasn't just since I ordered all the programs,
It wasn't just a single pallet that arrived at my office and my manager looked at me and said, you know, that's a whole conference room you're now taking up.
So it is well worth the process.
It is well worth the work.
If there was some way to offer something more than a commendation, but the absolute thanks of the workforce and what was done with this science adoption, I think it's important and significant to take the time to do that because this is a historic decision we're about to make.
All right.
Other board member comments?
Board member Sun.
I guess I have a question for my fellow board members who were involved in this adoption.
Board member Rucker mentioned that when the adoption for math or when the math framework first came about, that there were some uncertainties about the instructional approach.
And so what we've seen in my site as we are working to adopt the new science standards is that there is a lot of requirement on a part of our students, their literacy as well as their math skills.
It's really that combination to be successful with the NGSS.
So in looking at the framework and then matching that to some of these materials,
What were some lessons learned, I guess, from the past adoptions that you're kind of moving forward so that the approach, instructional approaches, while not being prescriptive, do help provide and support teachers in both of those literacy and math skills in combination with content, with the science content?
It's very complex.
Well, at the risk of saying something very controversial, let me say that probably what was because I've been through all of the adoptions.
I start starting with the mass adoption.
There was an assumption because the mass adoption was the first adoption that it would be that we would be modeling not only our processes about doing the reviewing and the vetting and the use of our criteria,
But there was some kind of assumption that the math adoption as an adoption was going to be the prescription for instruction.
And that was never the intent of the adoption.
That was not the way the framework was created.
And that was not the purpose of the mathematical practices in looking at the instructional shifts.
The difference that and what we learned from that adoption is that not only do people need greater support in professional development and professional learning for those who will learn to use the curriculum, but there have to be better processes in what and what guidance we give to the publishers about what we're looking for in writing curriculum.
Because even though we had a new approach to curriculum, what we didn't have was a new approach to curriculum development.
And so we had two different paradigms going on with the math adoption that absolutely changed with the science adoption.
So that we move more from the 20th century thinking about writing curriculum to the more 21st century idea about focusing on important curriculum practices.
And that's what we see in what was done with this adoption.
So there's close attention to not just what the standards are and the criteria and the framework,
but what the NGSS principles for instruction actually means and what it means to write curriculum to address those instructional principles.
That's what did not happen with the math adoption.
We learned a lot as a result.
So again, I know I said that at the risk of making a controversial statement, but I think the difference between the science adoption, which is our latest adoption,
and the math adoption, which is our first, is there was a clear expectation communicated to the publishers that they need to pay attention, not just to writing curriculum, but developing curriculum that helps teachers to use and understand the instructional shifts.
Board Member Strauss.
I want to follow up on and continue to elaborate on the discussion.
So I think that's the reason why after this item we follow with an item on science that Action Member Williams and I helped put together.
Because just adopting materials is just almost the beginning.
Because really, there's so much work to do to help understand all the shifts, as Dean was saying, Chair Reese, about the shifts in NGSS and what it means for implementation.
So we've actually crafted the next item to try to look at people who were the early implementers, people who are working on adoption, what the Science Teacher Association are finding, to try to give some guidance documents.
And we actually have some things that WestEd's been doing in evaluating.
That will help and say now districts as you're managing all these implementations.
What are things you need to do for administrators?
What do you need to do for teachers?
so I think we need to we as you look at the timeline from when the standards were adopted and and when we
when the framework and now the materials, the rollout and implementation, we have a lot ahead of us.
And so that'll kind of bridge into our next item and then maybe summarize some clear findings about what to do about the materials and the smartest way we can do professional development and support to get it really to happen in the classrooms.
And I think that is the mind shift that it's, by purchasing curriculum, purchasing textbooks, it doesn't mean that's the end of curriculum, right?
Because you purchase this because it's going to help scaffold the development of curriculum.
It isn't the curriculum.
So that's the change, and I think in looking at what we've been trying to do with professional development is making that bridge between those materials and actually teaching and touching kids.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
Well, I'm not that acquainted with this process, but I know that it's a lot of work because I read your instructional quality report with edits and notes on all of the textbooks, and it just seems so massive.
But one of the things that really caught my eye from a social science perspective in looking at this is that we were so, or you,
we're so diligent about looking at representation.
What are the pictures that we're showing our students, right?
How are we describing people?
I know here there was a strikeout for misrepresentation of girls, lack of diversity in some of these books.
And I think for students, when we think of STEM or the sciences, and we think of the underrepresentation of women, I have to check into my flight.
When we think of the underrepresentation of women and people of color and to think about if our students are going through these books, we want to make sure that there is positive affirmations of who they are and that that is captured in our textbooks.
You know, I thought about the meme of a bear hugging California.
And I was like, oh, I love being Californian because I know that this is probably not happening to this level of detail with this critical eye.
So I just want to thank you for this work.
To the IQC, Stephanie, you, your staff, this makes me proud to be a Californian, honestly.
Okay.
Do we have any further comments or recommendation now?
Yeah, before public comment, do you want to make any comment?
No.
Okay.
So we'll have the public comment.
Yeah, you said public comment.
We had a public hearing.
Nobody else?
Okay.
Yes, you may.
I move the CDE recommendation that we adopt the 29 instructional programs recommended by QC and direct CDE staff as follows to work with the publishers to make sure that all the edits and corrections that have been adopted are revised in the new materials.
Okay.
Moved and seconded.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Thank you.
Unanimously it's done.
Yeah.
Okay, we could take a brief break till 3... till 3.20.
Okay, the State Board will reconvene and we're now...
On to item seven, which is an improvement information item.
And it is a review and update of implementation of the next generation science standards.
And Barbara Murchison will present and we're ready for you to present.
Good afternoon, President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, board members, my name, you can't hear me?
It is on.
I'm just being shy.
I'll try again.
Oh, come on.
Good afternoon, President Kirst.
Superintendent Torlakson, board members, my name is Barbara Murchison.
I'm director of Educator Excellence and Equity Division here at the department, and very happy to be bringing to you today an update on the implementation of California's Next Generation Science Standards, or NGSS, as you will probably hear them referred to many times.
This, as President Kruse said, is an information item.
No action is required.
So as you recall, the state board adopted the California NGSS back in September of 2013 and adopted the middle school integrated learning progression model in November of 2013 at the next meeting.
About a year later, the NGSS systems implementation plan was adopted.
And in the item and in the plan, you'll note that there are some key state-level activities.
They're up on the screen as well.
And with your having adopted and taking action on instructional materials to support implementation of NGSS, we are moving pretty close to the end of the state-level activities.
Next spring we will be administering the cast operational test and the field test for the alternative assessment for science and after that we'll have some assessment data.
For the very first time, so in May 2016 you all adopted a design to
Get that science assessment data onto the dashboard and CDE staff will begin that work consistent with the timeline in the August 2018 information memorandum about how the dashboard will be updated.
So all of the other implementation plans that have been adopted, the Common Core Implementation Plan, the ELD Implementation Plan, rest on these seven guiding strategies that talk about professional learning and curriculum.
and career in college and tying in, and there are seven strategies for implementing standards.
This plan is a little bit different in that it has an eighth strategy, which is about building coalitions to ensure a consistent message and to sustain momentum during implementation of these standards.
And what you'll hear today, I have five key California science leaders with me, and they'll be doing most of this presentation today.
What you'll hear today is evidence of how Strategy 8 has really come into play to support implementation across the state.
Prior to the adoption of CANGSS, we've always had lots of activities going on to support districts and schools to learn standards.
The state board does its thing, the department does its thing, obviously the county offices play a key role, the California Science Teachers Association, the K-12 Alliance, they have all done a lot of work historically to help districts
implement standards, the science standards.
But with this implementation plan, there has been kind of this systematic collaboration and coalition building to really move this implementation forward.
So three of those efforts are listed on this slide and described a little bit in the item.
There is the Early Implementation Initiative that has been running from 2014 through 2018 with support from the S.D.
Bechtel Jr.
Foundation.
And my understanding is they've just received some additional funding to continue this work.
You'll be hearing about that.
We also have the Statewide Science Collaboration Committee and Communities of Practice, where we have a statewide group of science leaders working to design professional learning for folks who come from each of the 11 CESA regions and do kind of statewide communities of practice and regional communities of practice.
And then they take that learning back to their regions and continue to spread the information about implementation of science.
And then we have the California NGSS Collaborative, where we really have representation from all of the folks who are deeply invested in supporting implementation of science, coming together regularly and doing these series of rollouts.
We've already heard a little bit about the time rollout, that's rollout five, where they're gonna be helping folks to
Decide upon the best instructional materials for each district's local context and get some really solid training around that and then next year rollout six will be about Environmental literacy and how to weave that and tie that together with science But the fact that I'm saying rollout six indicates that this group of leaders has been coming together to support science implementation For five years now next year will be the sixth year
So what I really want to do today is have you here.
We've already talked about how, as the state is sort of coming towards the end of its timeline for implementing these state-level activities, we're really thinking about how do we support local folks to pick up this ball and keep running with it.
And today I have with me five science leaders from across the state who will share some information and hopefully a little bit of inspiration
to help folks who are wondering, who are maybe just starting out on their NGSS implementation journey, get some ideas and some information, hear about some of the challenges and some of the successes, and maybe give a little advice to those LEAs who may just be starting out.
So with me today, I have Jill Grace, who's the president of the California Science Teachers Association.
Sushila Nath, who works at Aspire Public Schools in Stockton and is one of the early implementers.
Deborah Schneider, Director of Instructional Media Services and Curriculum at Tracy Unified School District.
Marion Murphy-Shaw, our Educational Services Director at Siskiyou County Office of Education.
And Ramona Chang, Director of Curriculum Instruction at Torrance Unified School District.
So each of them has a little bit of a different story to share.
And I'm really looking forward to hearing so if you find I Hope they haven't left here.
They come please come on up
Hello again.
So President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board, I am Jill Grace, president of the California Science Teachers Association.
I'm also regional director with the K-12 Alliance at WestEd, who manages their early implementation initiative.
And I'm really excited to be with this team here today to present this to you to help paint a picture of what it can look like when you move forward with NGSS implementation.
And I personally stepped out of the classroom a little more than three years ago to work with these early adopter teachers as well as our statewide partners to really, as Barbara mentioned, build a thoughtful community to help us move forward and figure out what this looks like in classrooms.
And I'm going to tell you it's a big lift.
It's a big lift for districts.
It's a big lift for teachers.
It's a lot to ask of students initially as they transition.
But the payoffs are huge.
And I can attest this.
Watching the vision of NGSS play out in classroom instruction is, in my personal opinion, nothing short of beautiful.
And it reminds me of why I love science.
It reminds me of why I think being a science educator is the best job in the world.
And it reminds me of why it's so important that all students have access to a high quality science instruction.
So it's been a wonderful journey so far, and the journey is still going.
So when we were asked to do this presentation, I didn't want to just provide anecdotal information.
CSTA is very fortunate to have a wonderful collaboration with teachers that have stepped up into leadership positions in their district across the state as coaches and TOSAs.
And within 24 hours, 37 of them actually responded to a survey that I posted to share with you today.
And I wanted to show you where they're reporting they are in implementation.
And you'll notice that there is wide variance.
And there's a lot of reasons for that variance.
But what we also wanted to capture is once you get started, what are those lessons you're learning?
What are the successes?
What have the challenges been?
And what's the big takeaway?
that we can share with other people across the state.
So once you start moving, what does it look like?
So I have some trends that emerged from the survey from them.
And in terms of successes, they noted that they saw a significant investment within their districts to be successful.
They had to invest in teacher leadership and have those teachers help lead others and guide them along the way.
In addition, for the first time ever in many districts, science was actually on the agenda item for professional learning.
And in many cases that hadn't happened in districts prior to this.
They identify some really important challenges that are going to be echoed again by the other presenters tonight, and that is that it takes
probably more time than we think to actually implement NGSS.
And so be flexible with that.
Realize it's an investment of time.
You take one step, then you take another.
The pedagogical shifts are big.
So in order to support that, you need to have structures in place.
You need funding in place to support that high-quality professional learning over time, as well as the materials that are needed.
Because
you do stuff in science, right?
Another interesting challenge that is consistently emerging is that in many cases districts have such an emphasis on language arts and math, they often feel there's not space for science.
And that's been difficult for them to navigate and figure out how to move forward.
I asked them, what's your number one lesson learned?
And the trend is that you got to have a plan.
It needs to be big and comprehensive.
We're going to hear it needs to be flexible because plans need to change.
How do you really think about ongoing sustained support?
I'm going to pause for a moment to reflect on the last item.
I know that member Rucker and Strauss had mentioned questions about how we're moving forward with reviewing instructional materials.
So, we are celebrating today that we're moving forward in that process, but I'm going to dare suggest that you will find no perfect instructional materials out there.
And it's not about just the instructional materials, it's about investing in the teachers and how they're utilizing that in their classrooms.
And so we are really proud as a state, as our collaborative, we mentioned the NGSS collaborative, to do something that's never been done before.
and sort of shift the trend that we've had in the past for reviewing instructional materials and have a completely different process.
So that's the Toolkit for Instructional Material Analysis, the CANGSS time process that Dr. Gregson mentioned earlier, where we're now looking at that review as professional learning for teachers.
So we dig into the materials, but what are our expectations of it?
What are the strengths and limitations?
What do we need to bring this up to par for our students?
So I wanted to make sure that I stress that we are training our county office leads and partners in December on that process and then bringing that out to local regions in January.
So more on that to come.
So other lessons I can share with you come from the Early Implementation Initiative.
So this is the project with our eight districts and two charters.
And I'll add that in addition to funding from Bechtel that the Hastings Quillen Fund actually supported our two charters in the organization.
And we've had some really cool findings from these, I'm going to call them pioneers, that set out ahead of everybody else.
We're figuring it out together.
The whole premise behind this is this idea of theory of change, that this is a big lift we're asking of teachers and of our districts and our students.
How do we do this in a way that's going to be successful and meaningful and sustained?
And so really framing everything through this idea of theory of change where we need to change policies and practices to be able to do this.
We need to build administrator leadership because we can't do this without our administrator support.
We need to build teacher leadership.
They support each other and help each other out.
How do we shift and change teacher practice?
How do we provide increased opportunities for student learning?
And most importantly, I think the thing for me that's been so profound is building a community of leaders within local context, but also so we can share those best practices statewide.
And I think many of you know we've gotten national attention for this work.
So in that mind, we have some really exciting results.
You've all been given a copy of our WestEd evaluation reports and a report on some tools and practices that we have.
These are also available on the K-12 Alliance website for people that are listening in tonight.
And we have some really exciting findings.
And the number one finding is kids like learning science.
So when we put kids in a position where they are the scientists in the classroom, where they are making sense of their world and trying to solve problems and understand phenomena, that this completely transforms our education.
And in doing so, those habits of mind that they build actually help them learn all subjects.
So we have anecdotal evidence that that enthusiasm is trickling over into other subject areas.
When kids are in our science class, they don't realize they're being immersed in rich data.
When they're in our science class, I call it ninja writing.
They just are writing profusely, right, and don't realize that it's happening.
So it supports all of these other things.
We also know that it helps teachers improve all instruction.
So especially with our elementary colleagues, the pedagogical shifts they're learning have been trickling over into other subject areas.
We know that this is doable.
No matter your level of experience, you can take a first step.
And if we build that community, we can help you move forward.
So everybody can do this.
And we know that this requires sustained professional learning for teachers as well as administrators.
I'm going to show you a teaser.
This isn't public yet.
So our WestEd evaluators are working on a report right now on student engagement.
It's coming out in the next month or two.
And we were able to survey 293 teachers in the initiative and 65 administrators.
And the question was, what are you noticing in terms of quality science instruction in classrooms?
And you can see that across the board, they're reporting significant gains.
So it's not just the enthusiasm, the excitement.
but the quality of the learning is dramatically increasing.
I wanted to pause here on this quote from a middle school principal.
It was a totally different science class than I'd ever seen.
The kids were talking about particle size, particle structure, friction.
It was like little soil scientists in there talking about why a mudslide happens.
And I went, wow, this is really something.
Just the way they talked to each other, and the way they listened to each other, and the way they questioned each other, it was like a college class.
So with that, we get to dig a little bit deep.
And I'm going to go ahead and pass off to Susheela Nath from Aspire so we can get a lens of what this looks like in an individual charter.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, and members of the State Board of Education.
My name is Sushila Nath, and I am the Science Director for Aspire Public Schools and Early Implementer Project Director.
We believe in the core values of equity, quality, and innovation as we serve 16,600 kids across California.
Aspire currently operates 40 schools across three California regions, the Bay Area, Central Valley, LA.
As one of two charters chosen to be a part of the Early Implementers Initiative, the funding granted to us through the Hastings Quillen Foundation
opened doors of opportunity to our admin and educators for continuous professional development, teacher support, classroom support, coaching, curriculum writing, which has all transformed our teacher practice to provide our students with high quality science education.
When we first started this initiative, we only started with six schools.
As the peak of science grew among our 40 schools, we now in year five have 25 of the 40 schools as early implementers.
We know that implementing NGSS is a total paradigm shift for teachers, where learning student-centered, phenomena-based, and three-dimensional learning was the ultimate goal.
As we think of the theories of change, one of the most impactful changes was to change teacher practice.
As you walk through our Aspire schools and our science classrooms, you will see more of student to student discourse, less teacher talk, cohesive storylines, less individual learning, more teachers using what they are learning in science to all content areas rather than being in silos,
more about the practice of science and less about reading and regurgitating facts.
Here's what the teachers are saying.
It's not spoon feeding the answers the way it used to be.
Science used to be a finite amount of information and old school teachers were the ones who disseminated all knowledge.
Now I'm not the keeper of information anymore.
I'm the guide for how you process information.
I'm the one who poses the question about what you can think about and the students become the drivers of their learning.
Another teacher states, the early implementer NGSS initiative has helped me implement high quality instruction that is driven by phenomena and integrates common core standards.
My students have never been so eager to learn science, ask questions, and discuss core ideas.
The SEPs, DCIs, and CCCs are preparing students for STEM careers, college, and the 21st century.
Well, our teachers can go on and on about their classrooms, but the best part is the authentic learning happening amongst our students today.
Here's what the students are saying.
My favorite part of science is the investigation.
I learn best when I do science and try and figure out things.
This new way of science allows for us to understand the science and how it applies to real world problems.
Another student states, this is the first time I have had a love for science.
Our teacher opens up the classroom for us to investigate like scientists and problem solve like engineers.
We're not reading out of textbooks and just filling out packets.
We are actually doing science.
When we talk about the theory of change in perspective to changing student outcomes, we are seeing increasing opportunities for students to learn.
We are seeing minutes for science increase.
We are seeing opportunities for families to engage in science through family science and engineering nights.
We are also having dinner with scientists.
And students are getting bigger ideas and writing about them.
When you consider the system of the heart,
or when you consider the system, the heart of the system is the heart of student learning.
Our challenge was that there was no state testing at the time to measure student learning, so we had to look at other measurements of outcomes.
At Aspire, we really wanted to strengthen environmental literacy and engineering.
One of our learnings was that we needed partnerships.
In our case, that meant following the model in the initiative to reach out to institutions of higher education and informals to form partnerships and gain content expertise.
The biggest learning is everyone needs a thought partner and that we cannot do this by ourselves.
So, I will leave you with this message today.
Although implementation is never smooth, we must embrace the challenges, and we must keep the main thing, the main thing, where keeping the focus on the kids is the key to success.
Thank you, and now I will pass it on to my colleague, Deborah Schneider.
Thank you.
Good afternoon to President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, and members of the board.
My name is Deborah Schneider, and in addition to the title that you saw earlier, I'm the Director of Pre-K-12 Science for Tracy Schools, and including the Project Director of our Early Implementation Grant.
And I really appreciate being invited here today to talk about our implementation journey and the lessons that we've learned.
And I think in my head of the audience here today, being all the LEAs who could hear about this later and could get some messages from us, and that's why I'm thinking about lessons learned.
My first lesson is that vision matters.
Earlier you heard how important it is to have a plan, but in addition to that, this is really difficult work, and the shifts are really hard to manage, and the plans are going to change when all these complex issues come up.
So then what's going to guide you?
Your mission.
In about year two, we were able to settle on a mission.
And this is a poster that literally hangs on a window in my office behind the head of anyone who comes to talk to me about science.
That the purpose of this work is to implement student-centered, phenomena-focused, inquiry-based science for every student in TUSD.
And that is what I talk about.
And when you bring me any plan, if it fits that, we got something to talk about.
And if it doesn't, I'm going to help you change your plan.
But we also needed to build community and share practices with professional learning partnerships.
We were lucky to get the work with the K-12 Alliance and the grant.
They brought to us lesson study, and that impact it had on our students' learning and our teachers' teaching was phenomenal.
We really saw an impact.
And because of that, other content areas within the district are adopting our model of lesson study, the one that we learned from the K-12 Alliance.
We took deep dives with K-12 Alliance into pedagogy and into content, and other district initiatives, other content areas are doing the same.
Another thing about K-12 Alliance is that they have high expectations for all the work we do.
And then they provide high support to make it happen.
And so again, we're looking at high expectations, but with high support for quality teaching.
We also work with the County Office of Ed in San Joaquin County, particularly with our 6-8 and 9-12 teams.
For 6-8, we wanted them to get extra support for the middle school transition, because going to the preferred integrated model was a big shift for them.
And we were able to give them support to build a scope and sequence model for 6th, 7th, and 8th grade.
And they lead quarterly meetings in which pedagogy and content information is taught to all teachers at those grade levels.
We've also done intensive work with 912.
They recommended the three-course model to our cabinet and board after months of deep investigation.
They rewrote all the high school science courses to include all standards for all students.
And all of those courses have now been approved by the UCOP for the A through G requirements.
and they've been implemented this year.
The 9-12 committee and the county's work with us also helped update our graduation policy, so now it includes the specific courses graduates must have, which is physical, chem, and bio, each with earth science integrated.
Earlier, Jill mentioned that it's so important to build administrator leadership, and we found that this is a challenge for Tracy.
We need to provide multiple points of entry, because all administrators are not the same, and all sites do not have the same needs.
In our early work with the K-12 Alliance and the county office, we found that much of the teacher development work was focused, but not administrative development.
It wasn't the same thing.
And administrators need different development than teachers.
There are new state models being developed by the county offices and by K-12 Alliance for administrator development, and we're happy to start using those more to really hone our work.
In fact, I worked with my staff this morning, the management staff, with one of my K-12 Alliance regional directors.
In addition, differentiation is really key for the individual administrator.
Do they have the knowledge they need?
Do they need one-on-one meetings with me or one of my other leaders?
What does their site need?
What is the culture there?
How big of a group is best for their learning?
All of these have to be answered so they can get the best development and then support what's going to happen at their site.
We also need teacher leadership, which we had in spades from the K-12 Alliance work and with the county.
But then we had to scale up to get to every site and to every teacher.
We had to push to site-based leadership, that is, put the teams out at the sites.
That increased the legitimacy of their work because people at your site trust you, not the person who's coming from the district office.
But we also had to provide support at the district level so that we knew there was quality control going out to those sites.
So we have kind of a back and forth going right now.
And this is our first year trying that.
And so far, our evaluations show that it's going well.
We'll have another evaluation at the end of the semester.
My last point, though, is that we must persist no matter what.
Once you start, don't stop, and just keep making another step forward toward whatever that vision is.
We were doing that, and our focus was so strong on equity that we were contacted by the Community Training and Assistance Center of Boston, who are also concerned about student equity in science and math.
and they asked us to propose with them a grant for U.S.
ed in the education, innovation, and research section, which we submitted in June and which was accepted and rewarded October 1st.
So Tracy now has a $4 million, five-year grant from EIR based on our foundation that we already had from the county and K-12 Alliance and all the work we'd been doing, and because of our focus on equity.
So our journey continues, and maybe I'll come back and tell you about it another time.
So our next speaker is Marion Murphy Shaw from the Siskiyou County Office of Ed.
President Kirst.
Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board, thank you for having me here.
My name is Marian Murphy-Shaw.
I'm from the Siskiyou County Office of Education, and I also represent Region 2 on the Sisk Science Subcommittee.
I'm here today to report about one region's work with the Statewide Science Collaboration Committee and Science Community of Practice that you, CDE, and CSESA have all supported.
These structures have helped to develop statewide systems of support for NGSS implementation.
They are aimed at meeting the needs of California's districts, schools, and classrooms by supporting the leaders, the administrators, and the teachers through collaborative work.
I was selected to speak on behalf of the group because we know how important it is to all of you that we are serving California's rural schools, districts, and teachers.
The image shown on this slide illustrates the size of Region 2.
It's about 1 4th of the state land area in our northeast corner.
And pretty dispersed when you look at the numbers fitting in that land area.
The issue of equitable access to quality professional learning for our teachers, our coaches, principals, district and county leaders who support them in this geographically large region has been an ongoing challenge for a long time.
Participating in the statewide system of support for NGSS implementation since its inception in 2015 has provided Region 2 with capacity building access to innovations and best practices in science education.
It has expanded a regional leadership team comprised of teacher leaders, district administrators, county staff, higher education faculty, researchers, and informal partners to develop a nine counties wide community of practice with one vision.
shared learning for the leaders who support the teachers.
While we have seen the implementation of the California NGSS develop in our region, we also know we still have a lot of work to do, as illustrated by the data that Jill shared.
Our schools need the ongoing support of professional learning providers who have had the time to engage in learning themselves.
That is what will help keep quality science implementation progressing.
There are also other pockets of rural or very small schools all over California.
Our hope is that the work we've done can serve as a source of ideas about how to make professional learning equitable for the teachers serving students in the most remote parts of California.
In Region 2, we replicated the model of the State Collaborative Committee and Community of Practice with its diverse partner composition, shown in the image, because we found it such an effective process for not just holding meetings and not just hearing presenters, but for the professional learning leaders to learn together and then build the resources that focused on the local teachers' needs and were implemented with local support.
with many of us serving in the role as the sole science and math lead in our counties.
It made sense for us to design a project for both science and mathematics.
We felt strongly that equity for student access to high quality instruction was an area of need in our region that spanned both disciplines.
We wanted to collaborate to develop innovative ways to address that need.
And we agreed that greater equity of access could be achieved by helping teachers of both disciplines develop every student's ability to express their thinking as it developed into their own understanding through a focus on productive student discourse.
The model you see here is what allowed us to orchestrate a real-time, day-long, region-wide video professional learning event.
It was just this past September.
We had colleagues located at geographically distant county offices, but we worked as a collaborative presentation team facilitating both in person and through video.
The work and the endeavor to leverage our regional community of practice to deliver this nine county video event felt as the best way to examine how to provide our students, and we're serving teachers TK-12 during this event.
with access to high quality discourse about science and mathematics.
We realized that while we each had infrastructure for video meetings in our offices, that infrastructure was not being leveraged for high quality professional learning.
If we wanted nine counties to become a community practice about productive student discourse, we had a lot of work to do.
So we developed a learn together, plan together model as a regional collaboration committee to realize that vision.
The work with schools and teachers already underway in each of our counties was brought to the table.
It was used to inform what we would design.
We spent a lot of hours troubleshooting the content and the delivery through video in this way.
We brought together what we had learned at the state communities of practice.
We made use of the experts that we met there.
We were able to have the University of Washington School of Education, faculty in math from Shasta College and CSU Chico, and the staff at the Exploratorium's Institute of Inquiry work with us to narrow our focus on what we could do in one day to establish a community conversation about increasing productive student discourse in Region 2's TK-12 classrooms.
To address working across distances and some of the tech-specific challenges we faced, we sat down as a project team and developed what we fondly call our Zoom carts.
They're based upon the very small and often flexible spaces within our offices that we use for professional learning.
If I can say that this many times without messing it up, it'll be a miracle.
Professional learning.
The portable units address the need of high quality sound so that as we were listening to video presentations It wasn't garbled we could have conversations the carts were meant to be flexibly configured portable and Because we all had the same hardware We were able to troubleshoot anything that went wrong without needing to task are already very busy IT folks who are serving our schools as well as our offices
The participant feedback from our event in September was overwhelmingly positive.
We exceeded our hopes for making video professional learning engaging.
We developed a groundbreaking system of regional support for delivery of improved standards implementation.
The meeting innovatively leveraged relatively common technology, but leveraged it to ensure that each county had access and could participate in real-time learning together.
effort united TK-12 educators across levels, content areas, roles in their districts to learn together about instructional uses of strategies for student discourse to improve regional learning outcomes.
I got to tell you, it was a blast to watch.
We had teachers dropping parachutes in real time in front of the Exploratorium.
They were running up to the video cameras with their illustrations of their mathematical thinking, as we would ask of students, and showing those to the faculty at University of Washington and Chico State, and most importantly, to each other across this huge region.
They were all less than a 90-minute drive from their homes.
but they were talking to each other and sharing thinking.
We've already had several follow-up events using our model.
The Region 2 providers are able to collaborate.
I co-presented with MODOC and Butte and Siskiyou.
We had teachers from counties that were not those.
We were all able to interact.
and share our learning.
We've had requests for the use of our model by colleagues in our region and around the state, including our new GeoLEAD, the North State Q, Creek Networks, and even in our own internal offices.
As a matter of fact, the IT guys even want to use it to train schools on how to put on their secure browsers.
While we contributed to support this happening as counties working together, it's important to note we could not have risked developing and testing this model without the targeted funding and the support of the communities of practice work.
We were not required to have a cost recovery model to test our theory.
But the opportunity to challenge this norm of asking the teachers and the administrators to travel for hours to attend professional learning shifted the focus for them from worrying about being off the campus, from worrying about getting a sub, to being able to attend an equitable, high-quality professional learning event.
This is a significant change in how we can serve teachers, their administrators, and in turn, all of their students.
So we look forward to making use of our community of practice, the tools we put in place as we continue our California NGSS implementation.
which will require ongoing attention on our part, your continued support in the years to come.
Thank you.
I'm going to now ask you to shift your scale of perspective back to the local level with a district presentation from Ramona Chang and Torrance.
Good afternoon, President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, and members of the board.
Torrance didn't have the big grants or any of the grants that were out there, but we took a unique approach to NGSS implementation.
Some would think that perhaps it was a coincidental merge of opportunities.
Others might credit it to fortuitous timing.
However, we'd like to give credit to what it really was, a student-driven demand for inquiry-based learning.
As educators, we have known for a long time that student performance is directly linked to teacher performance.
In 2005, Torrance took the first step to broaden the use of best practices by sending a group of teachers to the Mickelson ExxonMobil Teachers Academy.
These are upper elementary teachers.
The academy immersed them in experiential lessons and when they returned that cohort met on a regular basis on their own supporting each other to sustain the concept of inquiry based science learning.
Our community demanded more and each year we sent more teachers eventually achieving district wide change.
So as our elementary students matriculated to the middle school they and their parents expected a similar inquiry based approach.
So in 2012 when the national document a framework for K-12 science education was released we began to prepare for both the pedagogical shift and the curriculum shift that were to come.
In 2013, our professional development days, our professional learning community times, sub-release time focused on science.
We asked that tough question of our middle school teachers.
Should middle school science keep a traditional subject-specific structure or adopt the integrated structure?
How can we better involve our parents, our community?
How can we better engage our students in STEM education?
By 2015 we had a board approved middle school model for science instruction.
To support this model we hired two teachers on special assignment our best science teachers to work with our site leads.
Modeling lessons and observing classroom teachers at both the elementary and middle school level.
It was important to sustain the work we had achieved at the elementary level while simultaneously rolling out the middle school program.
Additionally we started our NGSS rollout for fourth fifth and sixth grade then worked up through middle school to high school as we wanted to be sure we were optimizing the work for the new science test.
We reached out to our university partners CSTA NSTA and other colleagues to support teachers in increasing student engagement and in turn student proficiency in math and science.
In 2016 our high school science teachers were already familiar with the NGSS mission of all standards all students leading to their diligent work to integrate and align earth and space science into biology chemistry and physics sustaining their goal to optimize student engagement and inquiry.
By the time we began ramping up the implementation with the administration of CAST our teachers community families and students were all comfortably embracing the shift.
We do recognize though that we still have the challenge to sustain this focus on science beyond this initial implementation stage.
So did Torrance have a coincidental merge of opportunities.
Fortuitous timing.
Yes.
But it was more than that.
It was that student driven teacher supported systemic change in learning that transformed the teaching of science in our district in Torrance.
Thank you.
Well, that concludes our presentation.
But I have to say we've heard five different stories, five different folks, five different contexts.
But what I heard was student driven, collaborative and tenacious.
Right.
So I want to thank all five of them for being here.
And if you have questions for them or I don't know if you want to have a discussion amongst yourselves about what you want to open it up.
Board members Williams will start.
I do have a couple of questions, but I also want to say just a couple of things.
I've been involved with NGSS from the beginning, from 2011 when I heard Stephen Pruitt do a three-hour workshop explaining the pedagogical shifts and the whole structure of it.
And the science teachers, especially Jill and Susheela that I know from early implementers, know this story.
I don't have a science background, a formal science background, but my son Elliot was diagnosed with type 1 diabetes when he was 7 years old and I was devastated by it.
I thought probably all of his
potential in the future was, or half of it was going to be gone.
My own mother had died from type 1 diabetes just three years prior and he remembered it.
It was really pretty devastating, but we were very fortunate because the year he was diagnosed, there was a landmark study released by medical scientists, scientists
that proved that tight control of blood glucose, blood sugars, can delay or prevent almost all, what do you call them?
Consequences of diabetes.
And so we were very fortunate that that happened.
And my husband and I got on the job.
You know, we made sure we understood that study.
Got Elliot in the best camp in California.
And then we were fortunate because when he was 11, he was asked to be in the first study, a clinical trial, in the United States to see if pre-adolescents could handle an insulin pump.
Were they mature enough to be able to handle an insulin pump safely?
And so he did that.
And between the study and between the engineering, the computer engineering of the insulin pump, the whole biotechnology of all this,
it completely changed what was possible for him in life.
And that's why I've had such a passion around this, you know, a real passion around this.
And that son got married two weekends ago.
He is a medical doctor now at UCSD.
He's in his general surgery residency.
And he's among the first generation of surgeons, that first generation of type 1 diabetics to be welcome into surgery as a field.
and he will go on to get a fellowship when he finishes his school to be a trauma surgeon.
That kid that I thought wasn't going to have any potential is going to be a trauma surgeon and he's marrying a nurse practitioner in clinical oncology.
He just married her.
She's fabulous.
Anyway, that's the root of my passion.
That's what has driven me since 2011 is because I saw in NGSS the culmination, the bringing together of all the things that made such a difference for my son Elliot.
But there are a couple of other things about NGSS and one of them is the human impact.
And especially in the last couple of years, as I've seen science denied and human impact on environment denied, I think it's crucial that California be in the forefront of teaching our kids about human impact so that they're going to be the leaders, hopefully in time, to help be part of the solution to that.
Another reason for me that I've cared about this for so long is the equity issue.
It really is an issue in science, especially during the NCLB years when they started teaching more and more
lessons in math and English language arts in order to bring those grades up to meet and proficiency and dropped science out of the curriculum with the kids, the low-income kids that are the least likely to get science opportunities outside school.
And so it's a huge equity issue for me.
But who made this happen are the science leaders.
The science leaders like you guys here in California, you have embraced NGSS like I've never seen a discipline embraced by a group of people.
I mean, you are the most fun group of people that have your own passion around science and support each other and work so hard and we're so excited to have NGSS replace the old science standards.
which Kathy Dorana used to refer to as the dark ages in California.
And your enthusiasm just helped spur mine on during this entire time to never let go of this subject.
So I'm going to say just a couple things about the early implementers because I was very involved in getting that started.
And I hope Eileen will talk about communities of practice because that's not something I've been involved in.
But it was so wonderful to be able to work with Kathy Dorana
and Phil LaFontaine at CDE to kind of put together an idea about an early implementation initiative.
And it's just sheer luck that my previous role before the board, I was executive director of EdSource, and I knew a couple of funders that funded us at EdSource, and I thought they might be interested in this initiative, and they in fact were.
And so it to be able to be a part of that and work with all of you guys to to put that initiative together.
I just helped with the start of it.
And then Kathy and K-12 Alliance and the rest of you took it from there.
But so I really think the S let me think right now in case they're watching.
The S.D.
Bechtel Jr.
Foundation is so grateful for their support of this initiative.
So they supported it for four years and now they've agreed to support it for two more years.
And I also want to thank the Hastings Quillen Fund too for allowing two charter management organizations to participate along with the eight districts.
So when I leave the board after January, I just want you to know that I consider NGSS to be one of the most impactful
roles I've had on the board, but more important than that, one of the most rewarding roles I've had on the board.
It has been all gain, no pain.
And I want to thank all of you for what you're doing and what you're doing for California's students.
I want to have Eileen go ahead and say a few words.
I have some questions about those of you that are implementing the 6th to 8th grade integrated model and how
how you're doing that and how well you think it's going and how promising you think it is for other districts to perhaps pick it up.
But I'd like to hear from Eileen.
So I just want to share with the board and with the public who's here in the room and who's watching that this was a really significant presentation following the adoption of the materials.
Because if you look at the timeline of the 2013 adoption of NGSS, which everyone highlighted, it had been
Well, it's been more than 20 years almost, I think, since we have new standards and new materials.
It's time, and people know we know a lot more about science and things than we did maybe 20 years ago.
And the excitement and the energy that we're feeling from our presenters today is what you hear out in the field.
People are embracing this, but what we've heard is some key lessons, which is this is hard, this is complicated.
And so one of the things we were fortunate about is in having the early implementers,
was an extra component that we haven't had with some of the other adoptions that we've done.
And so they can help inform our rollout now that we're getting aligned materials.
And so I think there are some key pieces to this that I think statewide impact, you know, it's a giant state, 58 counties, more than 6.2 million kids.
How do you actually help with capacity?
In the northern part of the state, you have to go over a few counties to get to the science person.
L.A.
County is giant, but doesn't have as many as maybe Tulare.
So it's a challenge capacity-wise.
And so what the funding of the collaboration, so what we have is this collaboration committee in math and science, about 30, 35 people.
They plan three times a year this community practice, which brings about 100 people together, but they come in regional teams because their job is to go back to their region and do the rollout in capacity, knowing that Sacramento can't do all of that.
And even if you go to these great rollouts, which many of you spent a lot of time doing, it's just information at the beginning.
It's not the implementation process in it.
And so, it helps to inform our work, and I think the WestEd studies will be helpful, too.
And there's some key elements that we've heard.
Have a vision.
Be really clear.
It takes time.
It's complicated.
Think about teachers, but think about leaders.
Think about time.
And so, one of the things, and both Trish and I have talked at the early implementers administrative meetings, and
I was so impressed that as part of this program, they actually coached administrators on how to walk through classrooms and recognize effective science practices.
Because you might have been an elementary teacher, that's where I started, but I was a secondary principal for 20 years, so I might not have known deep science, I might have known what I knew when I taught elementary.
So how do I recognize and support science?
And so that model has actually helped to influence
how leaders are trained.
They have to know enough to give feedback.
They can't just expect the coach to do it.
So we had a lot of lessons here from both Torrance that didn't get the early implementers grant, the collaboration committee, the county work, the charter work at Aspire.
So one of the things that we're asking, we're going to ask for is CDE bring BRAC
an info memo that's like a guidance document that kind of pulls together some key things.
So basically districts now are going to have materials starting in early part of the year.
They're going to probably start looking at, oh gee, and hopefully they've spent enough time on the frameworks to actually be good consumers and recognize what might be a good match.
So I actually like the framework coming out before the materials because if you don't get to know the framework, you don't know, you might pick what you only know and not
things that need to be different.
So I think there's some way we could synthesize the key lessons for implementation.
Find time, work with administration, you guys have all the lessons.
But I think if it comes to an information memo that's like a guidance document, then it's posted in a way that says, here are things that we know about implementation, context matters, things that everyone's done as we've done implementation.
It's gonna take a long time to make this transition.
And as Tom Adams and I have done with the deans of the colleges of education, we've said, use our frameworks, they're free and you can use it as your textbook for teaching teachers in pre-service.
But it isn't just teachers in pre-service, it's those who are in the system for 20, 30 years and haven't learned some of this.
So those who came before us today helped highlight the lessons they're learning that we hope will help the implementation for people who aren't here today.
and who are nowhere near where our early implementers are.
And you know, even where the early implementers are, we got a lot of work ahead to do.
So I just personally want to thank you all for highlighting the key things you're learning for the daily energy that you have with your vision on the wall and the energy when people come to see you that we are doing science.
And for those of us who are now grandparents, not just parents, but grandparents want our kids to have this experience, it's from you that we'll do it.
So just first of all, thank you for that, but also asking CDE to try to pull together with this team some key lessons that we could say, here are some guidance as districts move forward with implementation for review of materials and implementation based on our lessons to try to help support that.
So I think there's probably a few more clarifying questions than the rest of my colleagues who also care about science.
Thanks.
Thank you so much for the presentation, all of you.
It's great for you to come here and show us what you've been doing.
I do have some thoughts for what they might be worth, if it'd be helpful at all.
Is it Marianne or Marianne?
Marianne.
I think I have a resource for you, if you could stick around for just a moment afterwards, all right?
Thanks.
We keep hearing over and over again how difficult this implementation is, what a heavy lift, how hard it is.
Being an old high school English teacher, I worry about words sometimes.
If you keep telling someone that the suitcase is super heavy, it is going to be really heavy.
And perhaps making some language shifts in a more positive way about how exciting this is, what huge change and shift can happen in a classroom.
how effective it is, and I have been in classrooms, been involved with classrooms who have implemented NGSS science units, and it is truly amazing.
And using those more positive words instead of repeating how hard it is, I think there's a
Fundamental shift.
You talked about, one of you talked about pioneers.
You know, a lot of people don't like pioneers.
You know, there were a lot of people that got pushed around by pioneers and liked things the way they were and don't necessarily want to see a pioneer, you know, come into their 40 acres or whatever.
So once again, language, as you work through implementation, I think is something to always consider and think about how you use it.
But just a couple of other thoughts.
One of you mentioned the Creek Network, which is, thanks to the superintendent and CDE, there's new, and the legislature, and the governor, get them all in there, right?
All right.
There's some new energy and money and funding and work being done in the Creek Network.
One really good example of what I've seen in the Creek Network recently, I'm sorry, I forget the region number, but it's Santa Cruz.
And they put together a list of non-formal science providers
aligned to each of the standards.
This particular non, for example, this particular non-formal provider will provide work in third grade standards or fourth grade standards in these ways, that sort of thing.
There are a lot of non-formal providers out there and the Creek Network is just one access point for them, but there are
eager to help.
They're very eager to help.
And a lot of them are doing a great job of it, very smart about it.
So I would really hope that in the statewide implementation plan that there be
sincere partnerships with non-formal providers, I think it can give a boost to bring these team members to the table and not just think we have to work among ourselves.
That sort of thing.
So that's one other suggestion.
And finally,
I also think it's super important to emphasize to all teachers how it's not just that students become more enthusiastic about learning other subjects because they were enthusiastic about science.
It's the fact that so many of the other standards through the other disciplines can be so easily and powerfully connected to work in NGSS and to
to truly help teachers understand that this is not more work, but this is more effective work.
That is, that's the paradigm shift, if you ask me.
And that is something that I also think needs to be built into the vision and the plan.
So anyway, blah, blah, blah.
Some suggestions.
I'll talk to you, Marianne.
Okay.
Board Member Cardenas.
Thank you so much for your presentation that has gotten me really excited because Oakland Unified is one of the people and I mean one of the districts involved and so I've seen the impact especially within my siblings so I really like how they've been very like enthusiastic about even though and I used to dislike science in elementary school because of how it was taught because there was no engagement that it was only about yeah, this is the periodic table like that's all it was and
But there was there was nothing else about it.
It was just this is a definition of science.
So the impact of how next generation science like the framework is going to work out like I'm very excited.
And just keep highlighting the positive because like what board member Holiday said is like the positive is going to engage more people.
It's going to get people excited.
You want to empower them.
You want to reel them in.
You know you want to sell it out to them.
So the positive keep showing that.
So I'm very excited.
I've seen how it's worked in Oakland.
So yeah I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Well, thank you.
Tremendous work, just powerful, exciting work.
Thank you, Trish and Eileen, for your extra diligence in interacting, working with staff and working with the teachers.
I became a science teacher, by the way.
Curious you mentioned the periodic table.
Because I was so bored in my chemistry class.
It was all about memorizing the rings and how many electrons spin.
It was just memorization.
It wasn't science.
And so I became a science teacher to try to change that a little bit.
So Bruce, I appreciated your comments and the discussion.
You mentioned, Trish, human impacts.
And Eileen, you mentioned getting some of the best practices together.
And so we'll definitely follow up.
And how do we disseminate some of the best programs in the state, how they're working, how can we help them get the resources they need to carry on?
I did have one question further in terms of could you share with us some of our teachers or Barbara, how
we're interacting, how are the science standards interacting with the environmental literacy goals?
And there's a natural connection, as Bruce was saying, so many of these things are connected.
So how are they interacting and how are they being incorporated, the environmental standards, into the NGSS rollout?
So one of the, can you hear me this time?
So one of the really exciting things that we've done and since the implementation of the science standards, since we adopted the science standards, the framework and the science standards document itself actually shows those linkages.
between the environmental principles and concepts and the science standards.
So we have made those connections explicit wherever we can.
And as I mentioned earlier, the NGSS collaborative is now building out some professional development experiences that are focused using some of the CREEC money that came through in the 2017 budget to really help people to understand how the science standards support the environmental literacy
Helping our students to become environmentally literate.
So those connections are explicit in the documents that the Department and the board are encouraging folks to engage with Thank you Or remember rocker
Well, I want to thank you, Barbara, for putting this panel together, not only because it was just very exciting to hear about the implementation, but the variety and diversity of the districts and programs that were represented actually told a much broader and better story about the implementation.
There are some key takeaways for me in what I heard that I really think is important to pay attention to as we go forward.
First of all, I want to associate myself with board member Holiday's concerns that we not talk about how hard this is for the reasons that we've already talked about.
It's not so much about merchandising as it is about marketing the responsibility of districts to do this well.
It's not because it's hard, but it's because it's their responsibility to make it better and to make and to simplify it or make it plain.
for their education personnel who are going to be doing this work.
What we've learned from previous adoptions is if the adoption itself didn't work or if the implementation of the standards didn't work, it's not because it fell on the teachers to simply implement this as an expert.
It requires a great deal of support.
It requires a great deal of time and planning.
It requires a great deal of professional development and professional learning.
Something that was not the focus or part of the planning in doing the implementing.
I want to remind you when we implemented the Common Core, that was done under one governor and one administration who simply implemented the, who simply adopted the Common Core for the purposes of qualifying for one-time federal funds.
And it was left to a following administration to actually do the work of implementing the Common Core, adopting new standards, adopting an assessment and adopting curriculum.
And as our friend Doug McRae would point out, with math, we did that in all the wrong order and in all the wrong way.
So, one of the first things I heard as a key takeaway from this panel was that the emphasis on early planning and the depth and detail and attention to planning was important along with the supports and incremental adjustments made to the plan was important.
But the other thing I did not hear in talking about that planning, I am quite certain everyone involved did not have the same level of success with implementing the plan.
What I also didn't hear was about the capacity for doing the implementation across an LEA.
I'm certain that there were some differences.
But also, what were the costs that were both unanticipated in purchasing and doing the support, purchasing the consulting and the support for the professional learning, but also the instructional classroom resources that had to be needed?
What was not considered?
in planning out and costing that out.
I'm not sure I heard that because that's also a key and important learning that we have to be aware of because for most adoptions, you buy a textbook, you're done.
Science is an adoption that requires ongoing support and regular replacement of materials to support the instructional program.
So I'm not hearing what that kind of capacity or considerations are.
And then even though we're hearing great programs and great models, which is a wonderful idea to hear about, I would like to hear from programs and from LEAs that are struggling and what their struggles are around.
Is it around understanding the standards?
Is it around understanding how to do the planning?
Is it around understanding or figuring out how to deploy and manage the resources that are necessary or that need to be marshaled
to help their teachers.
So, since everybody spent so much time talking about how difficult it is, it's probably a good idea to hear about people who are on another part of that learning curve for implementation.
Because we learn just as much from failures as we do from successes.
And it's important for us to hear those things.
And then the third and probably most important takeaway I got from this is that
There's a common agreement about what the instructional shifts in the teaching of science are here, but there's also a common agreement about the role and responsibility of the educator to carry and plan
for that implementation and the use of those instructional shifts.
And so I think the fact that people are being mindful about what that means and what it means to do that and do it correctly, not do it well.
There's a difference between doing it correctly and doing it well.
That was something I also heard from all the panelists.
So it was a great panel to hear from today and I'm very appreciative of that.
Okay.
Karen.
Karen Valdez.
Thank you very much for your presentation and for being here at the end of the day.
We really appreciate your time and your expertise and the opportunity that you've had in this early implementation.
I think this is about the why and helping people understand why we're doing science, why it's so important.
My father was an aeronautical engineer and I say he helped put us on the moon, right?
And so we have to really create the need, and so that's part of this campaign as you go forward.
In my prior district, we wrote integrated units of study around NGSS, and it was an industry in doing so.
But what we found was K-8, and then it was a K-8 district.
We really had to build the teacher's capacity to be able to do this, and capacity in the content, and capacity in the management.
And so when I looked at that one slide that said how many years have districts been implementing NGSS, there's a quarter of our districts, according to this chart, that haven't really started NGSS, or have started it maybe at the secondary level, but not at really the K-5 foundational level.
and in CAST measuring K-5, you know, on the assessment, it's gonna be really important.
So the role of the TOSA is really important, and I'm very proud, in the district I'm in right now, we have TOSAs for science, right?
And it's supporting them because I think that is something that as we go forward, somehow or another, some kind of infrastructure, because I think they're the ones that are gonna be really spirited in keeping and implementing deep implementation, supporting the teacher and the administrator for the look-fors,
and that the math practices pretty much match up to the science practices.
And so we have to show alignment and not another thing.
So anything you can do in support of integration, I think, really lowers the affective filter of stress that teachers or consumers might be having.
In addition to that, I want to say thank you to Trish and to Eileen for doing what they've done.
This is arduous work.
That's not a complaint.
I mean, it just really is.
And they are complex standards.
We can't discount that.
But we do appreciate what you're doing.
But I do think a focus on coaching to get deep implementation is what's going to be needed to build capacity.
Okay.
Any more comments?
This is information item.
Good.
I think, Barbara, you will need to discuss with, I think, Board Member Straus and Williams about the thing that Board Member Straus brought up about how to be more concrete in the implementation plan and rollout that we're going to have for this.
I think we need to take what we heard today and try and put it more into a planning mode
of how we can build this up from a few districts to many.
Yes, I'll connect with both board members and what I heard was recommendations, guidance for local implementation, like takeaways.
Just so the key thing, so it's not, we don't need another 1,200 pages, right?
So it's sort of the key points that we're learning and maybe we just cut and paste from some of them, what for leaders, for time, for professional development, capacity, you know, just some of the key pieces, I think, just as a guidance document in an information memo.
Okay, Board Member Williams.
Last thing.
I'm going to take a lot of personal prerogatives in my last two board meetings.
In this one, I want to say that we had two years of one-time funding for Common Core ELA and math and we haven't had any for science.
And so I want to pitch for the next administration, whichever SPI and
elected Governor Newsom that they consider California should be top in the nation in science.
Top in the nation in science.
And that they consider ways to divert funding, especially now that we have instructional materials.
This is the time to do funding targeted towards science for instructional materials and professional learning.
Okay.
Well, thank you very much for this presentation and the detail and we appreciate your coming.
And we're ready for public comment now, yes.
Will the following speakers please line up?
Jessica Salko and Andrea Ball.
Good afternoon, President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
I almost feel like saying good evening because the sun's coming down already.
If you ever wonder why I have such passion for this topic and why I'm so proud to work for the organization I work for, I think you just saw it with all the members who I work for presenting today.
They make me proud.
I did want to call out some other themes that I heard, we've been talking about the themes that we heard, which include support for professional learning, systemic approaches, building on what Member Valdez brought forward about how districts haven't, some districts are just getting started.
I happen to have a child in that district.
I'm a mom of an NGSS baby, not just a Common Core baby.
And also building on what Dr. Kerr said in regards to
looking forward and how, as you build your systems and your structures here at the state level and at your policy levels, incorporating science into those discussions, not as an add-on, but as an integrated part of that discussion.
Thank you.
Good evening, Andrea Ball on behalf of the California School Boards Association.
It is getting late.
And personal point of privilege, proud aunt of a middle school science teacher.
So I get to hear about that from her.
Anyway, we really appreciated this presentation.
And I just wanted to highlight some of the work CSBA has been doing and will continue to do.
in terms of providing board members with recommendations for how to do solid implementation.
One is that we've encouraged them, as part of their LCAPs, to develop an LCAP goal for their implementation of NGSS, to create committees to work on the NGSS implementation.
To the discussion earlier on the instructional materials,
The comment from board member Ortiz-Lacon on equity.
We've also been working with our boards on the local implementation and adoption of the science materials and encouraging them to have diversity and representation on the advisory committees that are going to select the committees at the local level.
So I shared with you a link in our memo, a recent brief that we put out to board members with these recommendations.
And we look forward to continuing to work with you and the board, I mean, and the department staff on this.
Thank you.
Okay, that completes our formal agenda.
So we have a choice, board members.
We can take item 20, which is SBE priorities today, or we can continue the meeting for tomorrow and take that up tomorrow.
So let's do it tomorrow.
Okay, we'll do it tomorrow.
So let me say that we... This is a continuance of our meeting.
We're not adjourning.
We will continue today's meeting at 8.30 a.m.
tomorrow and we'll start with a closed session where the board will hear and or take action on two cases, MSC and LAT versus the state.
So we're now in...
Continuation mode and we will.